Nếu có nhóm chuẩn bị xong rồi thì thôi,
mình bắt đầu luôn ha nhóm 5 bắt đầu được
chơi cái em.
Em thuộc nhóm 5 cô có nghe rõ không cô?
Ở nghe rõ.
Dạ vậy em xin phép bắt đầu trình bày luôn.
Giờ em trình bày bài.
Thực hành trước nha con,
xin phép chia sẻ màn hình.
Ok.
Dạ,
cô có nhìn thấy màn hình em chia sẻ không
còn.
Thấy rồi
Dạ,
một cái màn hình của em nó có bị mờ không
cô?
Không đỏ được.
Dạ dạ rồi em xin phép bắt đầu trình bày.
Dạ bài tập nhóm em làm có trình bày theo.
Ở 5 bước từ bước không tới bước 4,
sẽ tới bắt đầu trình bày.
Bước không chuẩn bị đầu vào là.
Bối cảnh doanh nghiệp và đặc doanh nghiệp
và đặc thuộc hệ sinh thái dịch vụ White
Station,
Westation là và đang khẳng định vị trí,
vì thế là một trong những chuỗi tổ hợp
dịch vụ trò chơi điện tử.
Bida và dịch vụ inb hàng đầu.
Với quy mô mở rộng nhanh chóng lên tới
hơn 30 chi nhánh trải dài khắp khu vực.
Tuy nhiên,
sự phát triển theo chiều rộng với tốc độ
cao đã kéo những thách thức cùng nhỏ về
mặt quản lý vận hành,
đặc biệt là sự thiếu đồng bộ về hạ tầng
công nghệ thông tin.
Mô hình hoạt động của Westation do trên
sự phân tán về mặt pháp lý mỗi chi nhánh
thường được đăng ký dưới hình thức là một
hộ kinh doanh cá thể riêng biệt.
Phương thức này mặc dù mang lại sự linh
hoạt tối đa về mặt.
Trong pháp lý tài chính.
Cơ sở và tối ưu hóa chi phí chi thuế tại
địa phương dừng lại cho thành một cơ ác
mộng đối với các kỹ sư quản trị hệ thống
và kiến trúc sư dữ liệu cụ thể thay vì
tồn tại một pháp nhân duy nhất.
Với một trung tâm dữ liệu hoặc một hệ
thống cơ sở tập trung thì hạ tầng của
Wise Station bị chia cắt thành 34.
Còn đào dương liệu riêng biệt.
Tự phần mảnh pháp lý này tạo ra một rào
cản to lớn trong việc thu thập,
thấp nhất và phân tích dữ liệu,
in quy mô toàn hệ thống do dữ liệu khách
hàng giao dịch và trạng thái hệ thống bị
cô lập.
Tại từng điểm,
ban lãnh đạo doanh nghiệp thiếu vắng một
tranh toàn cảnh về hiệu suất kinh doanh.
Hơn nữa,
mục tiêu nâng cấp chất lượng dịch vụ
thông qua công nghệ trí tuệ nhân tạo AI
và học máy nhằm tự động hóa quy trình dự
báo tài nguyên.
Cá nhân hóa trải nghiệm khách hàng và tối
ưu hóa chuỗi cung ứng việc sở hữu một hạ
tầng công nghệ thông tin thống nhất thích
hợp luồng dữ liệu liên tục và điều kiện
tiên quyết cấp bách.
Ủa cái này là em đang bắt,
em đang bắt đầu vào thực hành hay là đồ
Khảo sát.
án vậy sao con thấy giống đồ án quá trời.
Dạ bài.
thực hành.
Thực hành nhưng mà mình nãy giờ nó giống
như em đang nói về cơ sở hạ tầng mình cần
nâng cấp cho bên lớp dữ liệu luôn á.
Dạ em
Nếu mà các em,
nếu các em muốn làm thực hành thì các em
đánh thẳng vô cái bài toán phần mềm mình
muốn làm,
nói nãy giờ thì thí dụ các em bắt đầu từ
bối cảnh, á,
bối cảnh của một cái hệ thống phần mềm á
là nó đánh thẳng vô cái quy trình hoặc là
cái chức năng ứng dụng nền tảng nào nó
muốn phát triển.
Hoặc là nó muốn cải tiến.
Chứ mình không có nói vòng vòng đâu cái
thì mấy cái thuyết minh mà cái đề tài á
thường nó sẽ trải qua nhiều vòng.
Các nếu mà dòng đầu tiên á là đôi khi
người ta chỉ cho mình khoảng 10 trang,
nếu đúng 10 trang.
Tất cả về miu cái ý tưởng chung thì em ý
tưởng chính của cái đề tài để coi nó qua
được tới dòng tiếp theo để chuẩn bị hồ sơ
được hay không á.
Nên mình viết mấy cái thuyết minh đề tài
là các em nên viết theo phong cách đánh
Cho.
đánh gọn vô cái em.
Ừ.
Chứ không đánh dài dòng.
Không giúp lan man.
Thí dụ bây giờ các em muốn làm cái bài
thực hành đến vô cái hệ thống phần mềm
đúng không?
Phần mềm thì nó sẽ có quy trình chức năng
hoặc là những người dùng trọng tâm mục
tiêu.
Thì bây giờ nhóm mình trình bày cho cô
cái đó là được.
Dạ.
Và mình phải viết xung xung quanh xoay
quanh cái đó thôi,
Dạ nhóm em.
không viết lan mang bá dài nha, các em,
nhất là thời gian công cụ hiện tại là
công cụ ai rất là nhiều mình không có lạm
dụng nó,
các em mình phải dùng nó như công cụ và
nó phải viết vô đúng trọng tâm.
Chứ nó dưới quá dài là thứ nhất,
ngày xưa đã viết dài,
đã bị chê rồi thì bây giờ mới công cụ ai
có khả năng viết dài nhiều hơn nữa.
Thì đối với cách thức của đề tài là người
ta sẽ không có thích đâu.
Nâng cao và khi mà mình viết,
giết người ta nhìn vô cái văn phòng mình
viết,
người ta cũng biết là mình có nắm rõ cái
hướng đề tài mình muốn làm hay không.
Là các em sẽ giết rất là trọng tâm và
thúc súc tích chứ nó không có giết lăng
màng với lăng màng sao không đánh giá
logic tốt đâu.
Để bây giờ câu hỏi luôn,
nếu cái phạm vi như là nhóm đối tượng nè,
trích quy trình chức năng,
mục tiêu và nhóm muốn mục tiêu của cái hệ
thống phần mềm mà mình muốn triển khai á.
Lợi dụng là cái nào?
Dạ em nấu em chọn công nghệ là.
Mô hình nền tảng dữ liệu chuỗi thời gian,
tức là để mà áp dụng cho cái quy trình là
dự trình sắp xếp nhân,
sắp xếp nhân sự trong ca, tức là.
Sẽ vô vô vào những cái thời gian của quá
khứ.
Để mà mình dự đoán cái thời gian tương
lai để mà sắp xếp care cũng như là ví dụ
như là một ngày nào thì.
Ngày nào thì có lượng khách hàng đông thì.
Sắp xếp nhân sự theo nhân sự,
còn không ít thì sắp xếp nhân sự ít.
Nếu mà các em muốn nói vậy đó thì các em
nói về cái group,
quy trình thì quy trình hiện tại ở quy
trình và quy trình và nhóm cái nhóm người
dùng nào mà đang gặp hot và cái vấn đề cụ
thể trong cái quy trình này ở đây.
Thí dụ đây là quy trình quản lý nhân sự
đúng không?
Trong cái quy trình quản lý nhân sự thì
hiện tại block lâm là gì?
Thì lúc đó mình bắt đầu mới viết về cái
câu và dự đoán nhu cầu.
Dự đoán số lượng nhân sự vô chứ ở đây nếu
mà em chưa miêu tả vậy là nó không có
thuyết phục nhiều.
Người ta sẽ không thể nào mà bỏ chi phí
để mua dữ liệu,
xây dựng hệ thống để dự đoán ra một cái
giá trị mà nó người ta.
Giá giá trị không cần thiết nhưng cái giá
trị mà em giữ đoán được á,
nó phải là một cái giá trị người ta gọi
là dữ liệu vàng thông tin vàng á nó phải
là một cái thông tin vàng mà người ta cảm
nhận nó, người ta.
Thấy được đó là một thông tin vàng có giá
trị thì người ta mới sẽ chịu đầu tư em
chứ không phải không có xây dựng cái hệ
thống dự đoán khơi khơi mình không có mục
tiêu mà cái hoặc là nó đưa dự đoán ra một
cái giá trị mà cái giá trị đó chưa đủ
nặng để mà người ta đầu tư á.
Thì cái đó không phải là một ý tưởng hay
ha nên nếu mà các em muốn trình bày tính
cấp thiết đề tài ở đây hướng dẫn cho nhóm
đầu tiên là nhóm 5 này các nhóm sau các
em cũng chú ý khi mình muốn xin kinh phí
cho một cái đề tài.
Thì em phải làm sao,
làm nổi bật và đẩy mạnh cái vấn đề mà
người ta đang gặp phải và cái giá trị mà
em, cái phần mềm đang cung cấp lại á.
Nó thí dụ ở đây là.
Cái phần mềm ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo đi.
Có sự dự đoán ra được cái thông tin quan
trọng.
Mà nó có đủ sức nặng để người ta thấy cái
thông tin đó quan trọng và người ta sẽ
đầu tư cho nó.
Còn nếu cái giá trị đó không quan trọng
tại cái vấn đề này thường thường các bạn
sinh viên lần đầu tiên dưới cái minh đề
tài, các em hay bị đó.
Là các em không bấm sát thực tế hoặc là
các em không nối hoặc là có bám sát thực
tế nhưng mà cái vấn đề nó không phải là
vấn đề cấp thiết và cái giá trị mà em dự
đoán ra được á.
Nó không đủ sức thuyết phục cái người đầu
tư hoặc là người đó,
người ta thấy nó không quan trọng mà
không quan trọng để nhất thiết phải đầu
tư cho hệ thống như vậy nên khi mà các em
trình bày là các em phải nói vô được cái
vấn đề đó.
Từ ngữ cảnh, vấn đề,
giờ cần có thông tin gì hay cần giải pháp
gì và cái phần mềm mình sẽ cung cấp cái
giải pháp đó?
Nếu mà anh viết theo được thành một câu
chuyện liền mạch như vậy thì nó sẽ hiện
được tính cách thiết của đề tài.
Vậy bây giờ mình nói lại đi ha ở đây thì
theo cô hiểu,
nó là các em đang đánh vô cái quy trình
quản lý nhân sự thì cái quy trình quản lý
nhân sự hiện tại nó đang gặp ở công ty,
các em chọn nó đang gặp vấn đề gì?
Mà mình cần phải làm dự báo cái.
Số.
Nó thấy cái dự báo này,
cô chưa đọc được cái hệ tài dự báo nào và
dự báo số lượng nhân sự cần phân bố hết
nè.
Nên cô cũng không có rõ cái cropleme đây
lắm.
Và tùy cái bài này là em,
nhóm em đang làm theo cái file hướng dẫn
mà.
Từ bước không tới bước 12 con.
Thì cái bước đó là chỉ là kỹ thuật thôi,
em cái bước mà em đâu có đổ thừa cái đó
được.
Cái bước đó là cái phương pháp em thực
hiện,
còn cái ý tưởng hay là coi đang nói về ý
tưởng của các em mà.
Phương pháp mà mình làm như vậy,
bây giờ là cái tưởng đề tài của em nó
đang không có ý tưởng đề tài của mình,
nó phải hợp lý thì mình áp dụng cái
phương pháp đó mình sẽ ra vấn đề.
Cái phương pháp nó đâu có thể nó đâu có
nhảy ra được ý tưởng này của các em đâu.
Phương pháp hướng dẫn của cô làm gì có ý
tưởng này,
ý tưởng này cho các em tự suy nghĩ ra mà.
Và nhiệm vụ của mình khi mà các em viết
một cái thuyết minh đề tài học sinh kinh
phí là em phải bảo vệ cái ý tưởng của
mình.
Đúng không?
Chứ cái ý tưởng mình dự đoán cái số lượng
nhân viên cần phải trong tương lai,
cần phải phân bố.
Lại cho các em đưa ra mà.
Dạ do em cũng đang trình bày đi theo từng
bước,
từng bước như vậy đó con nên là cái phần
em nghĩ là cái chỗ bước một này thì em sẽ
Thì bây giờ bối cảnh,
ví dụ giống như bối cảnh kinh doanh và sự
đi thẳng vào luôn.
cấp thiết của đề tài nè.
Thì bây giờ em phải nói thẳng vô công ty
của các em chọn chứ nãy giờ từ vô mà bắt
đầu trong kỷ nguyên kinh tế số cạnh đang
khốc liệt trong ngành F B rồi viết.
Rất là dài,
nó nguyên một đoạn đầu tiên luôn.
Hoặc là em,
hoặc là cách em viết hoặc là cách em
trình bày nó chưa dấu vấn đề và ở đây
mình đang có 15 phút để cho trình bày cho
cả 2 hướng đề tài đường cung mới đó,
các em trình đánh trình bày vô trọng tâm.
Nhà hàng điều quý có nói không?
Thứ nhất là các em nói là cái vô trọng
tâm của mình là vô cái quy trình giống
quy trình của mình,
đây là quy trình quản lý nhân sự.
Và quy trình quản lý dân sự mình đang gặp
vấn đề gì? Em nói tên, vấn đề ra.
Và cái để giải quyết vấn đề này mình cần
có giải pháp gì hoặc là mình cần có thông
tin gì cần phải có?
Và nếu có nó thì nó sẽ hỗ trợ cái quy
giải quyết cái quy trình vấn đề của cái
quy trình này tốt hơn.
Em chỉ cần trình bày khoảng đối với theo
cái cấu trúc đó,
chỉ cần 5 6 câu là mình vô được vấn đề
luôn thôi mà còn nãy giờ mình trình bày
nó vẫn còn phía ngoài á,
chưa vô vấn đề luôn.
Hình như quý có nói không?
Dạ dạ em hiểu không?
Thí dụ cô là em nè,
em kéo vào các thông tin đề tài đi.
Bây giờ cô nhìn vô cái tên đề tài em nói,
em nói không. Cô không hiểu,
nhưng cô nhìn tên đề tài cô hiểu.
Thực chất là em ra dự báo lưu lượng khách
hàng thì khung giờ đúng không?
Dạ dạ đúng rồi.
Thì cái việc dự báo lưu lượng khách hàng
khung giờ thì bây giờ nếu mà em thực chất
nó không phải chỉ là quy trình quản lý
nhân sự đâu.
Mà nó có thể là quy trình về cái chiến
lược marketing và nâng cao dịch vụ chăm
sóc khách hàng nhiều hơn.
Tại cái này mình đang thực chất là lưu
lượng khách hàng thì mình chỉ sợ là nhân
viên mình không đủ để sợ cái dịch vụ của
mình không đáp ứng.
Đủ cái lượng khách hàng, nó tăng đột biến.
Thì bây giờ mình muốn có các cái chiến
lược không phải chỉ cần chiến lược nhân
sự hỗ trợ mà có thể là các cái chiến lược
quảng bá,
khuyến mãi khi mà vào những cái dịp đó để
mình kích cầu cho cái lượng khách hàng
đang tăng lên để người ta mua nhiều hơn
chẳng hạn.
Chứ nó cũng không phải là chỉ là quản lý
nhân sự nên nếu ở đây á thì các em có thể
đi tìm nếu mà mình dự báo được lưu lượng
khách hàng,
lưu lượng khách hàng trong tương lai đây
khung giờ mình hoạch định được cái lượng
khách hàng nó sẽ thay đổi và dự kiến như
vậy á,
thì mình nó sẽ giải quyết khá rất nhiều
vấn đề.
Thứ nhất là mình sẽ có thể nâng cao,
mình có thể kiểm soát nhân sự để nâng cao
dịch vụ chăm sóc khách hàng.
Thứ hai mình có thể đi kèm cái chiến lược
marketing hoặc là mình coi như marketing
hoặc là cái số lượng cái sản phẩm cái.
Cái lượng hàng nhập kho mình phải chuẩn
bị để đảm bảo lưu lượng khách hàng này
chẳng hạn.
Nếu mà mình kinh doanh bán hàng hay gì đó
ha thì nó sẽ có nhiều thông tin hướng dẫn
thì các em có thể coi nếu mà mình dự đoán
được lưu lượng khách hàng thì không giờ
thì mình có thể giải quyết được tất cả
các vấn đề gì.
Nếu cái giá trị của mình có thể ứng dụng
được cho nhiều vấn đề và mình nói ra được.
Nhiều giải quyết cho nhiều vấn đề đó luôn
á.
Thì mình sẽ tăng tính thuyết phục và tính
cấp thiết của đề tài,
không nhất thiết chỉ có phòng quản lý
nhân sự, người nói hết.
Phòng marketing người ta cũng thích,
phòng mà quản lý,
thí dụ nguyên liệu kho nếu đây là cách.
Cái công ty của các em cô không biết là
công ty gì ha quay station cô không rành
lắm.
Thì nếu giả sử đây là nhà hàng đi,
nhà hàng hay,
khách sạn hoặc là cái kinh doanh về sản
xuất, về cái lượng bán hàng đi.
Thí dụ mình biết cái khách lượng khách
hàng mua hàng trong cái.
Được nhiêu đó,
mình biết mình sẽ phải nhập hàng nhiều
hơn để đảm bảo tránh khi mà có khách hàng
đầu tiên người ta hổng có hàng để mua
chẳng hạn.
Thì khi đó là nó sẽ liên quan luôn cả bên
phần quản lý kho rồi bên quản lý,
bên quản lý kho và cái phần quản lý
marketing chứ không nhất thiết là cái quy
trình quản lý nhân sự cần.
Và nếu có tới 3 phòng,
ban cần cái dự án này thì cái dự án của
mình nó sẽ có khả năng xuất.
Cứ thuyết phục cao hơn.
Thì các em phải đánh vô cái chỗ đó,
thì ở đây khi mà mình xác định được cái
em mà xác định được cái đề tài mình dự
đoán được cái gì á thì các em phải tối đa
hóa cái ứng cái thông tin mình dự đoán
được.
Giả sử nếu mà có lưu lượng hàng thì mình
giải quyết được tất cả các vấn đề gì mình
liệt kê ra luôn.
Và khi trình bày thì các em sẽ liệt kê
hết tất cả các vấn đề đó ra.
Và nên chúng ta cần giải quyết luôn dự
đoán cái luồng luôn khách hàng này.
Và cái kỹ thuật ứng ứng dụng nền tảng
phần mềm em ở đây là các em dự kiến là
khai thác các cái dữ liệu nguồn dữ liệu
gì và sẽ xử lý cái phương pháp mà
selectinin là các cái thuật toán nào dựa
trên chuỗi thời gian.
Thí dụ như là LSTM BISCM,
đó là các thuật toán đức tin xử lý chuyên
cho chuỗi thời gian đó.
Còn nếu không,
các em chỉ cần nói như vậy là nó sẽ vô
trọng tâm rồi.
Biết kỹ từ lúc đó là cô biết em muốn làm
bài toán gì,
giải quyết vấn đề gì và mình đã nắm được
cái dữ liệu đầu vào mình gì cho cái
phương pháp này và kỹ thuật gì.
Em biết được các kỹ thuật mà nó sai,
dùng cho cái bài toán này luôn.
Không cần nói nhiều.
Dạ nhật tức là cái giới hạn của cái bài
thực hành là.
Áp dụng một cái công nghệ mới mà mình
cũng không có nhất thiết là phải đi.
Ví dụ như là cái công nghệ mới đó,
nó sẽ giải quyết được nhiều bài toán chứ
cũng không có cần phải là đi sâu vô một
cái.
Một cái quy trình gì cụ thể sao con?
Không cần đi sâu vô một quy trình cụ thể
sao là các em đánh vô bộ quy trình.
Thì cái bài toán này của em nhưng mà cái
em không hiểu cô nó ha,
nó là giải quyết các vấn đề và nó sẽ là
giải quyết các quy trình.
Và em sẽ phải nêu ngắn gọn các quy trình.
Khi các em hình dung là mình là nhóm công
nghệ thông tin.
Chứ mình không phải là nhóm bạch định
nhân sự hay là cái quản trị,
quản trị kinh doanh.
Mình đâu cần phải quản trị kinh doanh,
đưa ra cái quy trình đó đâu?
Người ta có quy trình nói sẵn rồi,
công ty mình là người ta có quy trình và
cái đội ngũ công ty,
cái đội ngũ IT của mình phải đi theo cái
quy trình của người ta.
Nên khi mà các em viết cách thuyết minh
đề tài này á cái người ta muốn thí dụ các
em kinh nghiệm của cô mà làm làm cái đề
tài nè,
cái người ta muốn là tôi biết anh chị có
hiểu cái vấn đề hiểu kỹ thuật và có khả
năng về kỹ thuật đó để.
Tính khai được hệ thống hay không?
Chứ người ta không cần em biết là em phải
trình bày chi tiết về cái quy trình này
và diễn giải cho người ta.
Tôi là người vận hành quy trình khách
hàng của các em chính là người vận hành
quy trình rồi.
Nên thí dụ trong cái thuyết minh đề tài á
các em phải nhớ là phải viết ngắn gọn,
viết cái người ta muốn.
Và cái mục tiêu của mình là gì?
Tình nhân mơ chứ không phải em trình bày
cái quy trình mấy em đừng có làm như cái
quy trình của công ty.
Mình vẫn phải hiểu quy trình để mình
triển khai,
sau này mình triển khai cho người ta,
nhưng khi em trình bày nó không phải là
mục tiêu chính,
mục tiêu chính cái chính là cái bài toán
công nghệ thông tin mà các em muốn làm á.
Và em phải trình bày cái bài toán công
nghệ thông tin để người ta thấy được năng
lực.
Chuyên môn của em có thể triển khai cái
hệ thống này, cái người ta cần là cái đó.
Chứ người ta chỉ sợ người ta chi tiền cho
em rồi em không biết làm.
Dạ tức là.
Nếu mà.
Nghĩa là em giống em đang bị hiểu sai cái
giới hạn của cái.
Cái đề tả cái bài thực hành nó con.
Tức là bây giờ cái.
Yêu cầu của bà thực hành là mình sẽ áp
dụng một cái công nghệ mới vô cho.
Tôi cho phục để phục vụ cho cái quy trình
để phục vụ cho các quy trình mà đang có
của doanh nghiệp cũng đúng không cô?
Đúng rồi.
Em là đội IT mà.
Chứ nên đâu phải là giám đốc điều hành
của họ đâu mà em có quyền thay đổi cái
quy trình nghiệp vụ vận hành của họ.
nếu.
Dạ để em xin phép qua bài trình bày bài
đồ ấy, cái bà này cũng sẽ sửa lại.
Nhưng mà quý cô ví cô ví dụ cái hồi nãy
là nếu mà hình dung cái đó không.
Hình dung được các tình bạn,
cái thuyết minh mà anh cần phải đánh vô
cái gì chưa?
Dạ tức là bây giờ nhóm em chọn cái đề tài
là.
Ứng dụng cái mô hình nền tảng chuỗi thời
gian này để dự báo lưu lượng cách theo
khung giờ thì với cái công nghệ này.
Có thể là áp dụng được cho những cái quy
trình nào như là ở doanh nghiệp như là.
Marketing hay là điều phối lại nhưng sự
theo cái thời gian đó thì mình sẽ trình
bày xanh xoay quanh cái công nghệ đó.
Mình xoay quanh vô cái bài toán dự đoán
lưu lượng khách hàng theo khung giờ.
Còn cái ứng dụng mô hình nền tảng chữ
thời gian,
cái cũng chưa chắc em cái câu ví dụ là mô
hình nền tảng chữ thời gian ở đây,
có thể nói là cái kỹ thuật cái này cô ví
dụ như ha,
khi mà các em làm một cái bài toán làm
cái thuyết minh đề tài á.
Cái mà khách hàng muốn là người người ta
chỉ cần biết là anh áp dụng công nghệ mới
và anh sẽ giải quyết cho tôi cái gì?
Thí dụ ở đây em dự đoán được cái lưu
lượng khách hàng trong tương lai cho họ.
Là họ, cái họ cần,
họ chỉ cần cái đó thôi và họ chỉ cần mình
là dự đoán luôn được khách hàng.
Làm sao chính xác nhất chứ được dự đoán
sai để họ đưa lên kế hoạch định kế hoạch
quản lý marketing, hòa nhập hàng sai.
Người ta chỉ sợ cái đó thôi.
Còn em sử dụng kỹ thuật gì á?
Người là người ta,
nếu mà có chuyên người ta có chuyên môn
hoặc người ta muốn dùng marketing thì
người ta có thể có một số quan tâm và
người ta sẽ đặt ra một số cái quy định kỹ
thuật cơ bản.
Nhưng mà nếu mà khách hàng mà không
chuyên,
đôi khi người ta chỉ cần kết quả thôi,
người ta chẳng cần biết em muốn dùng kỹ
thuật gì.
Em miễn cho tôi kết quả đúng và trẻ tốt
là được.
Thì cái phần kỹ thuật này lúc mà mình nêu
lên á thì nó có 2 xu hướng.
Một là deal hoặc là không nêu.
Do ở đây thì cái em nêu nó cũng vẫn ổn.
Nhưng mà cái này cô nói xa hơn,
thí dụ mà mình thật sự triển khai á đối
với các đề tài triển khai á mà mình nếu
mà nhóm.
Có kinh nghiệm và đã dừng trải đã từng
làm thử rồi mà cái dự án tương tự biết nó
làm được á thì giống như cô thì cô sẽ
viết thẳng luôn giống như em ở chiếc cái
áp dụng mô hình nền tảng chủ thời gian
hoặc mô hình để thanh niên hoặc là mô
hình học tăng cường gì đó.
Là tự cô sẽ biết thẳng luôn,
tại cô đã từng test thí nghiệm và không
biết cái nó gọi là khảo sát qua rồi.
Hay biết nó tiềm năng và có thể triển
khai được,
nhưng nếu mà đối với các cái dự án mà
mình.
Gọi là mới chưa có hoặc là chưa có ai làm
bao giờ và mình chưa có khảo sát kỹ,
mình chưa có test thử là mình có khảo sát
các kỹ thuật tiềm năng rồi.
Nhưng mà mình chưa có chạy về vô thử thì
đôi khi mình không dám viết.
Hoặc là mình viết ra rồi mình sẽ phải đi
thêm một câu là danh các cái phương pháp
nghệ thuật và thay các phương pháp kỹ
thuật tương đương.
Trong trường hợp lúc mà mình chạy triển
khai mình chạy á.
Nó không ra được như mình **** muốn,
có nghĩa là mình nghĩ rằng kỹ thuật đó
sao cho kết quả tốt,
nhưng mà lúc mà chạy rồi mới thấy nó
không ra được.
Hoặc là chạy ra kết quả không tốt,
cái chuyện này rồi bên dân,
bên dữ liệu làm gặp hoài.
Nghĩ là một chuyện trả kết quả ra là một
chuyện khác.
Chưa trả, chưa biết kết quả.
Nên người ta sẽ sợ rủi ro,
sợ mình lỡ mình hứa rồi,
khúc sau là mình không dùng kỹ thuật đó,
mình đổi kỹ thuật khác mà người ta không
chịu.
Thì nếu mà cái dự cái này tôi nói thêm
thôi,
còn ở đây cái em ghi cũng vẫn được tại
mình không có bị áp lực là mình phải
nghiệm thu đề tài và các em chỉ cần khảo
sát được các công nghệ nền tảng hoặc là
các công nghệ tiềm năng mà rồi đánh giá
tốt theo các bài toán các em chọn và các
em tìm hiểu nó được á.
Là cô đã đánh giá cao rồi,
nhưng mà nếu mà giả sử các nhóm sau này
mà cô cái này cô hơi xa phát triển rất
đẹp gọi là cao cấp hơn chút xíu á.
Mình nghĩ tới cái vấn đề nghiệm thu là
mình phải viết.
Cái thứ quần đề tài làm sao cho nó?
Biết cách chiết làm sao cho nó an toàn
nhất?
Có dự án dự, có phương án dự phòng.
Chứ nó mà không,
mình cái này mình không biết rõ nha.
Khúc cuối mà mình đổi kỹ thuật á,
người ta không chịu. Mình cũng mệt.
Mà do khi khách hàng có chuyên mua 10 IT,
mình giải thích người ta nghe thì là càng
tốt mà người ta không nghe.
Mình thì người ta lại nói là mình không
đáp ứng yêu cầu trong cái hợp đồng theo
thuyết minh.
Nếu mà.
Dạ, nếu mà cái bài của nhóm em.
Áp dụng cái công nghệ này thì nếu mà em
trình bày là nó chỉ là dùng để dự đoán,
còn cái việc mà.
Hình như là ra quốc ra ra quyết định cái
việc mà ra quyết định là không phải là
Không, mình ghi vẫn được em cái.
Cho quyết định thì.
công nghệ ra quyết định mà vẫn sẽ là do
con người công người quyết định.
Không có *** phải là con mà được ý hiểu
không?
Còn cái công nghệ này thì nó chỉ sẽ phục
vụ cho việc.
Không cái nào cũng vậy,
em không có ứng dụng hay ai nào quyết
định thay con người hết em.
Ý cô nói nãy giờ là khi mà các em nhất
trí thức về đề tài,
thí dụ em gọi là nền tảng chỗ thời gian.
Em áp dụng các kỹ thuật mô hình liên miên
về chuỗi thời gian khác nhau như hồi nãy
thể.
cô đi cũng 4 5 cái.
Tận
Ví dụ,
ở đây cái em ghi cái mình sử dụng cái này
đi, nhưng mà tới cái lúc mà mình em test,
em dự đoán ra cái lượng thời gian,
cái nó kết quả nó không có đẹp và em thử
kỹ thuật khác giống như em thử cái thực
transformers chẳng hạn.
Trong Fallanning nó mới cho kết quả tốt.
Thì lúc đó mình đổi kỹ thuật.
Tìm hiểu câu nói không cái chứ đâu phải
là mình nó kỹ thuật phần mềm.
Giờ giờ
Khi phải
Kỹ thuật phần mềm nó không có phải nó
giống như em xây dựng một cái hệ thống
phần mềm bình thường là em áp dụng kỹ
thuật mà nó chạy được là để nó chạy được
cơ nha các em.
Đối với các ứng dụng máy AI và dữ liệu là
cái mô đồ có rất nhiều cách để triển khai.
Và khi mà người triển khai.
Khai là một phải test tốt nhất từ năm tới
10 cái phương pháp trở lên để coi cái
phương pháp nào cho kết quả tốt nhất.
Rồi mình mới dự kiến là mình phải chứng
minh tại vì cái này trong ngành lĩnh vực
bên dữ liệu hay ai rồi.
Tại vì người ta cũng sẽ đọc ra các kỹ
thuật khác,
người ta sẽ hỏi tại sao không dùng kỹ
thuật này.
Thì phần lớn tất cả các dự án mà triển
khai cái này thì phải test thử trên rất
nhiều mô hình dự đoán khác nhau.
Nêu và mô hình dự đoán nào cho kết quả
tốt nhất và ổn định nhất thì người ta mới
build lên, người ta trả thử.
Và người ta sẽ cải tiến dần theo thời
gian nữa.
Thí dụ ở đây,
thí dụ lúc ở đây em triển khai thường đối
với các bạn sinh viên bắt đầu,
các bạn có thể chạy 4 5 cái phương pháp
bay lai đi,
sau đó bay chạy một trận một cái.
Thì cái chọn đó có nghĩa là em trải thực
nghiệm rồi em mới biết cái nào cho kết
quả tốt thì em mới chọn.
Và mình nên lúc mà cái viết mấy cái tên
đề tài này thường thường là người ta viết
tên của một nhánh kỹ thuật chứ người ta
không có dám nêu một kỹ thuật của cụ thể
hay tên toán cụ thể nào cả.
Nếu chữa các thực nghiệm thì không ai dám
điều hết á chưa chạy, chưa biết kết quả.
Nhưng với câu nói không?
Những cái câu nói không kỹ thuật phát
triển.
Dạ tức là tức là nếu mà.
Cái gì giống em có thể?
Đi theo cái trình bày lại theo cái hướng
là chọn cái nhánh công nghệ thay vì đây
em đeo trực tiếp là nêu cụ thể một cái là
mô hình nền tảng cho thời gian thì em sẽ
nêu tên lên cái nhóm cái nhánh của cái
nhánh của cái nhánh.
Hiện này.
Xong rồi
Ừ, có thể nêu được,
nếu như các em nói dựa trên nền tảng
trang Phallanine và Deep Linin vậy đó,
thường người ta sẽ gom các nhánh kỹ thuật
tiềm năng.
Lúc đó là mình thấy an toàn hơn khi mà
các em đặt tên người ta.
Dạ em hiểu rồi con.
Em xin phép qua bài đồ án,
còn bài này em xin phép trở lại với nhóm
Ok.
sau dạ.
Rồi qua đầu ấy nè em.
Dạ em xin phép trình bày bài đồ án của.
Dạ đầu tiên là bước không là xác định
phạm vi đề xuất.
Công tắc bối cảnh vấn đề Westation là một
hệ sinh thái dịch vụ tích hợp đa nền tảng,
bao gồm các mảng kinh doanh cốt lõi.
Cho mình.
Về phim thích cầu lông và húp SB chỉ.
Chủ nhật chủ đề 2 năm quy mô của Wiss
Totion đã phát triển tốt từ 22 lên 3 4
chi nhánh cổ rộng khắp của huyện tại
thành phố Hồ Chí Minh.
Phạm vi đầu tư hạ tầng cốt lõi để giải
quyết bài toán cốt lõi về sự phân mảnh hệ
thống giữa dự án này không đề xuất mua
sắm thiết bị phần cứng và rè rẹt tại từng
chi nhánh. Thay vào đó,
dự án tập trung ngân sách để.
Đầu tư xây dựng.
Năng lực 2 năng lực hạ tầng ở 2.
Ở hai phương lớp là.
Lớp 4 và lớp 5.
Ở lớp 4 thì xây dựng hệ thống cổ giao
tiếp tích.
Ứng dụng tập trung để kết nối và chuẩn
hóa luồng giao tiếp giữa các phần mềm
hiện hữu, triển khai kiến trúc.
Dịch vụ quy mô và hệ thống.
Quan điểm hệ thống định danh tập trung để
đồng nhất tài khoản khách hàng trên toàn
bộ hệ sinh thái.
Ở lớp 5 thì xây dựng kho dữ liệu tập
trung, có khả năng thu thập,
xử lý luồng dữ liệu.
Tự động từ 34 chi nhánh triển khai hệ
thống báo cáo thông minh theo thời gian
thực.
Đối tượng thụ hưởng và mục tiêu thời gian.
Cũng có đối tượng thụ hưởng bao gồm là
ban điều hành và quản lý có khả năng ra
quyết định dựa trên dữ liệu nhờ báo cáo
doanh thu tồn kho thời gian thực.
Nhân viên trí nhắn xóa bỏ 100% công việc
chụp liệu báo cáo SEC thủ công.
Giải phóng hàng chục giờ công mỗi ca trực.
Đối với khách hàng là trải nghiệm dịch vụ
liền mạch với một tài khoản duy nhất để
tích điểm và thanh toán cho tất cả các
dịch vụ tại Westation.
Thời gian triển khai và lộ trình 12 tháng
chia làm 4 giai đoạn theo mô hình phát
triển linh hoạt, triển khai cuốn chiếu.
Cho đoạn 1 là từ tháng 1 và tháng 3 là
thiết lập hình móng,
khảo sát toàn bộ databai chi nhánh,
thiết lập môi trường container trên điện
toán đám mây,
triển khai cấu trúc lõi của cổng giao
tiếp ứng dụng,
tập trung vào kho dữ liệu hội tụ.
Cấu hình mạng an toàn giai đoạn hoa.
Tích hợp và tích hợp và app nội bộ sử
dụng luồng dữ liệu đồng bộ tự động mỗi 15
phút triển khai quản trị dữ liệu chủ
chuẩn hóa danh mục,
ra mắt app vận hành nội bộ chốt cao và
các sự cố.
Giai đoạn 3 định danh và phân tích triển
khai hệ thống định danh dùng chung,
ra mắt hệ thống PR deadboard thời gian
thực,
chạy thử nghiệm tại 3 chỉ tranh lớn nhất.
Giai đoạn 4 là Go like và tối ưu mở rộng
hệ thống xuống.
Mở rộng hệ thống xuống 4 chi nhánh còn
lại.
Tổ chức đào tạo người dùng thiết lập quy
trình giám sát vận hành và bảo mật.
Ở phần khảo sát hiện trạng hạ tầng xuân
có số liệu,
hệ thống vận hành hiện tại phụ thuộc hoàn
toàn vào sức người, vì thiếu hụt một.
Cả tuần số tập trung đã bộc lộ những con
số đáng báo động trên cả 5 phân lớp.
Tính toán và kết nối ở lớp,
tính toán và kết nối, máy chủ cục bộ,
bộ chi nhánh được trang bị một.
Mình trình bày ngắn gọn thôi các em,
thí dụ bây giờ là theo cái khung sườn,
tiêu chí hoặc là chuẩn bị dữ liệu đồ vàng,
chuẩn bị đầu vào.
Thí dụ tên của trường đại học,
cái đó bên là thực hành đồ án á,
là khảo sát hiện trạng mới trước mình đã
có rồi, rồi các.
Vấn đề rủi ro mình không,
nếu không đầu tư thì ở đây em cũng có thể
nói đã nói sơ qua rồi.
Bây giờ mình nói tóm tắt lại,
em xài đồ án khoa học của em có bao nhiêu
mục tiêu đã đặt ra và bây giờ.
Mình dự kiến là các em sẽ có hướng những
cái KP hạ tầng nào.
Là cái này,
bữa trước là mình cũng đã trình bày một
Dạ vậy em.
phần rồi.
Ở đây mình có mấy mục tiêu.
Mục tiêu tương ứng với KPI.
Các em có viết theo hướng đó không?
Dạ chị em.
Trong theo cái hướng dẫn phải hướng dẫn
của cô đúng không cô?
Thì theo 3 hướng dẫn là mình trình bày là
em viết trong báo cáo,
còn bây giờ đang là trình bày mà các em.
Kem trình bày em hiểu khi mà câu hỏi của
vấn đề các em hiểu là các em trả lời thôi
chứ đâu phải là mình chỉ đọc biết đọc báo
cáo mình hổng có hiểu cái vấn đề.
Cái này cô đang hỏi những nội dung trong
báo cáo đó.
Và mình sắp xếp,
trả lời vấn đáp cho sao cho hợp lý,
một cái em thi cũng vậy á?
Thế bây giờ,
câu hỏi có bao nhiêu mục tiêu nè,
em có mấy KPI,
KPI này ứng với mục tiêu nào?
Câu hỏi đơn giản theo báo cáo của mình mà.
Dạ ở đây thì.
Còn nếu mà các em,
các em không trả lời được câu đó có nghĩa
là cái thiết minh đẹp,
một là các em dưới thuyết minh đề tài nó
chưa có hợp lý.
Thứ hai là các em không nắm rõ được nội
dung của mình.
Và nhóm em đang có đi theo 8 mục tiêu với.
SKBI tương ứng là.
8 mục tiêu nào đâu,
mục nào để 8 mục tiêu đó đâu,
cái ý chính của cái 8 mục tiêu nó ở đâu?
Dạ, ở đây em có em có để cái bảng này.
Thì cái mục tiêu ở một trên với mục tiêu
cam kết này khác nhau chỗ nào?
Hoặc là nó tương thích với nhau như thế
nào?
Tức là 2 cái lớp năng lực em lớp mà cái
mục tiêu này nó phải bám sát vào 2 cái
lớp năng lực mà nhắc em chọn đầu tư hay
sao?
Bưng các em phải viết,
nó sẽ phải có liên mạch với nhau chứ.
Em đã chọn năng lực đầu tư nào thì cái
mục tiêu của em phải đi theo cái mục năng
lực đó.
Rồi các thế giữa đây,
kem ghi là mục tiêu cam kết thực chất
cũng không nếu mình gọi chứ mục tiêu cam
kết nó nó cũng hổng có đúng lắm.
Cái này nó giống như là KP em đăng ký.
Theo cam kết phía trên.
Thí dụ em nói là em hứa rằng em xây dựng
giống như cái bây giờ cụ thể hơn,
giống như cái mô bài thực hành múa mình
cũng phải hứa vậy đó.
Em hứa là em sẽ xây dựng cái mô đồ dự án,
mua đồ dự đoán cái lưu lượng.
Cái khách hàng có độ chính xác và trên.
70% đi trên 70%.
Và có độ độ ổn định cao trên nhiều cái
ngữ cảnh ứng dụng khác nhau.
Hoặc là mình có là có cái độ chính xác
cải thiện cho hơn các phương pháp Bay
Light khoảng từ 10 đến 20% và có cái.
Độ ổn định trên địa phương,
độ ổn định trong một khoảng thời gian ổn
định tốt trên địa phương pháp hoặc trên
nhiều biến động dữ liệu khác nhau trên
một khoảng thời gian dài khác nhau.
Khi mà mình đưa ra các mục tiêu miêu tả
bằng lời như vậy thì người ta có cái đó
là mình miêu tả để cho người ta dễ hình
dung ha xong rồi bắt đầu vô KPI,
mình sẽ chi tiết cái đó ra để cho người
ta thấy thí dụ cái mục tiêu đầu tiên nâng
cao độ chính xác hay là hiệu suất hoạt
động của cái môn.
Bộ đồ dự đoán thì ở đây KPA ở đây,
chúng tôi sẽ dùng các độ đo như là phiếu
proxy recon để đây là những độ đo đo hiệu
suất của model,
và chúng tôi sử dụng sử dụng cái đầu đo
này và nó sẽ so sánh từ.
4 đến 4 đến 5 phương pháp Bella hiện tại
và nó sẽ cải thiện.
Chúng tôi hứa rằng cái phục mua đồ của
chúng tôi xây dựng nên nó sẽ tốt hơn các
phương pháp Bela hiện tại và cải thiện
tối thiểu 10% thì đó là loại cam kết của
em.
Rồi mình sẽ đi cụ thể phía trên rồi mình
ở trên mục tiêu,
mình có một cái ý là có chả ổn định trong
cho nhiều người cảnh dữ liệu khác nhau,
biến đổi dữ liệu khác nhau hoặc là mốc
thời gian khác nhau vậy đó thì ở dưới đây
mình sẽ nói là mình sẽ.
Tiến hành thực nghiệm trên bộ dữ liệu
trên bao nhiêu phiên bản bộ dữ liệu và dự
kiến các bộ dữ liệu thực nghiệm ở đây và
mình sẽ dự kiến trả trên 4 bộ data sét
khác nhau và mình sẽ dự đoán ra 4 mốc
thời gian mình sẽ tạo ra 4 ngữ cảnh phang
thời gian và mình sẽ test cái hệ thống
của mình.
Thông qua 4 này là xếp và các 4 nguyên
cảnh thời gian đó với cái độ chênh lệch
không quá và cái biến thiên Delta không
quá 10% chẳng hạn.
Thì cái đó là cái mà mình miêu tả rõ ràng.
Theo mục tiêu mình cam kết.
Giống như cái mục tiêu là một cái văn văn
để mà nói để cho người ta dễ hình dung á,
Dạ vậy em.
còn cái KPA nó chính là cái thông số kỹ
thuật để mình hứa và để là nó cũng chính
là cái giá trị doanh thu sau này của mình
luôn.
Và vậy,
em xin phép tổ trình bày cái phần mục
tiêu này là.
Dạ.
Mục tiêu mà nhận à,
mục tiêu cam kết là đối với.
Sẵn sàng à hình.
À,
hiện hiện trạng là tích sẵn sàng là không
xác định thời gian gián đoạn cao, tỉ lệ.
Điểm sự cố duy nhất bằng 100% mục tiêu
cam kết là đạt up thêm lớn hơn 99,
99% cho co cổng giao tiếp ứng dụng tập
trung và dịch vụ quản lý định danh lỗi.
Chỉ cho phép giao tham tối đa 5 phút mỗi
năm.
Căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu là báo cáo
uptime từ điện toán đám mây rovider liên
tục hàng tháng.
Ở nhóm tốc độ, tốc độ khôi phục.
Tình trạng là từ 12 giờ đến 24 giờ,
phải cử IT onsite, xử lý sự cố máy chủ lý,
mục tiêu cam kết là giảm xuống.
Ở hơn 15 phút.
Hệ thống tự động,
hệ thống tự động phục hồi qua 28S,
kiểm tra trạng thái.
Căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu là lock hệ
thống KTMS ghi nhận thời gian tự động
resort bộ chứa bị lỗi.
Cái nhóm khả năng giám sát hiện trạng là
từ.
4 đến 8 giờ cho nhân viên chi nhánh báo
lỗi của Zalo.
Mục tiêu cam kết là giảm xuống nhỏ hơn 5
phút hệ thống Montorin cảnh báo tự động
qua đo lường và phản hồi về Slack.
Là tìm căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu là
hệ thống.
Kia và hệ thống cảnh báo ghi nhận thời
điểm bắn ra lớp.
Ở đối với nhóm.
Phục hồi dữ liệu thì tình trạng là Big
Cup thủ công bằng tay ra trước B để phục
hồi bằng 24 giờ.
Thời gian phục hồi lại 4 8 giờ.
Về mục tiêu và cam kết là để phục hồi nhỏ
hơn 15 phút và thời gian phục hồi là nhỏ
hơn 4 giờ,
tự động khôi phục bản sao lưu cho các tam
quan trọng yếu.
Về căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu là đánh
giá qua diễn tập phục hồi thảm họa định
kỳ mỗi 6 tháng.
Mục tiêu tham là.
Từ mục tiêu thứ 5 là độ trễ dữ liệu.
Từ 24 tiền trạng là từ 24 giờ đến 18 giờ
phụ thuộc vào tốc độ gói xe của con người.
Mục tiêu cam kết là độ trễ nhỏ hơn 5 phút
dữ liệu doanh thu nhảy số trực tiếp trên
màn hình Dadboard.
Căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu sẽ.
Cửa vào quá trình đối soát dấu thời gian
giữa giao dịch tại chi nhánh và dữ liệu
hiển thị trên kho dữ liệu hội tụ.
Điều thứ 6 là tuân thủ bảo mật và dữ liệu
cá nhân nhạy cảm.
Ở hiện trạng là 0% dữ liệu mã hóa.
Xin tải lên like test qua Zalo,
căn mục tiêu cam kết là đạt 100% dữ liệu
nhạy cảm được mã hóa khi lưu trữ và.
Cái truyền tải.
Lóc hệ thống lưu trữ tập trung bất biến
tối thiểu 1 năm.
Căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu là đánh giá
qua bảng báo cáo kiểm thử xâm nhập và
kiểm toán bảo mật định kỳ.
Mục tiêu thứ 7 là tốc độ triển khai.
5 đến 7 ngày cho mỗi lần mỗi chi nhánh
mới.
Hiện trạng là 5 đến 10 ngày cho mỗi lần
một chi nhánh mới.
Cam kết là trở xuống ở 4 giờ cho mỗi chi
nhánh mới.
Ví dụ hoàn toàn hạ tầng dưới dạng,
dưới dạng mã, hạ tầng dạng mã bằng.
Terraform.
Căn cứ đo lường và nghiệm thu là giai
đoạn thực tế khi mở rộng chi nhánh thứ 35.
Mục tiêu thứ 8.
Rồi bây giờ cô nói này cái nãy giờ kem
kéo khúc cuối là cô thấy rồi mấy cái KPI
này sử dụng nội đo phải sử dụng nên sự
đọc các cái tài liệu về quản lý dự án để
mình lấy các cái độ đo.
Đã được chuẩn hóa và nó có cái tên nào đo
cụ thể nó chỉ trong slide của cũng có ví
dụ một tên một vài độ đo đó các em.
Và em dụng nó đầu đo đầu đo nó sẽ phức
tạp và nó có công thức tính và nó đã được
chuẩn hóa thành cái quy định kỹ thuật rõ
ràng rồi.
Thì mình dùng hoặc là mình sử dụng nó
trong cái mục tiêu và cái KPI đó cái
phương pháp đo lường của mình thì nó mới
thuyết phục chứ mình độ đo của mình ở đây
ra đó.
Ở đây cái em toàn dụng lời không à cái em.
Năm có tên.
Thì thứ,
cái đó nó không có người ta không đánh
giá cao về khả năng kỹ thuật của em đâu.
Hình như có nói không và sử dụng độ đo đó
và độ đo đó theo tiêu chí nào,
À, tôi làm mình phải.
tài liệu nào,
sách nào hay là cái quy định nào thì phải
sai tại sao tới nó là.
Tức giận á, tài liệu thông cảm cho nó đó.
Ví dụ em ở đây cái tốc độ triển khai thì
tốc độ triển khai là cái gì?
Ở đây có trong một số cái phương pháp đồ
đo thì người ta có sử dụng đồ đo thời
gian,
nhưng mà độ đo thời gian nó sẽ đi kèm với
một kỹ thuật cụ thể.
Chứ mà mình nêu chung chung như vậy thì
sau này rất là khó nghiệm thu và nó không
có cái chuẩn.
Đây có nhiều cái đồ đo mà người ta vẫn
còn tranh cãi luôn.
Thí dụ cùng một cái tốc độ triển khai
model đi thì có người là người ta sẽ tính
cái tốc độ build từ dữ liệu thôi,
nhưng mà trong đó nó có các kỹ thuật.
Như là Christop hiệu chỉnh 5 số rồi.
Linh tinh bên trong nữa.
Và với mỗi một cái bước hợp tác lựa chọn
khác nhau thì cái thời gian,
cái tính đo lường đó là nhảy khác nhau.
Tại vì có những cái nó chạm một lần rồi
ra có những cái phải chạy nọ lần nó mới
ra kết quả thì cái thời gian nó sẽ bị dội
lên và người ta có nhiều cách đo khác
nhau, có người ta đo từ mốc này,
có người ta đo.
Có nhiều người ta lại đo từ 1 khác,
chẳng hạn nên nếu mà các em đã sử dụng
các KPI đo lường ở đây á thì nên đọc các
hệ thống KPI đo lường,
thông dụng kỹ thuật và đã được công nhận
chung rồi.
Nó ta gọi là chuẩn chung rồi đó.
Cái chuẩn đã được chứng minh rồi thì bây
giờ chúng tôi chỉ sử dụng cái chuẩn đó
thôi.
Các độ đo để có chuẩn hết cho game chuẩn
hoặc là sẽ có quy định,
còn nếu mà em là người đưa ra cái độ đo
đó thì em phải chứng minh tính khoa học,
tính độ tính toán chứng minh cái nền tảng
và cái độ đo này nó khả thi,
nó có ích và nó tốt hơn.
Nó tốt ở cái ngành nào đó thì mới thuyết
phục người ta sử dụng cái độ đo đó được
chẳng hạn.
Mà ở đây,
thí dụ mà nhớ mình sữa là kem ở đây kem
cũng xác định được các cái yếu tố mà mình
muốn đo lường rồi đó,
nhưng mà hãy tìm cách độ đo theo các tiêu
chí mà các em đặt ra và nó có tên độ đo
cụ thể.
Có chuẩn độ đo luôn thì sử dụng thế đó.
Hiểu có nói luôn.
Dạ dạ em hiểu.
Mình chưa gửi ứng dụng lý thuyết ở đây
trước đây bên nhóm mình lúc mà kem ở tài
sản của nó luôn mới vừa hội đồng của cái
bên phân hệ của mình.
Là về khối lượng tốt nghiệp á là kem sử
dụng các độ đo mà các em cũng nguyên dụng
lợi trang như vậy luôn và các bạn đó là.
Kèm và hiểu á là mấy cái độ đo mày dùng
lại miêu tả kiểu đó là cái đó là bên em
cơm mấy công cụ quen ai mà mình kiểu mình
hỏi chung chung á nó hay đưa ra công thức
độ đo bằng lời kiểu đó lắm em.
Nhìn thị logic đó nhưng mà người ta không
có chấp nhận sử dụng cái đâu đó đâu.
Cái đáng nếu mà mình dùng thì nó phải có
công thức toán học để nó tính toán rõ
ràng.
Theo đúng quy trình công thức toán học
luôn mà các bạn, các em mà lập luận.
Lúc đó bạn kia lập luận là em sợ được
công thức toán học, người ta không hiểu.
Họ mình chết rồi đó nha em,
công thức mình không có cái nền tảng toán
học cho cái đo của mình hoặc cái tiêu chí
chuẩn của mình để tiến hành đo lường,
đánh giá và chứng minh nó là mình không
có sạc sử dụng được đâu.
Và nếu mình dùng đó để mình.
Chứng minh là phương pháp vận tốt hơn là
cái phương pháp cũng bị fail theo luôn,
tạo ra nó không có đủ độ tin cậy.
Nó ở đây cái em đã dùng là cái tiêu chí
đo lường thì phải theo cái độ đo quốc tế
thì nó sẽ có bữa trước.
Cô của nó có 2 trường hợp lắm.
Là cái nơi mà em xin phân người ta có bộ
tiêu chí kỹ thuật sẵn rồi.
Và người ta yêu cầu em viết theo cái sản
phẩm và theo cái bộ tiêu chí kỹ thuật đó
thì mình phải viết theo người ta.
Còn nếu mà trong trường hợp người ta
không có bỏ tiêu chí kỹ thuật sẵn thì
trong lĩnh vực này,
các bỏ tiêu chí kỹ thuật theo hướng kỹ
thuật mà nền tảng tố học là người ta dùng
cái gì á thì mình sử dụng mấy cái độ đo
đó thay thế.
Khi mà mình đưa ra một cái lời hứa hẹn.
Trong mục tiêu của mình.
Và nên nhớ các cái bài của mình,
á phạm vi một vấn đề nè phạm vi mục tiêu
trái cây VI của em nó phải xuyên suốt
thống nhất từ trên xuống dưới.
Chứ không có thể nào mà em nói là em sẽ
làm trong lớp 1,
lớp 2 mà cái mục tiêu của em đi kể tiếng
lớp 4 xong rồi cái KPA của em là của lớp
5.
Nếu mà nó mất, nó không có thống nhất,
vậy là cái bài đó là nó là bị rớt liền á,
đánh rớt á nên cái mục quan trọng là tất
cả các nội dung mà các em phân công cho
các bạn viết á.
Nó phải thống nhất từ trên xuống dưới chứ
không có kiểu là tôi mình nói một đằng,
nếu mà mình không thống nhất á thì nó sẽ
y chang giống như tôi hay nói các bạn
sinh viên á là các em hướng một đằng nữa
của cô em làm một nẻo vậy đó.
Đang góp ý của nhóm 5 kem các tiêu chí
thì kem cũng rõ rồi.
Thế nhưng mà đưa ra các tiêu chí KP cắt
lỗ đo sử dụng các độ đo theo quy định.
Và có nền tảng rõ ràng,
tránh kiểu miêu tả.
Dạ, anh hiểu rồi con.
Ừ.
Rồi bây giờ tới nó nhân tới cái khúc cuối
đi.
Kiến trúc,
phương án kiến trúc ở đây là các em dự
kiến là các em.
Giới thiệu mấy quán kiến trúc.
Được kiến trúc là này là sao con?
Thì kiến trúc, phương án,
kiến trúc của em đó, tốt 4 của em đó.
À.
Mấy cái.
Dạ, em có chia ra 3 cái.
Kịch bản.
Rồi sao nữa.
Dạ, và đó là.
Long 1 là.
Cô biết 3 kịch bản đó rồi theo sinh lý
thuyết xong rồi sau khi thi 3 kịch bản đó
xong rồi em làm sao nữa để nguyên 3 kịch
bản vậy luôn hả?
Và có chọn một cái kịch bản.
Số 2 là Harris điện toán đám mây.
Ừ,
tôi làm gì các em trình bày như thế nào
để mình chứng minh kịch bản sao là phù
hợp nhất?
Kèm điện thoại cho nào.
Dạ em có để ra một cái bệnh so sánh cho
cái 3 kịch bản này.
Để em xin phép trình bày phần bởi so sánh
này.
Và tiêu chí.
Con thấy rồi, mình hơi mất,
hơi quá thời gian.
Câu hỏi nhanh thôi ha,
cái kịch bản 2 này của em á thì mấy cái
tiêu chí này á, nó khớp,
nó phù hợp như thế nào đối với đối tượng
của mình mà mình chọn nó?
Là cái công ty mà các em chọn hoặc là cái
phạm vi của em chọn nó có đặc điểm gì á
mà nó làm cái tiêu chí quyết định là cái
kịch bản hay phù hợp nhất.
À dạ là tức là nhóm em vẫn chưa có là.
Dựa vào cái tình trạng của doanh nghiệp
để mà.
Nhưng mà chốt được cái.
Bể số 2 này.
Được cái nhóm bổ sung nha game.
Dạ.
Như game chọn phương án cho người ta mà
em không có đưa lý do làm sao người ta
tính.
Thương.
Dạ tức là em chắc là bị thiếu phần lý do
này dạ.
Rồi vậy mình sửa cái đó ha.
Được rồi, cảm ơn giống nhau.
Nếu là báo cáo xong thì các em có thể ớt
rồi,
các em hiệu chỉnh cái phần của mình lại.
Mình cũng gần cuối rồi nên trong mấy cái
buổi sau là mình sang Quốc Mỹ mà mình đi
liên tục để cho tới cái buổi cáo luôn á.
Nên mình làm tới đâu thì mình cố gắng
chỉnh hoàn cảnh tới đó để mốt tới cái
phần báo cáo thực hành chế độ án.
Có bị dồn diệt lại.
Rồi cảm ơn nhóm 5 nhóm tiếp theo để các
em chú ý 15 phút giống như những gì cô
hướng dẫn nhóm 5 rồi thì mấy nhóm sau là
các em đánh vô trọng tâm nha các em,
đừng trình bày lăng man.
Và cô cho em hỏi cái đó là cái ngày mà
cái ngày báo cáo cái bài thực hành lần.
Nào thì con.
Tối ngày báo cáo thì cô sẽ báo cáo trước
cho các em 1 2 tuần,
nhưng mà bây giờ là buổi thứ 6 rồi đó thì
là buổi thứ 9 mình sẽ báo cáo đó các em
là mình thi đó.
Rồi nhóm 11,
Dạ, em chào cô,
cô cho em 30 giây để em xem màn hình.
Ok
Tại cái file của bạn nó bị lỗi á cô cho
nên là trong lúc chờ 1 2 phút bạn mở lại
thì em nói luôn nha cô.
Tại vì cái phần đầu thì nó cũng không có
cần.
Trình bày trên trái file nhiều lắm.
Ừ
Tiết kiệm thời gian và thì đầu tiên thì
em chào cô các anh chị và các bạn thì em
là thiện hôm nay em xin đại diện cho nhóm
11 để báo cáo tiếp nối cái phần bài tập
này thì đầu tiên thì nhóm em xin thực
hiện cái phần báo cáo về đồ án trước,
sau đó sẽ nói tiếp luôn phần thực hành.
Thì cả hai được cùng thực hiện trên khảo
sát đối với các bệnh viện đại học y dược
mà nhóm em đã chọn cho cái phần tập của
môn này.
Đầu tiên là nhắc nhanh về bước không thì
tại vì đây là cái bước mà nhóm đã thực
hiện trước đó thì nhóm cho phép chỉ lướt
gọn qua thôi thì cái bước không vừa rồi
thì đồ án.
Mà nhóm lựa chọn thì nhóm lựa chọn đầu tư
vào 2 lớp,
đó là lớp 4 và lớp 5 vì cái hệ thống
nghiệp vụ tại UMC thì nó triển khai rồi
rẹt qua nhiều cái giai đoạn nên mà nó bị
thiếu cái tầng kết nói chung và cái dữ
liệu tuy là đã chuẩn hóa nhưng mà nó chưa
có nơi để tổng hợp.
Nên là hôm nay thì nhóm sẽ tiến hành đi
tiếp các phần tiếp theo đối với môn đồ án
sẽ đi từ bước 1 đến bước 4 và đi từ bước
0 đến bước 4 của phần thực hành.
Đầu tiên là vào phần đồ án thì.
Đầu tiên thì nhóm sẽ trình bày sơ qua về
cái mặt trận phạm vi đầu tư mà nhóm đã đã
nói qua thì nhóm bổ sung cái ma trận 5
lớp 5.
Tình bạn ngắn gọn,
tình bạn ngắn gọn cái ý tưởng cái mỗi cái
Dạ dạ thì.
bài tập mà cô giao cho các em về ví dụ đồ
án là từ bước 1 đến bước 4,
thực hành là từ bước 0 đến bước 4 đúng
không? Với mỗi bước á, các em trình bày.
Dạ.
Tóm tắt cái ý chính ở từng bước thôi các
em và hai nội dung của em nó có 15 phút
Dạ.
trình bày nữa nha.
Dạ vâng, nghiệp anh.
Ừ rồi bác nào đấy kênh.
Anh thì gia đình đi thật đi cái xuống xíu
quanh thì cái mặt trận này nó sẽ thể hiện
được là ở các cái ô mà tô màu thì nó sẽ
là những cái phần mà nhóm tụi em,
các thành phần ở lớp 4 và lớp 5 sẽ tiến
hành đầu tư,
tiếp theo đi đến bước một thì nó sẽ là
khảo phát, khảo sát.
Hiện trạng thì vì nhóm không có cái quyền
truy cập trực tiếp vào cái số liệu vận
hành thật cho nên nhóm dùng cái phương
pháp là mô phỏng có căn cứ cũng như là
kết hợp từ 3 nguồn công bố chính thức của
bệnh viện,
thống kê của ngành y tế toàn quốc và các
cái nguyên lý kỹ thuật phổ quát thì cũng
như là sử dụng các cái ràng buộc về các
cái.
Không các cái liên quan đến bên ngành y
tế như là thông tư 54/2017 của Bộ Y tế
này và đi vào cái hiện trạng đó thì nhóm
xác nhận được một số cái thực trạng quan
trọng đó là về hồ sơ bệnh án điện tử,
triển khai chính thức cũng như là phần về
kết quả chuẩn đoán.
Các hình ảnh các cái hệ thống như là PACS,
các cái phần này thì nhóm xin phép liệt
kê lại trong các phần chi tiết trong báo
cáo này từ những cái điều đó thì nhóm suy
luận ra các cái khả năng cao là sẽ thiếu
cái phần tích hợp chung cũng như là minh
họa bằng cái phép tính thì.
Từ một cái hệ thống lỗi nếu mà kết nối
điểm nối điểm theo như hiện hiện tại thì
cái tối đa nó sẽ có tới khoảng 45 cái kết
nối thì ở một 1.
4 này thì nhóm dựng thêm cái bảng về đối
chiếu 10 bước quy trình của khám chữa
bệnh.
Với cái hệ thống liên quan từng bước thì
2 cái điểm nổi bật mà nhóm nhận thấy đó
là cái bước mà khi mà bác sĩ nhận kết quả
và kết luận cần huy động cùng lúc 3 hệ
thống.
Làm.
Sẽ huy động cùng lúc 3 cái hệ thống này
thì cái xét nghiệm,
kết quả xét nghiệm cái hình ảnh và cái hồ
sơ bệnh án thì nó sẽ là cái quy trình này
nó sẽ cần dữ liệu từ toàn bộ hệ thống
nhưng mà hiện vẫn còn làm thủ công.
Đây chính là cái.
Cái bằng chứng cụ thể nhất cho cái nhu
cầu đầu tư của lớp 4 và lớp 5 đến cái
bước 2 của cái phần đồ án này đó là về
vấn đề rủi ro thì theo nhóm tìm hiểu thì
nhóm nhận thấy rằng có 3 nhóm tác động
lớn đó là về vận hành,
đó là nếu mà không đầu tư vào lớp 4 này
thì số điểm kết nối này nó sẽ tăng theo
cái.
Giáp số nhân lên mà khi có cái hệ thống
mới và nhóm bổ sung một số cái số liệu về
ngành như là một số cái dự án tích hợp
doanh nghiệp thường mất 3 đến 9 tháng nên
mà mỗi lần như MC mở rộng một cái hệ
thống,
nhiều cái khả năng nó cũng sẽ rơi vào cái
hoạt cái khoảng thời gian mất cái.
Cái thời gian này về cái việc tuân thủ,
ăn về cái việc tuân thủ và an ninh thì
đây là cái phần mà nhiều số liệu nhất
theo IPM năm 2025 thì nhóm tìm hiểu được
ngành y tế có cái chi phí về vi phạm dữ
liệu trung bình cao nhất trong số 17
ngành mà khảo sát thì trong đó thì.
Năm kết quả của năm 2.
025 thì nó chiếm tới 7,
42 triệu đô la Mỹ và nó dẫn đầu trong 4
năm liên tiếp về cái thời gian phát hiện
trung bình 279 ngày thì nhóm bổ sung thêm
2 điểm đó là tổ chức có cái tự động hóa
an ninh để rút ngắn được.
À 80 ngày và tiết kiệm 2 triệu đô la mỗi
vụ theo vùng báo cáo ABM thì những cái
con số này thì nhóm thực hiện khảo sát để
lấy từ các cái nghiên cứu, tổng thể,
tổng quát trong ngành y tế.
Về chiến lược thì Bộ Y tế cũng đang thúc
đẩy cái việc mà liên thông dữ liệu toàn
quốc, do đó là EMC,
họ có cái lợi thế từ cái giải thưởng mà
họ chuẩn hóa dữ liệu Stormes City từ năm
2022 trong cái báo cáo chi tiết thì nhóm
cũng cung cấp một cái bảng với 1, 2,4.
Vốn là tổng hợp lại tất cả cái rủi ro này
theo 3 cái tác động mà hướng trình bày
thì nhóm mà **** cô là sẽ xem qua và
trong nhóm ý kiến khi mà cô cô chấm chi
tiết đến với lại cái bước 3 là mục tiêu
và KPI thì tại đây thì cũng rút kinh
nghiệm từ cái phần cô vừa nhận.
Xét cho nhóm 1 thì nhóm vừa rồi thì nhóm
cũng có cái phần mục tiêu và cái vai
tương ứng.
Tuy nhiên thì nhóm cũng chưa có tên cái
độ đo thì chưa có trong báo cáo,
nhưng mà trong cái phần mà tìm hiểu thì
nhóm cũng đã tìm hiểu trước đó thì em xin
trình bày ngắn gọn sơ lược qua đó là về.
Mục tiêu đối với cái đồ án này đầu tiên
đó là việc nâng cao năng lực,
tích hợp các hệ thống nghiệp vụ thì nó sẽ
được đánh giá qua 2 cái cây gang tương
ứng là tỷ lệ giao dịch tích hợp thành
công được đánh giá qua cái độ đo là
sucessfuae thì nó sẽ tính cái số giao
dịch thành công trên tổng số giao dịch và
cái KPI thứ 2 đó là về thời gian.
Phản hồi API tại cái phân vị 95 nó được
đánh giá qua tên cái độ đo là v95 lagency
thì nó sẽ sắp xếp toàn bộ cái thời gian
phản hồi trong cái kỳ đo theo thứ tự tăng
dần và nó lấy cái giá trị tại vị trí 95%.
Mục tiêu thứ 2 của đồ án đó là giảm rủi
ro về vận hành từ kết nối điểm nối điểm
thì được đánh giá qua 2 KPI là thời gian
trung bình phát hiện sự cố tích hợp được
đánh giá qua thang đo MTD thì nó sẽ được
đánh giá bằng cái tổng thời gian từ lúc
sự cố xảy ra đến lúc mà nó được phát hiện.
Và nó cộng dồn toàn bộ cái sự cố trong kỳ
và nó chia cho cái số sự cố KPI thứ 2 về
để đánh giá cái mục tiêu này,
đó là về số bản ghi trong hàng đợi chết
thì được đánh giá thông qua cái.
Độ đo là DLQ backlock thì nó sẽ đếm toàn
bộ cái số bản ghi đang tồn trong cái hàng
đợi để mà hàng đợi chết tại thời điểm đó.
Mục tiêu thứ 3 đó là về nâng cao năng lực
khai thác dữ liệu tập trung thì được đánh
giá qua 2 KPI chính là tỷ lệ thành công
của Byeline.
Thập dữ liệu và cái độ mới của dữ liệu
phục vụ báo cáo thì nó sẽ được đánh giá
qua cái tỷ lệ sẽ set way như như trước đó
và cái thứ hai là về độ mới,
nó sẽ được đánh giá thông qua cái trang
đo là data presis thì nó sẽ được đánh giá
bằng cách là tại thời điểm truy vấn.
Nó sẽ trừ đi cái thời điểm.
Mà bản ghi mới nhất được cập nhật trong
cái kho dữ liệu và cái mục tiêu thứ 4 là
rút ngắn về thời gian tổng hợp báo cáo
quản trị thì sẽ được đánh giá thông qua
KPI là thời gian hoàn tất tổng hợp báo
cáo cuối tháng thì nó sẽ được đánh giá
thông qua cái report.
Pandoral time nó đánh giá cái thời điểm
hoàn tất cái báo cáo trừ đi thời điểm bắt
đầu tổng hợp và mục tiêu cuối cùng của đồ
án này mà nhóm đề ra đó là đáp ứng việc
cái tuân thủ việc bảo mật dữ liệu cá nhân
thông qua 2 KP chính,
đó là tỷ lệ dữ liệu nhạy cảm được mã hóa.
Hóa được đánh giá qua thang đo là
enriston Coverage và các tỷ lệ truy cập
dữ liệu nhạy cảm được ghi nhật ký là
audit lock coverage thì đó là các cái
thông tin tương ứng từ mục tiêu KPI và
các cái độ đo mà nhóm tìm hiểu được cho
phần đồ án.
Đến với phần tiếp theo của đồ án này,
đó là phần về các phương án kiến trúc to
B thì nhóm cũng đưa ra 3 phương án theo
cái hướng dẫn của cô. Tuy nhiên,
để tiết kiệm thời gian thì em xin nói
thẳng vào cái phương án mà nhóm chọn đó
là cái nhóm chọn nhóm hybrid lý do vì sao.
Vì đối với các nghiệp vụ lỗi và luồng
đồng bộ dữ liệu.
Dùng luôn đồng bộ thì sẽ giữ lại tại bệnh
viện để đảm bảo cái độ trễ thấp và hoạt
động được khi mà mất kết nối ra ngoài
những cái message,
nó sẽ được lưu hoàn đợi để đồng bộ lại
sau. Phần xử lý theo lô, phân tích,
báo cáo thì sẽ được đưa lên đám mây,
dùng để co giãn tài nguyên theo cái nhu
cầu.
Với những cái điều kiện dữ liệu là phải
được phân loại phù hợp trước khi mà đưa
lên,
đáp ứng điều này thì nó cũng đáp ứng được
cái luật về bảo vệ dữ liệu cá nhân năm
2025 của Việt Nam và ban hành.
Sở dĩ nhóm lựa chọn cái phương pháp này
vì tất cả các 3 phương pháp.
Đều phương án đó đều có những cái điểm
mạnh và điểm yếu riêng.
Tuy nhiên thì đây là các phương án mà
nhóm cảm thấy là nó có sự cân bằng tốt
nhất giữa các cái ràng buộc mà nhóm đã
thực hiện phân tích ở bước 2 và bước 3
thì đó là toàn bộ phần về đồ án mà nhóm
đã trình đã thực hiện trong bài tập lần
này ạ.
Thì không biết là em sẽ tiếp hành luôn
thực hành hay sao cô?
Mấy này cũng ổn rồi,
nhưng mà các em nhớ có bổ sung tài liệu
tham khảo cho các nội dung mình để trình
bày. Giống như các độ đo.
Dạ dạ.
Điểm.
Thì mình sử dụng cái độ đo nào mình phải
sai là phải refront đến ngay cái chỗ.
Cái câu anh nói á.
Dạ dạ, vâng ạ, em sẽ bổ sung ạ.
Ừ,
nãy giờ cũng với lại cái chỗ cái chỗ mà
Nhạc.
em trình bày về nó lý do vì sao em chọn
phương án Harbrid là em phải trình bày ra
cho người ta thấy em tại vì cái thuyết
minh đề tài,
Dạ.
nó sẽ không có ở đây là mình đang học với
cô thì cô cho.
Em có cơ hội bảo vệ cái thuyết minh đề
tài của mình,
ví dụ giả sử cô đọc cái thuyết của mình
cô hiểu thì cô hỏi và em trả lời được.
Hầu ý là mình hiểu mình trả lời chứ không
phải mình đọc là cái vai thuyết minh thì
Dạ.
đó là mình được lợi thế nhưng mà nếu mà
trong cái lúc mà đi làm thực tế á là mình
không có không có cơ hội bảo vệ cái
thuyết minh cho em.
Dạ, mày là cái này.
Vậy phần lớn cái thuyết minh có thể có
một số trường hợp đặc biệt là cái thuyết
minh dự án lớn thì người ta sẽ có một cái
dòng người ta chưa đọc cái thuyết minh
của mình,
người ta không hiểu lắm thì người ta sẽ
yêu cầu một cuộc họp meeting.
Trao đổi,
nhưng mà phần lớn cái đó là số hiếm,
nhưng còn phần lớn các cái bình thường mà
các cái dự án tiếp xúc đó vào là người ta
không có cho mình cơ hội sửa đâu.
Không cho cơ hội,
cơ hội trình bày luôn người ta chỉ đọc
cái thuyết minh OK thì việc còn không
được thì người ta phải rớt bỏ rớt người
ta đánh người ta đi qua thúy minh khác
liền.
Nên mấy cái chỗ mà các em nói hoặc là cái
lý do cơ sở là các em phải trình bày nó
ra chứ mình không có ở đây.
Sẵn rồi mấy công cụ AI nó hay cho là công
em lập mấy cái bạn so sánh,
nhưng mà cái em biết khuyết điểm của mấy
cái công cụ AI đó nhưng cũng là bản so
Dạ.
sánh, nhưng mà nó không có mục tiêu.
Em đọc cái bản so sánh nó xong rồi em
không có đọc được cái gì hết á,
em phải hình dung nha,
cái nếu mà nếu mà em có logic tốt và em
đặt điều kiện về cái bản so sánh đó ra
thì nó sẽ hỗ trợ em khá là tốt.
Nhưng mà nó đã có sự tương tác thì hay
hiện tại tương hoa thì có thể nó cải
thiện hơn,
nhưng mà theo hiện tại á là các em phải
tác động nó vô thì cái nó,
cái bạn so sánh em mới có giá trị.
Nhìn vô người ta thấy được cái điểm mạnh,
điểm yếu.
Và cái thấy được cái phương án hoặc cái
phương pháp nào nó nổi đang nổi bật nhiều
hơn.
Thường em như thế rất là sinh viên của cô
thì cô sẽ bắt là cái em phải khảo sát và
các em sẽ tùy theo mỗi bài toán.
Nó có các đặc điểm kỹ thuật,
các tiêu chí nào hoặc là các cái đặc điểm
nổi bật nè.
Thí dụ,
bạn đặt là muốn xây dựng một cái hệ thống
đảm bảo quyền riêng tư tính bảo mật.
Tiết kiệm chi phí.
Thì khi mà các em đã đặt đó là 3 tiêu chí,
các em mục tiêu tới tới thường nói là 3
cái tiêu chí trong cái mạng xã hội đó
luôn và mình đọc cái bảng tiêu chí nhìn
vô là mình thấy cái phương án nào nó khả
thi nhất liệt luôn.
Lúc đó là các em sẽ có ngay cả đáp án
luôn.
Là em không cần diễn giải gì hết á người
nhìn người đọc á người ta nhìn vô cái
bảng tiêu chí á và người ta thấy cái bảng
tiêu chí so sánh đó,
nhìn vô người ta hay biết cái phương án
nào đạt hết tất cả các tiêu chí đó là tôi
chọn thì cái đó mới gọi là bản so sánh để
tiêu chí để cho sự lựa chọn chứ cái bản.
Mà các em để cho các công cụ AI,
nó lập ra thì nó hay so sánh rồi nó lập
theo các cụm từ vân vân vân gọn để mình
đọc nhanh vậy thôi á,
nhưng đọc xong rồi thì cuối cùng lựa cái
nào mình những cái bảng mình không có lựa
được.
Nó không có rõ ràng,
giống như mấy cái bạn so sánh của nhóm
Trúc cũng bị cái tiếng này đó.
Nên nếu mình thí dụ ở đây các em cũng có
để bạn so sánh nhưng mà em nhích rất là
Dạ.
nhiều.
Mà các em phải hiểu nha,
người đọc người ta không phải ai cũng
siêng động đâu.
Và nếu đã là lập bản,
nếu mà đọc thì là con sẽ đọc.
Bản phân tích đọc 3 cái cái nội dung phân
tích diễn giải ở dưới,
còn nếu đã là vẽ bản.
Địa hình.
Thì phải xứng đáng là cái bảng với cái
hình nhìn vô gọn gàng tích chữ ký hiệu.
Có hình minh họa có icon minh họa và đôi
khi người ta nhìn vô người ta đã nắm được
sơ lược khoảng 80% các ý của cái ý của
cái ý.
rồi.
Không cần giải thích luôn.
Dạ.
Các em hình dung cái bảng tiêu chí là nó
phải vậy giống như thí dụ nãy cô nói 3
cái tiêu chí đó và mình chỉ dùng dấu các
dấu tích thôi.
Phương án nào đạt hết mấy cái tiêu chí đó
và mấy cái tiêu chí đó thường là các tiêu
chí mục tiêu đó nha,
các tiêu chí mà cô hay chỉ các bạn sinh
viên,
các tiêu chí trong cái bảng của em phải
là các tiêu chí mục tiêu mà mình đã nói
từ trên nãy giờ từ đầu.
Tóm tắt giới thiệu ban đầu mình đã nói
rồi,
tới khúc cuối luôn mình tóm lại thôi cho
người ta hình dung thôi thì người ta biết
là à lúc nãy giờ cái nguyên cái dự án này
tài là đã có 3 mục tiêu là xây dựng hệ
thống mới đạt được 3 cái tiêu chí 3 cái
tiêu chí trên.
Thầy và thông mấy cái phương án này có
cái phương án cuối cùng là đạt được hết
tất cả các tiêu chí rồi chọn phương án
cuối cùng.
Giải thích mình đôi khi người ta nhìn vô
mình không còn giải thích gì người ta
cũng biết cái thằng nào đang có thằng nào
ngon hơn.
Thằng nào có đạt được đầy đủ cái kỳ vọng,
còn thằng nào không đạt được.
Thì cái đó nó mới gọi là bản so sánh và
có ý nghĩa này các em.
Có gì mình có góp ý cho cái phần khúc
cuối,
khúc 4 mà về phương án phương án á nha
các em.
Dạ.
Tránh mình giết và dài giọng quá.
Nh.
Sử dụng công cụ là mình phải kiểm soát nó.
Dạ vậy con cho em nhắc lại là cái phần đó
thì nhóm nên trực quan hóa nó để nó có sự
liên kết với các mục tiêu để mà khi mà
mình nhìn vào thì nó có cái sự trực quan
là đối với mục tiêu nào,
hoặc là nhìn tổng quan lại là cái phương
án nào nó đang thỏa mãn được nhiều mục
tiêu nhất để mà người ta có cái nhìn tổng
quát.
Nh luôn.
Em có thể là nó không, nó không cố định,
em có thể là nó sẽ cái bảng của em có thể
Đẹp.
đi kèm các mục tiêu kỹ thuật,
vấn đề vậy đó.
Dạ vâng.
Nhưng mà nó sẽ là đi xuyên suốt từ trên
xuống dưới.
Và thí dụ giống như cái trên,
em nói là có các vấn đề rồi các cái mục
tiêu hoặc là các kỹ thuật tìm tiềm năng
thường thường là khi khi mà mình viết mấy
cái nội dung này,
nó sẽ có 3 nội dung chính mà các em không
có là viết bài toán gì, vấn đề gì.
Bài toán kỹ thuật gì,
các kỹ thuật liên quan tới bài toán đó
rồi các tiêu chí mục tiêu đặt ra mà muốn
đạt được cái gì?
Thì thường các bạn so sánh của mình,
nó sẽ xoay quanh mấy cái 3 cái nội dung
chính đó thôi.
Còn mình chọn làm bây giờ cái bảng của
mình chỉ nói mục tiêu thôi hay là bản của
mình vừa trình bày kỹ thuật vừa xem xét
mục tiêu.
Thì tùy mình thôi.
Đây.
Dạ, vâng,
nhớ em xin phép nó lại để điều chỉnh ạ,
vậy em xin phép đi qua phần thực hành cô
nhé.
Ok.
Dạ đối với phần thực hành của nhóm 11 thì
đây là một cái sản phẩm sẽ hơi độc lập so
với đồ án mà nó không có liên kết mật
thiết,
tuy nhiên thì nó có một cái liên kết
chung.
Đó là việc chia sẻ chung cái bối cảnh và
đối với cái tầng dữ liệu dùng chung cái
bối cảnh.
Khảo sát tại UMC thì đầu tiên đối với bức
thông về chuẩn bị đầu vào á thì cái bối
cảnh tại UMC thì đã nói ở phần đồ án nên
em cũng xin lướt qua luôn,
đó là tiếp theo là về cái vấn đề giải
quyết là bác sĩ sẽ nhận những cái kết quả
và cái kết luận nên mà bác sĩ phải tự đưa
ra.
Những cái tra cứu ở những cái hệ thống
khác nhau,
hệ thống nhận kết quả xét nghiệm,
hệ thống nhận kết quả về hình ảnh,
hệ thống nhận cái kết quả về tiểu sử bệnh
cũng như là các cái chẩn đoán bệnh của
bệnh nhân trước đó này kia thì cái đối
tượng chính xác chính ở đây là các cái
bác sĩ.
Lâm sàng và hệ thống liên quan gồm có các
hệ thống nghiệp vụ hiện có của bệnh viện
và các ràng buộc quan trọng nhất là tuân
thủ theo nghị định số 13 năm 2023 và luật
bảo vệ dữ liệu cá nhân vì.
Theo nhóm nhận định thì cái dữ liệu sức
khỏe thì nhiều thuộc nhóm dữ liệu cá nhân
mà đặc biệt nhạy cảm về bước đặt tên đề
tài thì tên đề tài mà nhóm xác định đó là
xây dựng hệ thống hỗ trợ quyết định lâm
sàng ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo,
tổng hợp dữ liệu đa nguồn.
Phải gợi ý chẩn đoán và đề xuất phát đồ
điều trị thì nhóm đưa cái cụm từ trí tuệ
nhân tạo vào ngay cái tên của đồ án.
Tại vì nhóm muốn nhấn mạnh việc sử dụng
cái công nghệ mới này vào.
Trong cái tên đề tài để mà đánh vào cái
điểm mạnh của đồ án cũng như là việc các
cái hướng mà các cái phần mà các vấn đề
mà nhóm sẽ giải quyết cũng được đưa vào
tên của đề án để đổi đề án để mà dễ đánh
vào cái tâm lý.
Trực quan hóa vấn đề đối với bước 2 là về
bối cảnh và lý do chọn đề tài thì nhóm
tách các quy trình bác sĩ kết luận thành
5 bước con thì trong đó là có thời gian
ước tính cho từng bước cũng như là.
Cụ thể trong cái bảng này thì nhóm xin
lướt qua cho nó nhanh.
Các cái bước này cộng dồn thì đâu đó lại
ở một cái ca khám bệnh thì nhóm nó.
Cái này câu.
Nhạc.
Cô góp ý luôn nha các em các em sửa là
khi cái mục tục tiêu bối cảnh của mình
theo cái tên đề tài lại đi.
Dạ.
Cái tên nếu mà em đang xác định cái phạm
vi theo cái tên đề tài mà ra đặt mặt nãy
giờ nói chung chung đúng cái em.
Dạ.
Nói chung lắm,
mình không có triển khai được đâu.
Thí dụ bây giờ.
Cho câu hỏi luôn hay là cô không biết là
do các em đặt mục tiêu sai hay là do các
em đặt cái tên, không biết cái đặt tên,
cái tên nó hơi hơi bị chung chung.
Em kéo là cái tên cho cô đi.
Nhạc.
Chắc là cái tên đi qua.
Xíu số mấy bạn.
À, sẽ xuống dưới xíu mình.
Xây dựng hệ
Cái tên đề tài em.
Phần dưới nợ, dưới nợ, bức chế nợ,
bước số 1 quá.
Đúng rồi, cái bảng.
Xây dựng hệ thống hỗ trợ quyết định lâm
sàng, ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo,
tổng hợp dữ liệu đa nguồn để gợi ý chẩn
đoán và đề xuất phát đồ điều trị.
Nó 3 cái này là 3 cái bài toán lớn luôn á
em,
thí dụ hỗ trợ ứng dụng quyết định lâm
sàng dựa trên ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo
đúng không?
Thì nếu mà người ta làm thì người ta sẽ
Nh.
chọn một cái đội bệnh cụ thể các em.
Tại vì dữ liệu y khoa,
nó là một loại dữ liệu y khoa.
Khó.
Dạ.
Trên nó học và mỗi loại dữ liệu khoa nó
sẽ có cái kỹ thuật xử lý khác nhau nên
trong một cái đề tài mình không ngồi mình
không có xử lý được hết tất cả các loại
dữ liệu y khoa để đưa ra quyết định lâm
sàng cho nhiều loại bệnh khác nhau được
đau.
Nên nếu mà các em đã chọn cái này thì
phải chọn như một bệnh thôi.
Dạ.
Nhạc
Bà,
thí dụ Nga đúng cái tên đó là cũng đã có
rất là nhiều đề tài cho một cái tên đó
rồi.
Nếu mình chọn cụ thể một cái còn tổng hợp
giữ sao em?
Dạ, cô cho em.
Em chia sẻ cái này một phút đi còn tại vì
cái hướng ban đầu của tụi em là lựa chọn
đúng một cái nhóm bệnh là nhóm bệnh ung
thư luôn,
nhưng mà chắc là do cái hướng mà suy luận
của tụi em nó bị sai á cô.
Tại vì tụi em có suy nghĩ là khi mà mình
chọn cái nhóm bệnh khó như bệnh ung thư
mà mình đã giải quyết được vấn đề thì tại
sao mình không chọn một cái hướng.
Rộng ra là khi mà đã giải quyết được bệnh
ung thư thì nghĩa là những cái bệnh đơn
giản khác,
nó cũng đã có thể giải quyết được bằng
cái hệ thống này cái cô.
Cho nên nhóm em nó mới bị lật ngược lại
là nó thành quá rộng như vậy,
cho nên là nhóm em có thể quay lại cái.
Vậy là các em chưa tìm hiểu, chưa,
chưa vô tìm hiểu thử vô dữ liệu của bệnh
ung thư đúng không?
Nhà nó chưa có đi quá sâu và phần đó.
Thì các em,
nhiều các em nên kem mới có suy nghĩ đó
dữ liệu ung thư thường thường.
Bây giờ là người ta lấy,
ta lấy dữ liệu sinh thiết, dữ liệu gen.
Nhưng mà đâu phải ung thư,
chỉ có cái dữ liệu đó đâu,
Dạ.
nếu mà thí dụ các ung thư khối u thì nó
lại có thêm cái hình ảnh CT ảnh em ray
nữa. Cái đó là xử lý kiểu khác nữa nha.
Dạ.
Ren là dữ liệu theo kiểu Tower là kiểu
bản.
Còn nhưng mà nó số chiều nó cao lắm.
Còn đối với cái ảnh CT với anh Empray nó
là ảnh và nó loại ảnh khác nhau là xử lý
khác nhau nữa.
Dạ.
Thí dụ cùng một bệnh đó 2 cái nguồn,
đó là bình thường người ta cũng chỉ chọn
một cái thôi.
Chọn hỗ trợ,
chọn một loại để xử lý đi sâu kỹ thuật vệ
một cái đó thôi,
nên nếu mà được thì cái em chọn một cái
Dạ dạ em hiểu cái con này.
thôi,
còn cái phần mà tổng hợp dữ liệu đa nguồn,
đề xuất phác đồ điều trị.
Tổng hợp dữ liệu đa nguồn thì nó sẽ đẩy
cái bài toán là tổng hợp đa nguồn ở đây.
Nguồn ở đây là từ nhiều bệnh viện khác
nhau nha,
là nguồn dữ liệu chứ không phải là cái đa
nguồn là mình lấy cái dữ liệu ở nhiều
khoa mà ở khoa.
Trong cùng một bệnh viện á thì người ta
không có gọi ra ngồi ngay tất cả các khoa
trong cô một bệnh viện thì nó cũng dùng
chung một cơ sở dữ liệu thôi thì nó chỉ
là một nguồn thôi.
Còn nếu mà em dính được cái chữ đang
nguồn này thì người ta sẽ hiểu em tổng
hợp.
Dữ liệu từ những cơ sở giống như là cái
cơ sở dữ liệu của bên Singapore đó là
tổng hợp dữ liệu trên toàn bộ Singapore
luôn,
có nghĩa là tất cả các bệnh viện trung
tâm khám sức khỏe trên Singapore.
Họ chia sẻ dữ liệu khác nhau với nhau
luôn.
Cho nhà nước qua do nhà nước quản lý,
thí dụ cái đó cô không đồng minh bên
chính thức quản lý trên hệ thống như thế
nào, nhưng mà họ chia sẻ,
có chia sẻ thì nó mới hỗ trợ là bây giờ
đi khám bệnh ở chỗ nào thì bác sĩ cũng có
thể nhìn được tiền sử bệnh án của bệnh
nhân. Từ đó tới giờ, từ lúc sinh ra tới.
Với cả luôn,
nếu mà làm được vậy thì rất là tốt,
nhưng mà cái đó là phải chia sẻ dữ liệu
đa nguồn thì lúc đó nó sẽ dẫn đến các bài
toán là đảm bảo tính tổng là.
Khi mình chia sẻ dữ liệu đa nguồn thì nó
là một bài toán khác rồi đề xuất phát đồ
điều trị nữa.
Cái này thì thường thường đi kèm với bài
toán trên nhưng mà là cái phác đồ điều
trị này hiện tại á.
Lúc mà cô đọc mấy bài báo đang cho nhóm
nghiên cứu của cô đang đọc các bài báo về
cái này thì là thường người ta mới dự
thằng nóng bệnh thôi.
Còn mấy cái kiểu đề xuất phác đồ điều trị
này hiện tại còn đang phụ thuộc vào bác
sĩ.
Dạ.
Chứ chưa có nghiên cứu triển khai đề mô
được luôn á.
Theo khảo sát hiện tại,
nên nếu mà các em chọn,
Dạ.
các em chọn nhánh trên thôi,
vô một bệnh cụ thể là được rồi.
Dạ dạ phải trúc cô cho em nhắc lại phần
này là nếu em nếu mà lựa chọn thì vô một
cái nhóm bệnh như là nhóm bệnh ung thư
thôi.
Còn cái phần mà đa nguồn thì nó nên dạ.
Những bệnh ung thư và một loại dữ liệu
theo loại dữ liệu rồi đem thực hiệu kỹ
Dạ.
thuật chính cho loại dữ liệu đó là được.
Nếu.
Dạ.
Chứ mình không có xử lý được đâu,
thí dụ nếu mà nếu mình gọi là nhóm lớn
thì các em làm đang làm cụm nhiệm vụ hoặc
là chủ nhiệm vụ thì em có thể nói là em
nằm trên tất cả các loại dữ liệu của bệnh
ung thư.
Dữ liệu xét nghiệm cho bệnh ung thư,
em xử lý hết.
Cái đó riêng của cái đó là làm cho nhóm
lớn và người ta có nền tảng kỹ thuật.
Còn ở đây,
các em mới bắt đầu thì cô mới khuyến
khích là em chọn một cái thôi.
Tại vì cái em chọn một cái để các em hiểu
Dạ.
sâu về kỹ thuật đó chứ.
Và trả lời được thì nó sẽ được đánh giá
cao hơn là các em chọn rộng người ta hỏi
em.
Mình không có cái nào mình rành nữa thì
người ta không đánh giá cao đâu.
Dạ.
Việc của anh cô là để mình có thể dừng ở
cái việc mà.
Đã chuẩn đoán được không cô?
Tại vì hiện nay nhóm em đang nhớ nhóm em
đang có,
Ừ,
đúng rồi thì mình dừng ở chẩn đoán á em.
và nhóm em đang có tài liệu là về cái
việc mà và nghiên cứu về cái chẩn đoán
bệnh viêm ruột thừa và đậu dược luôn á cô
thì chưa tới cái bước điều trị.
Thì cũng hơi tham vọng tí,
nhưng mà số liệu thì nó có thể lên tới
chỗ chuẩn đoán nguyên cục từ.
Thì cái gửi đến nhà của cô nói với các em
và các em nên dừng ở chẩn đoán.
Tôi thì nó hơi rộng.
Chẩn đoán bệnh thôi.
Còn cái chọn mà đề xuất phác đồ điều trị
Dạ.
là cho bác sĩ em.
Cô biết cô mới nói hồi nãy là.
Nếu như em nói đó chưa có dự án nào mà vô
cái đó tại vì đề xuất phát đồ điều trị nó
là đòi hỏi chuyên môn sâu của bác sĩ và
cái phác đồ điều trị nó đòi hỏi người có
trách nhiệm về cái phác đồ điều trị đó
khi mà nó triển khai cho bệnh nhân thì
chỉ có bác sĩ làm thôi.
Ai sao nó chịu được.
cảm ơn.
Đúng không?
Nếu mà có các nghiên cứu thì người ta
cũng nói là gửi bắt đầu điều trị thôi,
gửi phác đồ,
gợi ý theo kiểu phác đồ một số cái phương
án phác đồ khác nhau dựa trên các kết quả.
Giờ.
Nhưng mà cái bài toán đó hiện tại nó hơi
khó tại vì nó thí dụ cái phác đồ điều trị
nó sẽ còn dựa trên cái bệnh án rồi cái
trạng thái của bệnh nhân.
Mấy cái đó thì chỉ có bác sĩ người ta
khám người ta mới làm.
Còn nếu mà dữ liệu hiện tại.
Tại nếu có dữ liệu đủ thì mình cũng có
khả năng mình học thôi mình trên,
nếu mà mình xây được bộ dữ liệu kiểu đó
mà hiện tại các bộ dữ liệu bên y khoa nó
đang dừng cái kiểu là có kết quả xét
nghiệm rồi có bệnh hay không bệnh hoặc là
có khối u hay không có u hoặc là hình ảnh
có u xác định vị trí khối u.
Nó kiểu đơn giản như vậy thôi nên cô mới
nói là cái bài toán gợi ý cho đề xuất
phát đồ điều trị nó khó nên chưa triển
khai được á không có đủ dữ liệu để làm
hết.
Cảm ơn cô.
Rồi nhóm mình xác định cái phạm vi phù
hợp lại rồi mình tập trung những cái đó
vậy.
thôi hả em?
Dạ,
em có cần trình bày tiếp phần mục tiêu
Tôi không cần đâu,
game mục tiêu KPI của mình phải đi sửa
không cô? Tại vì cái dạ.
lại theo cái phạm vi mới nữa.
Dạ dạ vâng.
Rồi vậy ha,
nhưng mà các em xác định được cái mục
Dạ và em cảm ơn con.
tiêu thì nó cũng sẽ ổn hơn rồi.
Nó tỏi đi lang men.
Dạ.
Em cảm ơn con.
Ok
Rồi nhóm tiếp theo nhóm 2.
Nhóm 2 anh em.
Mấy cô thấy màn hình của em chưa?
Rồi bây giờ nhắc lại nha,
nếu mình có 15 phút,
thí dụ đồ án của mình có 4 bước,
mỗi bước em trình bày tóm tắt về cái nội
dung quy định kiến làm,
thực hành thì có từ bước 0 đến bước 4,
trình bày tưởng tượng.
Thì em xin phép đại diện nó mai trình bày
về phần bài tập thực hành của nhóm,
thì về phần bước chuẩn bị đầu thì do nhóm
không có quyền truy cập dữ liệu nội bộ
nên là nhóm sẽ sưu tập các kênh truyền
thống của doanh nghiệp.
Và các thanh niên trang cổ đông bằng là
từ những nguồn đất,
báo chí lớn về các loại phân tích tài
chính hoặc là về phần pháp lý thì tra cứu
trên các trang của chính phủ.
Bên cạnh đó thì cũng có tham khảo thêm
một số kiến trúc của các.
Hệ thống bán lẻ trong ngành để có thể đối
chiếu với doanh nghiệp về tên dự án của
nhóm em thì nhóm em sẽ xây dựng một cái
nền tảng AI hỗ trợ dịch vụ khách hàng và
tư vấn.
Bán hàng đa cân cho thế giới độc.
Về hiện trạng khi có của.
Về cái mảng tư vấn bán hàng online thì
hiện tại khách hàng đang truy cập website
và tự tìm kiếm sản phẩm và không có một
ai gọi là tư vấn trực tiếp một hay là tư
vấn trực tiếp online cho khách hàng.
Hệ ở bên thế giới động thì cũng có tích
hợp sẵn sẽ bốc, nhưng mà nó về thường,
về những cái kịch bản có sẵn,
thường nó sẽ không có văn nói như người
thật nên là.
Cũng khó tiếp cận được người dùng và thứ
3 nữa là các cái data mà còn chatbot đã
có thì nó sẽ không có đưa thêm với các
cái sản phẩm mà.
Thế giới động đang có nên là khi khách
hàng hỏi thì nó cũng sẽ không có trả lời
được hoặc là tư vấn được thì từ những cái
vấn đề đó thì tụi em.
Để định hướng ra một cái giải pháp là xây
dựng một cái kiến trúc RG kèm theo vector
DB gọi là xây dựng một con AI để có thể
training tất cả các chính sách.
Sản phẩm khuyến mãi của thế giới động để
khi mà khách hàng muốn tìm hiểu hoặc là
muốn tư vấn một sản phẩm nào đó thì hay
là đề xuất một cái số sản phẩm nào đó.
Theo nhu cầu khách hàng thì có thể thì
con chatbox này có thể tư vấn trực tiếp
cho khách hàng luôn.
Bên cạnh đó thì cũng có xây dựng thêm một
cái hệ tuần của lớp 4 để có thể kết nối
giữa các hệ thống bên ngoài kiểu IIP và
CIM.
Ồ,
cái này là em đang làm bài tập hành hay
là đồ án vậy?
3 thực hành
Và thực hành tập trung như hệ thống phần
mềm.
Quan trọng là các em trình bày về kỹ
thuật AI và các em có thể build được cái
con đó trên cái bộ dữ liệu và bây giờ nó
có thể trà phản hồi trả lời ra sao,
sử dụng các độ đo gì để trả lời.
Cái sử dụng các cái đồ đo gì để đánh giá
cái mức độ trả lời và đánh giá độ mức cái
câu, mức độ về cái câu hỏi,
câu phản hồi của mình nó sẽ tốt.
Bối cảnh bây giờ là cái nhóm mình làm khá
là ổn rồi đó.
Dạ.
Do chú chỉ là mục tiêu KPI,
mục tiêu KPI của em đặt ra làm sao để em
đo lường rằng chứng minh công sách box
của em birdra nó sẽ tốt hơn con hiện tại.
Và em sẽ đo các tiêu chí gì nó để em hứa
với người ta.
Thì về mục tiêu hiện tại thì tụi em sẽ
xây dựng,
thứ nhất là một con AI chuyên về chatbox
để phản hồi người dùng.
Một con AI về VoIP để xử lý các.
Cuộc gọi.
Tư vấn này và một cái nữa là.
Tích hợp thêm một cái quy trình bảo hành
có AI hỗ trợ kiểu như là khách đặt lịch
hoặc là khách muốn tra cứu thông tin bảo
hành. Thì đó là mục tiêu mà.
Nhóm đề ra là sẽ xây dựng 3 cái vấn đề đó.
Vì cái ai ai, cái như sau 3 với.
Không,
cái 1 thì tụi em chỉ về việc tư vấn bán
hàng thôi,
kiểu đề số các sản phẩm theo nhu cầu
khách hàng hoặc là các chính sách bảo
hành.
Còn cái quy trình bảo hành mà tụi em sẽ
chắc kỹ hơn về thông tin đơn hàng của
khách hàng về thời gian bảo hành,
về chính sách bảo hành của từng sản phẩm,
từng theo từng cái đơn hàng mà khách hàng
có.
Có nhu cầu mà muốn bảo hành cái sản phẩm
đó.
Mà giờ vừa xử lý test xong rồi cái như
cây hand nhảy ra xử lý voi nữa hả?
Mà kem chơi 2 cái đó đúng không?
Dạ.
Dạ đúng rồi, tụi em sẽ làm 2 tên 2 cái.
Giờ là mình đi phải đi theo kỹ thuật 2
cái nha.
Em phải hiểu rõ về 2 kỹ thuật đó nha các
em.
Khi voi khác test.
Nếu mà nhóm mình không chưa có kiến thức
về NLP thì chọn 1 thôi.
Một là vô NLB nên như được test,
hai là trên dữ liệu vôi,
dạ.
hai đây là hai nhánh khác nhau đó nha các
em.
Vâng,
theo những kiến trúc mà tụi em có đi file
trên thì chắc là tụi em sẽ chọn SK1 về
phần chất bất.
Để gọi là tăng trải nghiệm người dùng.
Rồi về cái độ đo, cái mấy cái điểm,
mấy cái KPI,
độ đo dự kiến mà nhóm mình sẽ đo lường là
cam kết với người ta là cái nào.
Dạ, về độ đo thì tụi em gọi là về,
em làm về phần chất bóc nên là tụi em
thường đánh về thời gian phản hồi của các
cái tin nhắn.
Đâu có em đi khám,
nó có nhiều độ đo đo lường lắm em.
Cũng như là.
Phản hồi nhanh mà trả lời ngu thì nó cũng
đâu có tốt, đúng không?
Thế tụi em.
Cái quan,
cái chết bốc của mình khi mà mình muốn
nâng cao là mình phải sử dụng các độ đo
giống như là các cái độ đo đo lường cái
độ dài phản hồi,
cái mức độ ý nghĩa của phản hồi,
rồi cái nội dung của cái phản hồi có trả
lời cái đúng khi word của người dùng hay
không.
Thì đó là các cái độ đo để mình đo cái
mức độ diễn giải của mình,
của của cái con trái bắp của mình,
sau đó thì nó nếu mà em bên em b nó sẽ có
2 dòng KPI đo,
có nghĩa là đo lúc mà mình đang demo để
mình test hệ thống.
Một cái trường hợp đo thứ 2 là khi mà sau
khi người ta sử dụng một dịch vụ thời
gian,
người ta sẽ phản hồi mấy cái này là cái
em đang sử dụng mấy câu AI nhiều cái em
sẽ thấy thấy thấy hay hỏi bạn có hài lòng
với cuộc hội thoại này không?
Nó đang phản hồi tốt hay không?
Nó đang lấy cái thu thập.
Cái phản hồi sau khi suy nghĩ cũ để nó đo
lường cái mức độ hài lòng của người dùng
hoặc là cái mức độ cái câu hỏi cái con
nghe này có trả là hiểu được cái câu hỏi
đó của em hay không?
Mà sử dụng cái độ đo sau khi sử dụng thì
ở đây cái em mình đang làm thì mình phải
nêu nó rõ ra cái em chứ không có dùng
thời gian được đâu.
Thời gian, nó chỉ là một yếu tố nhỏ thôi.
Thì tụi em thường đánh MKBA kiểu thời
gian phản hồi rồi số lượng đơn hàng tăng
Đúng
Nếu mà em
lên từ sau khi áp dụng chatbot này.
Đọc kỹ thuật vô đi,
em đây đã cô đang cho các em để các em
Dạ.
trước khi đi du chuyên ngành đó, và NLP á.
NLP bây giờ nó cũng thịnh hành mà.
Tìm lộ đo về các cái độ đo đánh giá không
trách móc trên dữ liệu.
tụi em.
Trong cái lĩnh vực cảnh NQ đi, mình dùng.
cuối cùng.
Em về đề xuất thêm.
Qua đồ án đi.
Vâng,
vừa rồi ấy thì chắc có bạn Duy sẽ chia sẻ
rõ hơn.
Đồ án thì mình trả lời và treo 4 bước,
mỗi bước em đã làm những gì.
C
Giờ cô ạ, cô thấy màn hình của em chưa ạ?
Thấy là em bắt đầu đi.
Chào cô, các bạn,
em xin được đại diện nhóm trình bày về
cái từ bước 1 đến 4 của tàu Á. Đầu tiên,
về cái bước một khảo sát hiện trạng hạ
tầng có số liệu thì cái mục tiêu là tôi
bị đầu.
Tư thì bọn em à,
đang có mục tiêu là chủ nhật là hiện
trạng hạ tầng công nghệ thông tin của ơ
thế giới di động thì.
Các phẩm nhựa sát sẽ liên quan đến trực
tiếp với kênh đối tác khách hàng như là
online, fanpage,
cửa hàng của ba thương hiệu chủ lực,
sử dụng di động,
đỉnh xanh và đèn packag xanh.
Về cái bối cảnh ấy thì bọn em có dựa vào
những cái số liệu công khai.
Cô mới hướng dẫn hồi nãy rồi,
mỗi bước trình bày tóm tắt các ý xem làm
thôi em.
Vâng ạ, thì em có các bảng ở.
Thí dụ bước 1 khảo sát đề tài.
Mức thí dụ bước 1 nè, khảo sát,
bước 1 thí dụ khảo sát hiện tại,
Các bạn số địa ở đây.
đề tài thì em nói chung,
đặc điểm hiện trạng hiện tại của công ty
em chọn nó như thế nào?
À vâng ạ,
thì em xin bước qua phần kết luận là cái
hiện trạng cho thấy là 1 2 đều đặn thành
viên ban lớn nhưng mà đang có bị thiếu ở
các 3 lớp cần thiết và 3 cái lớp này sẽ
cần thiết cho cái phần chất.
Có đã nêu ra ở cái phần bài tập thực hành
là các phần bảo mật định danh ứng dụng
thích hợp và nền tảng dữ liệu ạ thì.
Qua tới bước 2 là cái các vấn đề rủi ro
như không đầu tư.
Thì em gặp các vấn đề đầu tiên là tớ tác
động đến vận hành.
Thì nó có nguy cơ gián đoạn hệ thống bán
hàng,
thích hợp giữa các hệ thống nó ngày càng
phức tạp thì nếu như mà không kiểm soát
cái vấn đề này thì nó sẽ khó theo dõi và
bảo trì ở vấn đề thứ 3 là dữ liệu bị phân
mảnh và không đồng nhất.
Thì các cái dữ liệu phát sinh từ nhiều
nguồn,
nó sẽ không có được đồng ghép để mà mình
xử lý ở trong một hệ thống ạ.
Cái thứ 2 đó tác động về an ninh và tuân
thủ thì.
Nguy cơ chiếm quyền tài khoản rất là cao
trong một cái công ty mà có sự lượng lớn
thành viên của tài khoản hệ thống.
Thứ 2 là nguy cơ rò rỉ dữ liệu khách hàng
về dữ liệu nghiệp vụ thì cái dữ liệu xử
lý dữ liệu của khách hàng là rất lớn nên
là sẽ phải đảm bảo cơ chế mã hóa,
phát triển dữ liệu để đảm bảo cái quyền
riêng tư của khách hàng.
Thứ ba là phát hiện sự hỗ trợ.
Thì sẽ phải lắp và cảnh báo các sự cố
phát sinh trong quá trình vận hành.
Thứ tư là tác động những cái vấn đề tác
động chiến lược thì nó sẽ khó mở rộng quy
mô hệ thống cũng như là khó phát triển mô
hình bán lẻ đa kênh.
Và hạn chế khả năng khai thác dữ liệu và
AI ạ.
Thì ở đây em có các bảng lý do đánh giá
rủi ro. Nếu như không đầu tư.
Thì ở cái đoạn bước 2 ấy thì nếu như mà
về quy mô hàng nghìn cửa hàng và nhiều
thương hiệu,
mô hình bán lẻ đa kênh thì cái mức độ phụ
thuộc của thế giới rộng và công nghệ
thông tin ngày càng lớn thì cái 3 lớp này
sẽ có phát hiện.
Trực tiếp với nhau là thiết lập kết nối
các ứng dụng nghiệp vụ lớp diện tiếp nhận
và trả lời dấu hiệu ờ sau.
Trong khi lấy lớp mà sucrurity,
ý sẽ bảo vệ xuyên suốt người dùng ứng
dụng máy AP và các dữ liệu ạ.
Qua 3 xét nghiệm mục tiêu PB và hạ tầng
thì cái bước này bọn em có một số cái giả
định.
Của các lớp
Như là cái độ phủ của ờ công ty fashion
aths as and fashion ờ sirin.
Và cái.
Chỗ này thì ờm.
Em đang giả định từ.
1 đến 6 tháng thôi ạ,
chỗ này em xin được lướt qua.
Cái đó đâu phải giả định đâu em,
cái đó là cái chỗ mà các em đang hướng
với người ta mà.
Cây đa đặt ra lời hứa của mình với họ đó.
Bọn em có giả định là giả định cái ở hiện
tại ở bella hiện tại ạ thì ở.
Ừ thì cái gia đình hiện tại là phía trên
đã giả định rồi,
còn cái em đã xuống bước 3 thì đây là cái
cam kết về cái phương đồ dự án đầu tư của
em sẽ làm được gì mà.
Em đang ở bước 3 đâu còn gia đình nữa em.
Em chỉ các em chỉ giả định cái hiện trạng
của công ty thôi.
Nếu mình không có thông tin chính thức.
Nếu mình có sử dụng các độ đo,
đây chắc hồi nãy giờ có sửa lại rồi,
nhưng mà mình tăng cường cái phần diễn
giải các độ đo và cái tài liệu tham khảo.
Sai cái trích dẫn là để tham khảo chính
xác cho chỗ đó để người ta biết là loại
rau nào tại vì cũng có thể người ta nhầm
sang loại đo trùng tên chẳng hạn.
Ví dụ, giống như đồ đó là thiếu RC á,
nó sử dụng được sử dụng cái tên đó được
đặt cho rất nhiều độ đo,
có nhiều độ đo ở thiếu oxy cho những bài
toán khác nhau lắm nên thí dụ các MC mà
độ đo nào thì các em cũng phải diễn giải
độ đo đó ra và cái tính toán và tài liệu
tham khảo gốc.
Thì người ta biết là em đang nói cái
thằng đầu đôi nào.
Sự chính xác.
Ví dụ như những cái này thì em bọn em lấy
độ đo là cái độ phủ,
tức là cái độ mà áp dụng cho hệ thống ấy
ạ thì.
Thì phải có tài liệu tham khảo.
Về mấy cái độ đo mình sử dụng đồ phủ là
cái phủ,
cái gì làm sao tính cái độ phủ đó.
Cái nào đo này được công nhận để đo lường
đánh giá cho cái tiêu chí này đó giờ hay
chưa thì mình mới được sử dụng.
Hình như có ý có nói không?
Phần.
Thì bọn em xin anh chủ nhật lại.
Chờ tới bước 4 đi,
cái đó các em sửa lại tới bước 4.
Vâng ạ.
Bước bố ở đây,
em có mấy phương 3 phương án phải không?
À chuyện 4,
Vâng ạ,
bọn em đang có passion là on Premise nâng
cấp Cupion 2 là hybrate và Option 3 là
Cuard First thì.
Rồi vậy bây giờ mình nhảy tới cái đoạn mà
so sánh và cái tiêu chí để lựa chọn
phương án mà em đề xuất đi.
Vâng ạ,
so sánh thì bọn em đang thấy trong một
cái thị trường bán lẻ nó rất là diễn ra,
rất là nhanh và bận rộn thì bọn em đang
ưu tiên những cái phần thang tung market
và khả năng mở rộng cao.
Cùng với đó là cái độ phức tạp vận hành
nó thấp thì qua so sánh á thì em bọn em
đang thấy là cái khả năng mở rộng cùng
với lại cái thang tool market của cái
option warfer là rất là lớn.
Trong khi đấy cái mức độ kiểm soát thì ờ
nó ở.
Đợt kiểm soát thì đang ở phần là trung
bình cao thì bọn em chọn cái option là
graphir ạ.
Thì.
Cứ lao phớt là đang dựa trên cái tiêu chí
gì là lấy kem mấy thêm to market hả?
Family Market và khả năng mở rộng.
Cùng với đó là cái cam kết ban đầu thấp.
Thì em đang muốn là cái option này là
công ty có thể là vừa tự ờ mình vừa xây
Ừ.
dựng vừa devoi ạ.
Rất là nó khả năng mở rộng cũng rất là
lớn.
Rồi kéo xuống cái chỗ dưới đi,
cái chỗ mà mấy em cái lập bạn so sánh á.
Nếu mà em sánh cái biểu đồ của em phải
đánh vô cái mục tiêu của em nói và với
cái ngữ cảnh của công ty á,
chứ các em so sánh thì nhìn vô kiểu này,
con thấy cái nào nó cũng như nhau hết.
Không chưa biết chọn cái nào luôn.
Đây đây bảo so sánh là cái đây ạ.
Hay là thầy cô được điểm rồi.
Thì ấy,
cô nói cái bản so sánh của mình nó phải
giúp cho cái người khách hàng người ta
đập vô người ta hiểu.
Thí dụ mà em muốn đặt cái bản so sánh
kiểu đó thì em phải đặt với cái ngữ cảnh,
vấn đề của người ta đang đặt gì,
hoặc là cái tiêu chí nào là tiêu chí mục
tiêu thì dùng nó là cái tiêu chí đánh giá
chính để đưa ra cái sự kết mà mình có cái
phần chú thích về kiểu đồ và đưa ra cái.
Vẫn được sự lựa chọn của mình luôn.
Bổ sung cái đó vô.
Biểu đồ đây à.
Thì em cũng vừa nói là nếu như mà cái
công ty nó tập trung vào phần bán lẻ ấy,
cái thị trường nó nhanh.
Thì bọn em đang muốn là tập trung vào cái
khả năng mở rộng và cái tham tôi market
ấy.
Đi cái câu của em nói nãy giờ trong cái
bảng này nó có đâu,
cái em có cái biểu đồ không mà em đâu có
cái chú thích.
Của các biểu đồ hiểu con nói không?
ạ.
Phần hoặc là.
Vâng ạ.
Khách hàng không em lúc mà người ta đọc
thuyết minh,
người ta không có gọi em đem đứng kế quên
em giải thích cho người ta đâu,
người ta đọc á.
Em không viết ra là người ta lướt thôi,
thí dụ ở đây chỉ có cái biểu đồ thôi chứ
biểu đồ của em có 3 tiêu chí đúng không?
Thì nếu mà theo tiêu chí mà gọi là 2 cái
tiêu chí mà khả năng mở rộng và thị
trường marketing thì cái lâu first tốt.
Đúng không?
Nhưng mà nếu mà anh ở đây người ta không
có rành đâu.
Người ta là khách hàng mà người ta chưa
biết là cái tiêu chí nào bây giờ vấn đề
ra trên thì người ta cần phải đặt mục
tiêu,
tiêu chí nào lên ở cái khách hàng người
ta thì hỏi là tôi muốn có mức độ kiểm
soát cao hơn.
Người ta chọn on ren thì sao on rem là em
đang đánh cao nhất đó?
Đúng không,
em phải giải thích ra cho cái bộ tiêu chí
của em biểu đồ vẽ ra mà em không giải
thích, em không nói lý do.
Thiện đồng thuyết phục được.
Bổ sung cái đó vô.
Dạ vâng ạ.
Rồi vậy mình chỉnh cái đó là được rồi,
hoàn thiện cái bài của mình vô trọng tâm
với xíu nữa.
Tôi không nhất.
Rồi thế thì bọn em xong rồi.
Năm 2 đường ok.
Để các em về chỉnh hoàn thiện cái vai của
mình lên ha.
Các em bắt đầu viết các bạn rap nữa,
có nội dung tới đâu?
Các em bắt đầu viết cái bản rap đi mình
tới buổi tuần thứ 9 là mình.
Thì vấn đáp.
Là vườn tượng thứ 6 rồi.
những mà.
Nếu bạn có đây không?
Dạ, cô cô đợi em nha.
Sao nhóm 3 nhóm 10 chuẩn bị.
Rồi những bà kem có 15 phút để trình bày
đồ án môn học thì có 4 bước, bước 1,
bước 4,
mỗi bước thì kem trình bày tóm tắt em đã
làm gì các bước đó.
Thực hành thì mình sẽ có từ bước không
tới bước 4 cũng trình bày tóm tắt.
Theo các bước.
Rồi bây giờ em trình bày đồ án trước hay
tự hành trước, thực hành trước đi.
Giải trưng bày bài thực hành trước.
Em gọi trình bày tóm tắt theo các bước.
Bắt.
Dạ, trước hết em chào cô và các bạn,
em đến từng nhóm 3,
em xin trình bày về thực hành của em là
về FE Credit.
Thì.
Về cấu trúc thì báo cáo báo cáo có 5 một.
Báo cáo giúp em cuối năm 1 lần và chuẩn
bị đầu vào tên đề tài và thông tin chung,
bối cảnh mục tiêu KPI và đối tượng phạm
vi.
Và đối tượng phạm vi thì.
Đầu tiên là về.
Chuẩn bị đầu vào, chuẩn bị đồ.
À,
về doanh nghiệp thì bên em sẽ tập trung
vào là FE Credit,
vấn đề hiện tại là mạo danh bằng hình ảnh,
ở video mặt nạ hay là deffect?
Thì khi vay hồ sơ thì chúng em sẽ tập,
sẽ phát triển là ở ứng dụng AI vào phần
quét hồ sơ ạ.
Đối tượng sử,
đối tượng sử dụng là sẽ là những khách
hàng vay những người nộp hồ sơ mà cần
phải xác thực khuôn mặt thì ở đây là
chúng em sẽ xác thực khuôn mặt ở các bước
là khi người dùng Smith hồ sơ.
Thì sẽ tiến hành quét khuôn mặt và sau
khi quét khuôn mặt xong sẽ chấm điểm.
Thì sẽ sau khi chấm điểm xong thì sẽ đánh
giá và đưa qua cho bộ phận hồ sơ.
Thì ở đây em đang giả định trường hợp.
Ở các các hệ thống bên em sử dụng là ở
các hệ thống liên quan thì sẽ là CCI lưu
trữ thì là minio,
hệ thống thì sẽ có Apax cấp cao.
Oendy
Ở vậy,
thời gian thực hiện thì bên em dự kiến là
đi a.
Dự kiến là đi theo phần.
Nghị định nghị định năm 2025.
Là nghị định được đưa ra vào ngày,
vào cuối tháng 6 thì thời gian thực hiện
của chúng em sẽ bắt đầu dự giả lập thì sẽ
là bắt đầu là khoảng 1 tháng 7 năm 2025.
Là giai đoạn sẽ nâng cao cái bảo mật của
nhóm em.
Là sau đó thì sẽ ứng dụng AI vào vào hồ
sơ hóa.
Thì đây là toàn bộ khoảng thời gian mà
nhóm em sẽ dự tính triển khai từ lúc mà.
Từ lúc mà nghị định đã ra để nâng cao bảo
mật. Cái thứ nhất,
thứ 2 là ứng dụng AI là đây là toàn bộ
quá trình thì địa điểm triển khai dự kiến.
Vậy thì tụi em đang giả lập là OFE Credit,
nơi là dự điểm triển khai sẽ là.
Truộc sở chính của FE thành 8 về bối cảnh
thì.
Về bối cảnh thì tụi em như em đã nói thì
quy trình tiếp nhận và thẩm định hồ sơ.
Cái tên đề tài của các em là gì vậy em?
Cái đây.
Cải tiến, nâng cấp quy trình tiếp nhận,
xác thực và thẩm định hồ sơ vay tính.
Tính chất trực tuyến.
Cái này trực tuyến đúng không?
Dạ.
À.
Thì cái phần áp dụng của mình là áp dụng
cho toàn bộ hệ thống chứ không phải trụ
sở nào hết em. Nếu mà em làm như vậy.
Em đâu phải là chỉ áp dụng cho cái hồ sơ
camera tại cái trụ sở đó.
Còn trực tuyến là có nghĩa là ai tham gia
vô cái hệ thống vài tính chất này là có
thể sử dụng đó mà.
Dạ,
cái này là tụi em giả lập quy trình vai á
cô là khi mà người dùng vay thì sẽ ứng
dụng toàn bộ là khi người dùng spmit đơn.
Vay thì sẽ tới bước thẩm định bằng AI
quét hồ sơ quét khuôn mặt á cô.
Là nó sẽ cơ là vay tín chấp trực tuyến á
còn triển khai.
Thì nên ý nó là vai tính chấp trực tuyến
thì đang là vay cho nguyên toàn bộ hệ
thống rồi.
Dạ,
còn cái này là địa điểm triển khai là địa
điểm mình sẽ khởi hành cái đó đầu tiên á?
Là mình chỉ triển khai là từ cái cơ cái
đầu vào từ bước 1 tới bước hoàn thiện hết
thì nhân sự này kia thì nó sẽ ở trụ sở
chính thì mình sẽ triển khai trụ sở chính
triển khai ra.
Thì nếu anh em đang dự kiến là như thế.
Trụ sở chính điện ra hay là cô vẫn chưa
hình dung được cái phạm vi áp dụng của
các em á.
Ví dụ,
nếu mà em đang sử dụng cái này thì mình
Dạ.
áp dụng cho toàn bộ hệ thống FE Grid chứ.
Dạ,
thực thi cấu hình đó cô làm giống như là
hạ tầng.
Cái này bà thực hành là đang nói bà đầu
án kìa.
Dạ vậy thực hành.
Thực hành xây dựng hệ thống phần mềm cho
cái phân dùng người dùng đúng không?
Để tôi đăng ký và hỗ trợ cho cái bên
khách hàng quản lý,
bên nhân viên quản lý hồ sơ sẽ kiểm tra
cái hồ sơ để tránh.
Cái giả mạo ở đây thực chất em đang đánh
vô deep fake thôi.
Đúng không?
Dạ đó đúng
Ừ
Nên cái phạm vi trụ sở chính thì em nói
một hệ thống rồi cô không cô bị lăn tăn á
bây giờ nếu.
Mai tốt là đúng rồi,
chỉ là thí dụ bây giờ các em đang đi
nghiên cứu về cái bài toán và xử lý dữ
liệu ảnh trên xử lý dữ liệu camera để
mình chống cái deffect.
Và xác nhận đây là cái người thật để khi
mà thực hiện cái phương thức vay tiền nó
sẽ được chính xác và tránh bị thất thoát,
đúng không?
Dạ đúng ạ
Thì nếu mà em đang nghiên cứu cái đó vừa
áp dụng vô cái quy trình này,
Nhẹ.
khi nó triển khai trên cái phần mềm hệ
thống,
phần hệ thống này cho tất cả khách hàng
người dùng với giới hạn trụ sở nào đâu em.
Em đang làm trực tuyến mà.
À.
À dạ dạ dạ em hiểu rồi.
Dạ vậy em đi tiếp thì cái này có gì em
nhóm em sẽ review lại?
Đã cái tên vô đúng cái trọng tâm em.
Dạ vâng ạ
Đặt cái tên em đặt cái tên mà người ta
không mình dung được là em đang đánh vô
cái nào á.
Nói cô biết cái này.
Nhiều nhóm làm ý tưởng và sinh viên hay
làm cái này hình như có một cái đề tài về
cái deffice mà đã đã book được chung nó
khá là nhiều nhóm dùng nó.
Không nghe cái đề tài này mấy lần luôn
rồi.
Thì chủ yếu nếu mình nếu mà làm cái đề
tài cái này,
nó cũng vẫn là có hướng làm thì cái hướng
làm nó là chủ yếu là nâng cao cái độ bảo
mật.
Khi mà người ta xác thực thông qua camera
chóng cái deffect thôi.
Thì em phải đặt cái tên xong nhìn vô là
người ta biết là em đang nghiên cứu các
kỹ thuật để xử lý ảnh,
xử lý cái khâu sắc thực khuôn mặt.
Và chống giả mạo vậy thôi.
Và sử dụng cái công nghệ gì đó thì thêm
tên công nghệ vô.
Tên sao nó phải sát với cái đề đại của
mình á?
Dạ dạ dạ em hiểu rồi ạ.
Ok rồi.
Rồi đi tiếp đi.
KP đo lường ở đây, em là gì?
Mục tiêu với KP các độ đo mà các em dự
kiến là em sử dụng cái gì?
Dạ chưa thấy là.
Đi nói tóm tắt nhìn vô mấy cái mục chính
em.
Dạ đây.
À,
một mục tiêu chung của giúp em là sẽ
hướng tới từ mua định từ.
Từ mô hình thẩm định thủ công sang tự
động hóa và thực hiện giao tiếp với nhau
bằng cấp ca thì.
Các đơn vị của bên em là tụi em sẽ tính
là bao nhiêu hồ sơ và bao nhiêu phiên vô
giao dịch thì đây là tổng hợp KPI.
Kem của anh em thì của em sẽ có.
Cái này cái nó không phải KPI,
nó không phải cái tỷ lệ chấp nhận tấn
công giả mạo,
tỷ lệ từ chối nhằm người thật.
Cái này là mấy cái đầu đôi gì vậy?
Mấy đồ đo này em có khảo sát chưa vậy?
Dạ, cái này,
cái này là bạn đang giả định trường hợp.
Các em nên đi tìm cái đồ bài toán và
diffect này nhiều lắm,
em đi kiếm một cái bài kỹ thuật đọc nó đi
có các độ đo khi mà em xây dựng cái mô đồ
nhận diện chống giả mạo.
Dạ.
Tụi em đang.
Thí dụ giống như là ở đây em có 1 độ đo
gần giống nè,
độ chính xác soi khớp khuôn mặt.
Đúng không?
Cái đầu đo dưới mới hàng là mấy cái đầu
đo đó đó là em đưa công thức toán học,
em tính toán ra.
Mấy cái đồ đo em sử dụng á.
Sang.
Dạ mình áp dụng những công thức toán học
nó còn.
Em phải đừng đúng rồi,
em phải hiểu nó ra thì lúc mà này em mới
sử dụng cái nguồn mấy cái bài tập này thì
chắc cô đang cho cái em để tìm kiếm cái
input đầu vào để cho em viết thuyết minh
đề tài cho tốt hơn đó.
Ví dụ,
em sử dụng mấy cái độ đo gì thì em phải
đưa công thức rồi đưa cái tài liệu tham
khảo chính ra.
Sai tức giận,
đó là sự tham khảo chính để mình xác nhận
coi cái độ đo đó sử dụng và áp dụng cho
cái vô.
Cái bài toán này người ta mới hiểu chứ em.
Thí dụ cái độ đo mà em trình bày em còn
không rõ cái độ đo là công thức tính toán
cũng không có nền tảng.
Là người ta sẽ đánh giá được cái mức độ
hiểu của em đối với cái đề tài này rồi.
Dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Tụi em đang tại vì tụi em đang giả đang
giả định là trường hợp là tụi em đang đi
theo hướng là giả giả định từng sự kiện
tại từng lớp tại từng nhóm đó cô.
Nước nhớ gì?
Cái tai đề tại từng nhóm.
Nhóm gì.
Ví dụ như như khi khi mà vào đúng không
thì ở tụi em sẽ chia ra,
ví dụ như thứ nhất là nhóm là làm sao là
đặt được một KPI là làm sao để chống mộ,
chống mạo danh rồi dùng á cái gì đó.
Tại vì em thấy có cái trường hợp là ở giả
dạng dùng AI để mà gọi điện người thân đồ
á cô em có coi mấy cái mà liên quan tới
gì hết chưa?
Giả dạng người thân nằm viện đồ này kia.
Cô biết cô biết cái đó,
nhưng mà câu hỏi là mấy cái nhóm này của
Nhận.
nhóm mình là các em đọc nguồn tài liệu
đâu mà tách nhóm rồi đưa ra mấy cái PA
này vậy hay là gì?
Các em vừa phân tích dựa trên suy nghĩ
của mình, các em list ra?
Dạ, tụi em đang liếc ra rồi.
Lứa ra theo suy nghĩ của mình đúng không?
Đi đọc cái một cái kiếp,
một cái bài gốc chính để đọc đi mấy cái
bài thì diffice thì nhiều.
Yeah.
Các em phải nhớ là kem là không phải phân
tích quy trình.
Triển khai nữa đâu mà các em đang đứng
góc độ kỹ thuật á?
Và cái đây người ta đang muốn biết là cái
em có cái chuyên môn kỹ thuật để có thể
triển khai được hệ thống này hay không,
rồi em có biết cách đo lường cái hệ thống
giống như ở đây các em có cái model em
xây dựng cái model có thể được test được.
Là đây là người thật hay là đang sử dụng
các kỹ thuật giả mạo?
Rồi giờ làm sao mình đo đường cái bộ đồ
đó đây, nó sẽ có rất nhiều tiêu chí để đo,
đo lường cái hiệu quả,
hiệu suất hoạt động của cái model đó.
Thì bây giờ mình sử dụng cái đồ đo nào em
liệt kê ở đây và nó sẽ là cái tiêu chí
cam kết của em khi mà em triển khai cái
hệ thống trần tang.
Nếu em xây dựng cái hệ thống mà cái tỷ lệ
hiệu quả nó dưới 50% thì tại sao anh ta
chịu được?
Bây giờ em hứa phải trên 70 80 gì đấy.
Là cao hơn tùy theo cái ngữ cảnh nữa.
Trời ơi, quay.
Ở đây game đang đi theo bài toán phân lớp
hay sao?
Nãy em lướt xuống dưới một số rượu đo hay
gì đó giống e gì?
Quyền phân nhóm của em hay tự phân nhóm
theo cái suy nghĩ của mình quá các em.
Dạ,
tụi em đang chia heo từng KPI tầng 1 á cô.
Ăn cây KPI từng lớp á.
Ví dụ như là.
Lớp nào bài thực hành mà các em,
em đăng bài thực hành mà em đang đánh giá
cái model, cái phần mềm của em mà.
Dạ dạ cái này là em đang đi theo hướng là
thí dụ như một we một we toàn bộ một cái
quy trình ứng dụng AI thì.
Không có đi theo quy trình.
Mình đang là mình đang xây dựng phần mềm
AI thì em đang đánh giá cái phần mềm AI
của em đạt chuẩn khi em bàn giao cho
người ta.
Giống như cái giống đầu tiên rồi.
Em không có quyền quê quản lý quy trình
của người ta.
Em hiểu ý cô nói không,
mục tiêu phải bài thực hành của mình là
gì,
xây dựng hệ thống phần mềm của ứng dụng
AI là cái model AI của em á.
Cái phần mềm của đội AI của em có đạt
chuẩn và sử dụng được hay không?
Thì mấy cái độ đó KPI của em phải đi theo
cái phần mềm của em.
Em.
Các em chỉ có cái phần Deepfake thôi,
ở đây các em kéo nè,
có thời gian phản hồi khách hàng sau khi
nhận hồ sơ.
Em là cái dự án IT phần mềm làm sao em
kiểm soát cái KPA đó?
Cái đó là nhân viên,
cái bên cái công phần bộ phận,
phòng ban quản lý cho nhân viên đó,
người ta xử lý hồ sơ chứ làm sao em quản
lý được mà em đem cái đó vô KP này?
Thế có nói không?
Ừ
Dạ, nếu nếu vậy là.
Tụi em đang giả lập là ứng dụng AI tại
một quy trình đó thì tụi em có cần phải
giải thích là quy trình đó gồm có cái gì
thì tụi em sẽ ứng dụng cái AI ngay tại
phần nào và các các cái thông tin liên
quan.
Em ơi, mình đang là phần mềm, em đang,
mình đang là phần mềm, em và cái em,
Không.
cái phần mềm của em hỗ trợ cho cái quy
trình đó.
Và em chỉ cần nói tóm tắt về cái quy
trình đó thôi và mình phải dành cái thời
lượng để trình bày cái phần mềm của mình.
Và cái ứng dụng AI của em nó,
nó là một cái hoạt động độc lập chứ nó
không phải là nó được ứng dụng trong cái
giai đoạn nào của cái quy trình đó.
Thường thường khi mà cái quy trình mình
xây dựng một cái phần mềm mình xây dựng
ra cho người ta đó là mình sẽ hỗ trợ toàn
bộ cái quy trình của người ta.
Ra chứ mình không có hỗ trợ một bước rồi
còn lại để người ta tự bơi.
Thí dụ,
bây giờ em xây dựng một cái hệ thống quản
lý đăng ký học phần trong cái sinh viên
đi thì em phải làm từ a tới z cho sinh
viên rồi các bên liên quan để quản lý cái
quy trình quản lý đăng ký học phần đó.
Chứ mình nó có bàn bỏ giữa chừng đâu các
em.
Các em phải hình dung được cái hệ thống
phòng quyền của mình với cái quy trình là
nó bao trọn cái quy trình á.
Nếu mà phần mềm lớn là nó bao,
nếu mà phần gọi là phần mềm tổng quan lớn
á,
hệ thống lớn á và gọi hệ thống luôn rồi
đó là nó sẽ bao gồm nhiều quy trình hoặc
là tất cả các quy trình ở công ty đó là
nó quản lý hết luôn.
Lại thống của mình cung cấp cái chức năng
cho người dùng sẽ quản lý hết luôn á.
Chứ nó không có ở 1 bước nào cả đâu,
quản lý là quản lý hết cả quy trình.
Chứ em xây dựng cái,
em xây dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm cho cái
một cái phòng ban đó mà người ta xài nửa
chừng thôi, các bước còn lại,
người ta phải tự xử ai đặt hàng mình nữa.
Hiểu có nói không?
Em tập trung vô mấy cái độ đo vừa độ đo
đo lường cái phần mềm của các em model ai
của các em á.
Đọc kỹ thuật chưa?
Chứ đừng để mấy cái gợi ý,
quy trình của mấy con này nó dẫn đó.
Dạ
Rồi chỉnh lại cái KPI của mình nha.
Dạ, anh nên nếu vậy.
Dạ vậy là cái KPI thì mình sẽ tập trung
vào cái xử lý cái phần mềm đặt đặt nặng
như phần mềm đó chứ không có liên quan
tới mấy cái.
Không phải đặt nặng phần mềm meme sản
phẩm bài thực hành của em chính là cái hệ
sản phẩm.
thống phần mềm em thì đương nhiên bây em
hứa với người ta là em xây dựng cho người
ta cái hệ thống phần mềm thì nó là cái
sản phẩm duy nhất và chính của em chứ
không phải cái quy trình.
Cái quy trình mình chỉ nói để cho người
ta hình dung được là cái sản phẩm của tôi
đang áp ứng cái quy trình gì của các anh
chị á.
Và nếu mà các anh chị đặt hàng đầu tư cái
này thì cái quy trình của các anh chị sẽ
được vận hành tốt hơn.
Hình dung không?
Dạ dạ.
Tại cái cái mì.
Rồi vậy mình chỉnh được cái đó đi hả em?
Dạ vâng ạ.
Mình thích cái đó đi rồi theo cái đó thôi,
xác định đúng mục tiêu phần mềm nha,
chứ không có quy trình hết theo quy trình,
nó chỉ là ngữ cảnh thôi em áp dụng cái
phần mềm lên thôi.
Vậy
Rồi.
Vậy là theo em hiểu là cái phần của mình
sẽ đi sâu về cái là cái phần cái quy
trình thì nó chỉ là một cái ngữ cảnh để
mình phát triển ra cái phần mềm đó và để
giúp đỡ người ta trong cái hoàn cảnh đó.
Cái quy trình nó chỉ là cái ngữ cảnh ứng
dụng thôi.
Là cái phần mềm của mình sẽ được ứng dụng
vô đâu á?
Em sẽ dựng phần mềm dựa theo quy trình
của người ta,
cho người ta sử dụng để quản lý cái quy
trình đó.
Hiểu gần đúng rồi,
nhưng mà em hiểu hơi ngược.
nhạc.
Khi giống như bây giờ cô mở một trung tâm
giáo dục đi nè.
Nhạc tại vì.
Tôi nói,
bây giờ tôi mở trung tâm giáo dục.
Trong trung tâm giáo dục tôi hiện tại sẽ
dự kiến,
sẽ có bây giờ chi phí để quản lý hết tất
cả các quy trình vận hành của trung tâm
giáo dục. Nó không có đủ tiền để chi.
Giờ chỉ tập trung vào một số quy trình
chính để tạo nguồn thu cho trung tâm thôi.
Như là quy trình về quản lý hoạt động
giáo dục và đăng ký học phần đăng ký học
phần của học viên.
Đúng như mang cái quy trình đó.
Giờ bạn xây dựng cho tôi hệ thống phần
mềm quản lý quy trình đó cho tôi và cái
quy trình trung tâm tôi dự kiến tôi sẽ
làm như nè.
Trung tâm tôi sẽ có mở mấy cái lớp này nè
và có yêu cầu học viên rồi.
**** muốn là có các gói dịch vụ này để
cho học viên đăng ký học viên của chúng
tôi có nhóm người dùng vậy đó.
Và chúng tôi kỳ vọng có những chức năng
này để tôi quản lý cái quy trình chúng ta
sẽ người ta sẽ miêu tả ra cho mình.
Hoặc là mình sẽ đi khảo sát hiện trạng
của người ta để coi người ta cần chức
năng gì rồi bắt đầu là mình mình á nhà IT
á là mình sẽ dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm
là mình xây dựng theo cái yêu cầu đặt
hàng của người ta.
Hình dung không?
Là cái quy trình của người ta có sẵn rồi,
người ta tôi đang có trung tâm vận hành,
tôi có cái quy trình đó,
giờ tôi muốn đặt hàng anh chị xây dựng
cái hệ đóng phần mềm quản lý cái quy
trình đó cho tôi một cách tốt nhất.
Và bây giờ thay vì chỉ quản lý không thì
bây giờ có thể ứng dụng với ai cho cái
quy trình nó hoạt động tốt hơn nữa,
thông minh hơn nữa chẳng hạn.
Để nhóm đạt sửa lại cái đó,
còn mấy cái vấn đề đó là hồi nãy cô nói.
Mấy nhóm trước là các em có thể coi là
video để mình tới nhóm tiếp theo nha em.
Hiểu không những mang đạt mở mứt.
Dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Ừ.
Rồi thế nhưng mà sửa lại cái đó.
Nhóm tiếp theo.
Nhóm 10
Nhóm nào kem báo cáo xong thì có thể ớt
rồi phân công học riêng,
phân công các bạn để hoàn thiện cái bài
mình hơn.
Nhóm 10.
Cà Mau cho cô.
15 phút,
mỗi bước trình bày tóm tắt các nội dung
Ừ
mà các em dự kiến thực hiện trong các
bước ở đồ án cũng như thực hành nữa các
em.
Trình bày thấy cái frame đó.
Dạ vâng.
Bây giờ mình trình bày đồ án hay thực
hành trước.
Dạ em trình bày đồ án trước ạ.
Ừ rồi bắt đầu đi em.
Nhạc.
À
Nhưng em xin tóm tắt tại cái phần dự án
của nhóm mình và đầu tiên là bước một
khảo sát hiện trạng hạ tầng AS và AS,
mục tiêu của bước này là không đánh giá
dựa trên cảm tính mà còn có số liệu.
Làm base live ờm.
Nhóm sẽ khảo sát ở một số.
Một số chỉ số quan trọng cần thu nhập làm
và uptime hiện tại là sự cố trong vòng 3
đến 6 tháng.
Tỷ lệ backup thành công RPO và R.
RTO các thiết bị hết hạn hỗ trợ gồm lỗ
hổng và chưa được xác.
Chưa được xử lý. Ngoài ra, bài toán á.
Keywisei nhóm đặc biệt quan tâm đến xác
thực khuôn mặt.
Và khả năng triệu tải của
Số lượng giao dịch tăng.
Ngoài ra, bước này là hồ sơ.
Là sơ đồ kiến trúc hiện tại,
bản Base Life KPI và các painpoint được
định lượng.
Nhóm em cũng xác nhận bằng các bước từng
qua từng lớp.
Ở tiếp đến là bước 2 là xác nhận vấn đề
rủi ro và quan vấn đề rủi ro từ base line.
Nhóm xác định các rủi ro theo 3 nhóm,
nhóm thứ nhất là.
Vận hành.
Ở
Nhóm thứ 2 là an toàn và tuân thủ.
Nhóm thứ 3 là chiến lược,
ngoài ra thì có là các vấn đề tác động
đến như là bảo mật sinh trắc học,
hiệu năng và các khả năng mở rộng,
khả năng phục hồi và giám sát và tổng sự
cố.
Nguyên nhân gốc là do các nguyên nhân là
công nghệ internet chưa có diffect
dission chuyên biệt,
thiếu GPO phục vụ xử lý AI chuyên sâu và
kiến trúc.
SA và DR chưa hoàn chỉnh.
Mi minitoring chưa bao phủ đầy đủ các cái
chỉ số sinh trắc học chưa có những kho dự
liệu vòng đời và quản trị mô hình in hoàn
chỉnh và.
Ở và từ đó nhớ chuyển sang câu hỏi quan
trọng là nếu đầu tư thì chúng ta muốn hệ
thống tốt hơn vào điểm nào và bằng chỉ số
đo nào thì chúng em có xác nhập xác lập
mục tiêu KPI.
Để hoàn thành được cái mục tiêu này thì
đầu tiên là có mục tiêu tổng quát xây
dựng kiến trúc skyity và identity có khả
năng xác thực danh tính an toàn chống
deepfake.
Ở và cách mục tiêu cụ thể như là có bước
một là đảm bảo các tính năng sẵn và khả
năng phục hồi và nâng như là nâng cấp
bước time giảm RPO và.
Nt.
Tăng cường bảo mật sinh trắc học và chống
biết phách,
nâng cao hiệu năng và khả năng mở rộng,
nâng cao khả năng giám sát và sự cố.
Tăng cường kiểm soát,
truy cập an toàn hệ thống dưới đây là KPI
to we.
Ở
Như vậy là chuyên gia có chia thành 5
nhóm chính.
Ở các camera này được đo trước triển khai
để lấy bay like và đánh giá sau các mốc.
tầng 1, 3 và 6 tháng ở.
Tại các tiêu chí thành công giúp em cũng
đưa ra là giải pháp được xem là thành
công khi mà đạt các tiêu chí trên.
Đối với.
Đối với đối tượng áp dụng bằng phạm vi.
Và khi làm buộc thì chúng em hướng đến
các.
À dạ phần này hình như nhóm em bị làm bị
nhầm qua phần thực hành các cô.
Có cái chỗ mà KPI này em tới cái chỗ,
cái loại hệ thống mà các em muốn triển
khai.
Quán kiến trúc.
Nhạc.
Ngoài kiến trúc nào,
các em muốn triển khai.
Em chưa nghe rõ mạng bên em nó hơi nó hơi
ngắt.
Phương án kiến trúc, phương án kiến trúc.
Sau khi chọn KPA xong rồi thì tới cái
bước cuối cùng của phần mềm hôm nay là
phương án kiến trúc dự kiến triển khai đó.
Dạ.
À phương án kiến trúc tụi em được viết
triển khai là Highbus ạ các thành phần vì
các thành phần dữ liệu sinh trắc học và
các hệ thống cốt lõi thì cần phải được
kiểm soát chặt chẽ.
Ở.
Và trong và cách xử lý các thành phần
được để có thể triển khai và linh hoạt
hơn ạ.
Cái phần đó nhớ mình chưa làm đúng không?
Ưu điểm.
Dạ đúng rồi, vợ em làm.
Cái mẫu.
Vậy bổ sung cái nội dung đó.
Với lại bổ sung từ tham khảo cho các KPI,
Bị nhầm.
độ đo của KPI mà các em đang dùng,
trình bày.
Dạ vâng.
Rồi chú qua bài thực hành đi.
Ở em cũng xin trình bày vào thực hành là
tên đề tài và thông tin chung của em là
đề tài giải.
Dạ đề xuất giải pháp xác thực khuôn mặt ở
tích hợp phát hiện dét phát tại TPBank ở.
Với giải pháp công nghệ và em xin tóm tắt
lại với giải pháp công nghệ và luồng vận
hành là mô hình giải pháp được xây dựng
và hệ thống xác thực khuôn mặt AKYC kết
hợp với.
Kết hợp sau với công nghệ deep phách tạo
thời thời gian thực,
luồng vận hành thực tế.
Ờm số lượng.
Giá trị cốt lõi là ngăn chặn tuyệt đối
các hình thức tấn công giả mạo,
nâng cao như video deep phát phát lại,
mặt nạ 3D hoặc là các cuộc tấn công chèn
hình ảnh vào luồng camera để nâng cao.
À, bảo mật cho khách hàng.
Các mục tiêu và chiến lược thì nhóm em
đưa ra là nâng cao mức độ bảo mật định
danh trực tuyến,
tuân thủ chặt chẽ các quy định pháp luật
của Ngân hàng Nhà nước và xác định sinh
trắc học, đồng thời.
Duy trì trải nghiệm mượt mà nhờ nhanh
chóng cho người dùng.
À thưa cô là vì phần này nhá nhóm em chưa
update kịp nên là phần nội dung nó sẽ
khác với những gì em thuyết trình á và
những và những bài chịu trách nhiệm về
phần này sẽ update phần này sau ạ.
Ở về các chỉ số KPI đề xuất là hiệu năng
xử lý ở thời gian hoàn tất quy trình và
kiểm tra deepfake là phải dưới 3 giây
giao dịch, độ chính xác của AI.
Cái này nè em,
hồi nãy cái nhóm của mình tương tự cái
Dạ.
nhóm của sữa hồi nãy.
Cái em coi là cái lá họ coi video coi lại
cái phần hồi nãy để mình.
Hiệu chỉnh và mình viết cái phần này cho
nó hoàn thiện hơn há.
Nhạc.
Ừ,
phải có nội dung trình bày và các em phải
nhớ thuyết minh mình viết làm sao cho nó
người ta đọc vô người ta hiểu vấn đề.
Dạ vâng.
Tại vì mình cái thi trong môn này của
mình thì cô cho các em báo cáo á.
Còn nếu mà các em dưới thuyết minh thực
tế là người ta chỉ đọc cái thuyết minh
của mình xong người ta quyết định luôn á
chứ người ta hiếm có chỉ có một vài
trường hợp đặc biệt mới cho báo cáo để
người ta trao đổi rõ thêm nếu mà thấy có
tiềm năng.
Mà chưa rõ chị đó thôi.
Dạ không.
Dạ nhóm em vậy xin nếu em sẽ xin update
vào ngày sau ạ.
Ừ, sao mình chỉnh phần đã sao hả em?
Em.
Và nhóm tiếp theo.
N 7
Giờ giờ đến chia sẻ của mình.
Rồi 15 phút và trình bày theo các bước
với mỗi bước thì em trình bày,
tính tắc các nội dung mà thực hiện trong
bước đó thôi nha,
các em để cô hãy nắm cái ý tưởng để coi
mình đi đúng hướng hay không.
Dạ rồi.
Có thấy màn hình em chia sẻ cho cô?
Rồi thấy rồi,
bây giờ mình báo cáo đồ án trước hay là
đồ án trước đúng không?
Khi giá đồ ấy, giá đồ án trước của thì.
Rồi bắt đầu lên.
Cho cô là em là Tuấn đại diện nhóm 7 báo
cáo.
Đồ em một cơ sở hạ tầng cũng tin thì.
Bước một là ở bước này là nhóm em.
Khảo sát và biết em khảo sát các quy mô
hoạt động hiện trạng hạ tầng công nghệ
thông tin thì qua khảo sát và nhóm MM lập
ra các chỉ số để đánh giá năng lực.
Ra các chỉ số để đánh giá năng lực và
nhận thấy có một số thành phần xuất hiện
dấu hiệu dương cầm giới hạn như là về
phần campus này nè,
là cái phần CPU vào giờ cao điểm CPU thì
nó đạt.
Nên đến đến 88 đến 92%.
Thì như cái phần dưới đây cũng như vậy,
nó đều đạt cái gần mát lên phần full lên
thì như vậy tới cái phần bước 2, ờm.
Nó sẽ có cái vấn đề nêu ra đầu tiên là về
rủi ro,
rủi ro về giá động dịch vụ thứ 2 nữa là
năng lực.
Cái máy chủ và story tiến tới gần giới
hạn như hồi nãy các lớp 5 lớp trên mà em
đã nói và khả năng phát hiện và xử lý sự
cố về với các rủi ro bảo mật.
Thì từ các hiện trạng trên,
nhóm em xác định các vấn đề,
nếu mà mình không đầu tư kịp thời,
cái định nghĩa này nó có thể bị ảnh hưởng
trực tiếp đến các hoạt động khai thác.
Đây là cái bản rủi ro,
nếu mà không đầu tư thì em có lập ra nhóm
em có lập ra các cái bản như thế này và
các mức độ.
Rủi ro từ cao cho đến hk.
Rồi về cái phần bước 3 là xác lập mục
tiêu và KPI hạ tầng,
thì ở đây thì nhóm em lập ra cái bảng.
KPI này là KPI giả định ờ cái KPI giả
định này là do giống như em tự suy nghĩ
và tự lập nên chứ chưa tụi em chưa có
khảo sát.
về.
Thì cái này là các em thấy hồi nãy giờ
sửa cho nhiều nhóm rồi nhóm mình từ chính
là phần này ha.
Cái này thì có một lỗi của tiên thì để
tiện chỉnh lại ạ.
Vùng.
Thì ở bước này là nhóm em dựa trên các.
Gia đình để lập trên các bảng KPI này thì
nó cũng hơi lỗi thì em luôn xin lúc qua
phần này và tới lúc 4 thì các phương án
như là đầu tiên là phương án 1.
Và tự nhiên chọn 2 fits of platform.
Rồi phương án 2 tụi em chọn phương án
Paris thì cuối cùng là nhóm em đánh giá
lý do cần đầu tư ngay.
Là do quy mô và nhu cầu thì càng tăng
trong hạ tầng đã xuất hiện.
Nó có nhiều cái điểm nghẽn như các lớp mà
hồi nãy nhóm em đã phân tích ở trên thì
nếu mà cứ.
Mình cứ tiếp tục,
cứ chậm đầu tư như vậy thì nó càng ngày
nó càng gia tăng cái điểm nghẽn lên và nó
sẽ ảnh hưởng đến dịch vụ và ảnh hưởng đến
năng lực. Cái năng lực kinh doanh,
năng lực khai thác.
Cái này càng lớn.
Dạ.
Thì chế độ án bước 4 nguyên là như vậy.
Hồi nãy cô gợi ý về cách sửa bản so sánh
để chọn phương án và cái thần chú diễn
giải cái lý do mình chọn phương án thì
nhóm chỉnh lại nha em.
Cái mình viết kiểu này là người ta không
biết đường nào, người ta lựa đâu.
Dạ.
Rồi vậy qua bài thực hành đi em.
Đầu tiên là
Đầu tiên là bài thực hành là nhóm em xác
định bối cảnh doanh nghiệp,
các vấn đề cần giải quyết vấn đề cụ thể
hoạt động tại cổng hoặc bãi lưu lượng
biến động.
Nhưng mà cái việc đường phố nó còn thiếu
công cụ dự báo nó còn thiếu cái công cụ
dự báo để mà được phát hiện sớm cái xảy
ra tình trạng.
Bị động và ùn tắc thì à.
Ở đây thì cái vấn từ cái vấn đề trên thì
các nhóm em đã xác định đề tài là xây
dựng hệ thống báo lưu lượng và hỗ trợ
điều phối hoạt động cổng bãi cho cảng Cát
Lái.
Thì giải pháp của nhóm em là được định
hướng triển khai với dạng protototype để
thử nghiệm tính khả thi.
Rồi.
Bối cảnh và lý do tụi em chọn đề tài thì
nhóm em nhận thấy dù mặc dù.
Các em đặt em coi cho cô là cái tên đề
tài đi.
Do kích tụi em.
Xây dựng hệ thống báo lưu lượng và hỗ trợ
điều phối hoạt động cộng bãi cho.
Dự báo lưu lượng.
Dự báo lưu lượng để hỗ trợ điều phối hoạt
động đúng không?
Da hoặc nông cảnh và cho kẻ tăng cả chiếc
lá.
Dự báo lưu lượng để hỗ trợ em chứ không
phải và hỗ trợ.
Nếu mình và cái đó là mình giống như mình
đang làm cả hai cái đó.
Để hỗ trợ.
Dự báo luôn lượng.
Lưu lượng gì?
Đặt tên nó phải rõ em kiểu bá lưu lượng
gì?
Lưu lượng.
Lưu lượng các phương tiện như cái xe tải
lớn.
Rồi lưu lượng phương tiện để hỗ trợ điều
phối hoạt động cổng bãi cho cảng.
Biểu kiện rồi ở đây cái em có nhóm kỹ
thuật tiềm năng nào chưa?
Giờ thưa cô là.
Ký chấp kỹ thuật nhóm kỹ thuật tiềm năng
đó cô là.
Ừm
Cái kỹ thuật dự báo lưu lượng các em khảo
sát các phương pháp dự báo lưu lượng chưa,
là bài báo có hội quy thì chắc các em là
bài toán hội quy thôi.
Em khảo sát chưa?
Nếu chưa thì 1 khảo sát.
Vui và chưa của.
Nếu chưa thì bố khảo sát rồi mình đặt tên
có thêm tên app,
kết hợp với tên kỹ thuật vô thì cái tên
đề tài của mình nó hay hơn.
Rồi bây giờ tới cái game như vậy,
tới cái mục tiêu KPI đi em.
Dạ thì là ở cái bước này thì giống như
xác định cái mục tiêu của hệ thống là dự
báo lưu lượng của các phương tiện thì tụi
em sẽ cảnh báo sớm.
Nguy cơ ùn tắc và hỗ trợ và điều phối
thông qua cái dashboard thông qua cái
dashboard là đồng thời là tụi em có đưa
ra cái KPI để đánh giá hiệu quả và đội
Em cái bé này của em là giống y chang như
mấy nhóm trước rồi,
chính xác.
sao lại bay KPI thời gian chờ trung bình,
cái này cái em đang đánh vô quy trình á.
Các em nên nhớ là các em đang xây dựng hệ
thống phần mềm mà.
Hàng như quý cô nói không?
Đây là cái hiểu ý là cái KPI này là mình
ý của mình đưa ra cái KPI này là để cái
phần mềm của mình là giải quyết cho khách
hàng là làm sao để.
Để để đi để sao ta để.
Để đo chất lượng của hệ thống phần mềm
của em các em.
Cái em mình cũng đi làm rồi,
em đang đưa cái sản phẩm đây,
cái là cái dịch vụ của em và cái sản phẩm
của em là gì là hệ thống phần mềm.
Thì làm sao đo cái chất lượng hệ thống
phần mềm của em khi em bàn giao cho khách
Dạ.
hàng.
Hãy đi tìm hiểu các cái độ đo kỹ thuật
cho hệ thống phần mềm.
Và ở đây cụ thể bài toán của em là mua đồ
hồi quy để dự đoán cái lưu lượng.
Hình như ý cô nói không?
Còn ở cái thời trang mà cái em trình bày
trình bày KPI này là các em chưa có hiểu
Cao có.
cái bài toán của mình muốn làm cái gì hết
á.
Còn bay slide.
Là các phương pháp.
Đã được đề xuất trước đây cho bài toán dự
đoán lưu lượng.
Ví dụ trước đây thường người ta làm dự
đoán lưu lượng giống như là dự đoán cái
gì.
Ở đây các em khám sát kỹ thuật chưa.
Chắc chưa đúng không,
chưa thì làm đi coi cái bài toán hội quy
nè,
thường cái bài toán cơ bản là người ta
lưu tiếp tục rection.
Là nó là một cái like cơ bản,
thường mọi người so sánh đối với bài toán
dự đoán nguyên tượng.
Bài toán dự đoán hồi quy á.
Chứ đây em ghi câu đó là các em không
hiểu vấn đề.
Về nếu mình chỉnh coi lại khảo sát kỹ
thuật và coi là cái này ha.
Dạ cuộc.
Nếu nghe các em.
Mình học công nghệ thông tin thì cái mục
tiêu này cô cho các em để các em làm quen
các cái dự án công nghệ thông tin,
sản phẩm của các em đối với bài thực hành
này là phần mềm hệ thống thông tin.
Và mình phải đo lường nó trước khi mình
bàn giao cho khách hàng.
Là KPI của em là các độ đo để đo lường
cái hệ thống phần mềm đánh giá chất lượng
hệ thống phần mềm trước khi đưa cho người
ta đó,
chứ không phải đánh giá quy trình của
người ta.
Mình không kiểm soát được quy trình gì
của người ta hết đâu,
Đánh giá chất lượng.
chất lượng sản phẩm bằng dao.
Sản phẩm của em là cái gì?
Hệ thống phần mềm.
Hán phần mềm của em đó là nó có ứng dụng
model tích hợp model với ai thì đánh giá
định lượng model ai luôn.
Rồi về chuẩn là cái này nha nhóm.
Dạ.
Rồi nhấn tiếp theo.
Liêm chính.
Dạ cô đợi em xe ạ.
Nhắc lại hồi nãy cô nhắc tới nhóm trước
thì em rõ hơn 15 phút nha các em trình
Dạ hiện tại
bày tính cách theo bước.
Dạ.
Dạ, đầu tiên.
Bây giờ đồ án hay là thực hành trước đi.
Và đồ án ạ.
Ok rồi bác cả lên.
Dạ thì nhóm em là đầu tư nền tảng ứng
dụng tích hợp và nền tảng dữ liệu cho hệ
thống bán lẻ đa kênh hợp nhất FASA.
Thì sau khi khảo sát hạ tầng thì nhóm em
nhận thấy là.
Có 3 điểm giao chính thì cần phải giải
quyết đó là tồn kho ảo và thất thoát
doanh thu do động vật do độ trễ đồng bộ
chậm trễ ra quyết định kinh doanh và rủi
ro gián động vận hành.
Thì tụi em đưa ra một kết luận,
đó là các nền tảng cơ sở lớp 1,
lớp 2 và lớp 3 thì nó tương đối đã hoàn
thiện rồi. Tuy nhiên,
sự thiếu hụt trang lực cốt lõi ở lớp 4.
Và lớp 5 chính là nguyên nhân gốc rễ gây
ra tình trạng chậm dữ liệu phân mảnh và
thất thoát doanh thu thì đây là 2 lớp cần
được bổ sung và khắc phục.
Thì.
Tiếp theo,
nhóm em xin nói đến là vấn đề và rủi ro
nếu như mà không đầu tư thì.
Rủi ro tụi em có một vài nhóm chính như
là rủi ro về vận hành,
rủi ro về chiến lược.
Rủi ro về dữ liệu,
rủi ro về hạ tầng dữ liệu và rủi ro về
kiểm soát.
Thì vì sao phải đầu tư lớp vốn lớp 5 này
thì với lớp 4?
Thì đầu tư để giữ cho cái hệ thống kết
nối và trao đổi dữ liệu ổn định AI.
Những cái thành phần này sẽ hỗ trợ thống
nhất và giảm sự phụ thuộc trực tiếp đồng
thời dễ mở rộng trong tương lai.
Với lớp 5 thì.
Nó sẽ đảm bảo được tài nguyên dữ liệu
được xử lý đầy đủ và cái cụm máy chủ đó.
Nó sẽ đảm bảo là sau này ta sao có thể
phát triển thêm và không gặp vấn đề gì cả.
Về lớp 5, về phần mềm thì.
Cho.
Định hướng đến là đầu tư cho pha ra một
cái.
Cái cơ sở dữ liệu ươm cụm để mà xử lý lại
tất cả các luồng dữ liệu hiện tại hiện
tại,
dữ liệu đang phân tán và sẽ gặp rất là
nhiều độ trễ khi mà dữ liệu đổ từ nhiều
nơi về.
Và.
Cho em xin phép đi qua phần KPI.
Thì tụi em có những cái KPI để thị được
cái cách đo như sau thì cái KPI này là
tụi em lấy từ bộ từ nhà nước,
bộ khoa học và kỹ thuật.
Thì đầu tiên là đo độ trễ đồng bộ với KPI
01.
Thì mới là hiện tại nó là 15 phút và sao
dậy của tụi em sau tháng đầu tiên có thể
là bé hơn 5 phút,
tháng hai có thể là bé hơn 60 giây và
tiếp đến.
Tháng sáu có thể là bé hơn nữa.
Thì.
Công thức tính của tụi nó thì tụi em có
dẫn nguồn tham khảo ở đây dạ và mục tiêu
cuối cùng của KPI này là cập nhật tồn kho
kịp thời và đồng nhất giữa các hệ thống.
Và ngoài ra thì và đây là 4 cái KPI của
cái lớp 4 mà tụi em.
Đưa ra và cái này cũng là những KPI của.
Lớp 5,
Thì cũng giống như lớp 4 thì.
Những cái KPI này tụi em đều lấy từ bộ
khoa học và công nghệ kỹ thuật.
Thì
Mình có thể cô có thể tham khảo qua đây ạ.
Thì tụi em xin phép đến phương án kiến
trúc vào.
Thì đầu tiên là kịch bản thì tụi em có 3
kịch bản,
nhưng mà để cho nhanh gọn thì tụi em sẽ
đi đến cái sơ đồ luôn thì tụi em đề xuất.
Ở đây là sơ đồ hydrid.
Thì cái lý do để chọn cho đồ highric,
đó là về cái ưu điểm khi mà nó.
Có trọn vẹn được cái của nó,
giữ được cái ưu điểm của 2 lớp kia và nó
không bị.
Cái nhược điểm quá lớn đó là nói chung
hòa trọn vẹn giữa kiểm soát an toàn và
tính linh hoạt cao,
nó tận dụng tối đa giá trị hiện có và sau
này có thể mở rộng ra dễ hơn.
So với on ren và.
Vào lao thì về bảo mật nó sẽ không có
bằng.
Còn Harris thì mình có thể linh động.
Thì về nhược điểm thì mỗi cái đều có
nhược điểm riêng,
nhưng mà cái nhược điểm của hydrid này có
thể chấp nhận được.
Với pha ra và về chi phí thì.
Harris nó sẽ tối ưu hơn là cái thằng
ongame và cloud về lâu về dài ạ.
À, nhóm này này em.
Dạ.
Mấy cái phần phía trên thì nếu mình làm
khá ổn,
còn cái phần bản so sánh mình không có
trình bày cái kiểu này hồi nãy cô có gợi
ý cái bản so sánh rồi em,
nếu mà em đã lập bản so sánh thì mình
Dạ.
phải lập bản so sánh theo các tiêu chí
hoặc là các vấn đề theo cái nhóm đối
tượng mà các em đặt ra á.
Rồi em sẽ xem coi cái phương án kiến trúc
nào nó đạt được tất cả các tiêu chí,
kỳ vọng của mình tốt nhất để người dùng
đọc vô là người ta thấy được sự lựa chọn
luôn.
Chứ mình không có trình bày so sánh mình
không có lập bảng so sánh mình theo kiểu
Dạ.
chữ như thế này, nó không có ý nghĩa.
Dạ vậy để.
Để người ta nhìn vô nhìn được vấn đề ha.
Dạ vậy em xin phép để phần này lại nhớ em
sửa.
Em mình sửa cái phần mềm chuyển qua mà
thực hành đi.
Dạ.
Dạ về bài thực hành.
Dạ,
tên đề tài của tụi em là hệ thống dự báo
nhu cầu và tối ưu phân phối theo từng nhà
sách cho chuỗi VASA ạ.
Và bối cảnh và lý do chọn.
Thì tại vì.
Nhưng cô gọi mọi người đã biết thì nhà
sách thì nó sẽ có những cái khu vực và ở
thời điểm mùa vụ mà sách nó tăng hoặc nó
giảm thì.
Cái tụi em muốn giải quyết là giải quyết
các vấn đề như là thiếu sách tại chi
nhánh có nhu cầu cao,
tồn kho tại các chi nhánh có sức mua thấp
và chậm điều chuyển hàng giữa kho và nhà
sách chẳng hạn, vân vân.
Thì cái hệ thống của tụi em nó sẽ đưa ra
cái ơ.
Gợi ý để mà phân phối hàng.
Đúng vào cái thời điểm hoặc là cái mùa vụ
đó để giảm được cái rủi ro tồn kho và tối
ưu,
chi phí trong việc vận hành ờ khâu vận
chuyển.
Dạ,
đến với mục tiêu tổng quát thì mục tiêu
cuối cùng của tụi em của tụi em vẫn là
giảm tình trạng hết hàng cục bộ tại các
điểm bán,
kiểm soát tốt hơn lượng tồn kho chậm tay
hoặc là dư thừa.
Và nâng cao độ chính xác trong việc dự
báo nhu cầu và rút ngắn cái thời gian
quyết định đưa ra quyết định phân phối ạ.
Để cái mục tiêu cụ thể.
Thì tụi em có tóm tắt lại như sau.
Thì tụi em cũng có một vài cái KPI.
Ở đây để mà tính toán lại đưa ra cái tiêu
chí thành công của này thì đầu tiên với.
Tỉ lệ hết hàng tại điểm bán thì cái này
tụi em tham khảo từ APQC thì cái công
thức này nó được tính như sau thì nó sẽ
bằng.
Cái số lần đơn vị nhu cầu không thể đáp
ứng do không có hẹn chia cho cái tổng số
nhu cầu nhưng cho 100% thì.
Ta dẹp cuối cùng sẽ.
Cái base line có thể tính trên 12 tháng
liên tục trước khi cô like.
Các anh thì là em.
Dạ.
Cái mô đồ,
cái này nó có liên quan gì tới cái mô đồ
dự đoán cái.
Cái này của em là dự đoán lượng đúng
không?
Ơ dạ, dự đoán nhu cầu phân phối ạ.
Nhu cầu,
nhu cầu phân phối làm giống như em dự
Dạ.
đoán số lượng hàng cần có, đúng không?
Dạ đúng ạ.
Thì mình đi vô cái bài toán kỹ thuật đi
chứ cái này là cái độ đo đó,
em đang đo đó bên cái model dự đoán lượng
của đâu có ai thấy sử dụng cái đó đâu.
Cái này các em đang giống như em đang lo
cái đầu đo bên quản lý bên bên cái phần
quản trị quy trình quá chị.
Dạ vì.
Và hình như cái phần này thì nhóm em đang
nói về cái.
Cái đo khi mà dùng xong thì nó sẽ giảm
được cái nào cô nên là chắc cho nhóm em
sửa lại phần này ạ.
Mình không có đo được cái đâu được sự là
em.
Cái lúc mà em bàn giao cái hệ thống phần
mềm cho người ta đó là em bình thường đối
Dạ.
với cái hệ thống phần mềm kia bàn giao
mình chỉ đo lường kỹ thuật.
Để đánh giá giống như là đảm bảo cái hệ
thống của mình đầy đủ các chức năng mình
đã cam kết nè,
nếu hệ thống phát hành bình thường,
khi mà bàn giao á.
Thứ nhất là đủ các chức năng được cam kết
nè, đảm bảo được cái yêu cầu về.
Quy định về bảo mật an toàn thông tin và
đảm bảo quyền riêng tư nè rồi,
nếu mà cái model hệ thống của mình có ứng
dụng chức năng AI á thì mình sẽ định đánh
giá định lượng thêm cái hiệu suất hoạt
động của các chức năng AI dựa trên tập
test của mình.
Để mình đánh giá cũng như mà cái đó nó
cũng chỉ là dựa trên tập test hiện có
thôi rồi mình bàn giao cho hàng là mình
kết thúc.
Còn nếu mà thí dụ cái dự án đó là trong
trường hợp ví dụ giống như công ty có đội
ngũ phát triển.
Lâu dài á là công ty phát triển ra cái dự
án cái phòng giá phòng mềm đó xong rồi
giao cho bên bộ bộ phận của 5 công ty sử
dụng sau đó rồi có cái bộ phận lấy
feedback.
Để cho cái biên độ kỹ thuật nâng cấp cái
hệ thống có cái feedback của mình,
giống như là mình đánh giá định lượng
trước khi mà bàn giao là mình thấy nó ổn
hết rồi, giống như là mình tester á.
Thử cái hệ thống ờ nó không có lỗi gì hết
nha,
nhưng mà lúc mà build lên và đưa cho xử
xử lý trong 6 tháng thử nghiệm đầu tiên á
nó phát sinh lỗi nó lúc đó nó phát sinh
lỗi rồi mình có feedback thêm rồi mình
mới quay lại mình cải thiện.
Thì cái đó là cái dòng thứ 2 rồi.
Còn đây thí dụ ở cái dòng kỹ thuật đầu
tiên trong thuyết minh là các em đánh vô
dòng kỹ thuật đầu tiên.
Còn nếu mà có cái dòng thứ 2 luôn dự kiến
cũng có thể nêu ra nếu mà đang đặt ngữ
Dạ.
cảnh.
Mình có thể lấy cái nét tệ của người dùng.
Dạ dạ vậy em nhóm em xin phép để cái này
là nhớ em sửa ạ.
Rồi vậy, nếu mình chỉnh cái đó lại.
Dạ,
bây giờ đến phần đối tượng ạ thì cái đối
tượng áp dụng của tụi em sẽ là ban lãnh
đạo và quản lý cấp trung.
Thứ hai là bộ phận kinh doanh kho vận và
quản lý nhà sách.
Thứ 3 là nhân viên lập kế hoạch phân bổ
và điều kiện khách.
Dạ, chỉ có 3 cái phạm vi đó thôi ạ,
còn 3 cái đối tượng áp dụng đó thôi ạ. Dạ,
bây giờ đến phạm vi thực hiện thì trong
cái dự án này thì tụi em sẽ chỉ là.
Thu thập và tích hợp dữ liệu bán hàng.
Tồn kho và thông tin chi nhánh ờ xây dựng
nền tảng dữ liệu tập trung và dự báo nhu
cầu theo nhóm khách,
khu vực và thời điểm báo cáo dashboard về
doanh thu tồn kho và xu hướng tiêu thụ.
Và cảnh báo thiếu hàng và tồn kho bán
chậm và gợi ý phân bổ điều khiển khách và
cuối cùng là tích hợp kết quả dữ liệu và.
Mai cái chức năng sao hơi bị quá tập của
mình rồi đó em.
Dạ.
Cái theo cái mục tiêu tôi ban đầu là em
có làm được mấy chức năng đầu thôi em tới
dashboard là dừng rồi đó.
Dạ vậy để tụi em xóa 3 tính năng cuối ạ.
Giống như thí dụ thứ nhất là em dự đoán
được cái lưu lượng.
Thí dụ em đương nhiên các cái phần mềm
này mình có thể không thể nào mình chỉ
xây dựng không?
Nếu mình áp dụng theo quy trình đó thì
các em có thể xây dựng cái pro thai theo
rượu và mình xây dựng cái passport thống
kê.
Thu thống kê tất cả các cái chỉ số quan
trọng và trong đồng thời,
bên cạnh thống kê thì mình có tiến hành
dự báo được cái lượng sách bán hàng trong
tương lai để cho người ta kết hợp với cái
giá trị trên date bo để người ta hoạch
định ra cái chiến lược cái phòng.
Cái đối tượng mà kem sử dụng nước trên
người ta hoạch định ra chiến lược tốt hơn
thì mình có thể dễ dừng ở đó,
còn gợi ý phân bổ hay là cảnh báo trước
hoàn nó qua bài toán khác rồi em.
Thí dụ cảnh báo thiếu hàng tồn kho bán
chậm như ha, đó là cái bạn
Trong phân lớp và nó đẩy qua bài toán
khác rồi gợi ý phân bổ á là giống như là
em phải đi xây dựng cái quy trình và em
gợi ý cho các quy trình các bước thực
hiện thì nó lại thành một bài toán mới đó
lúc sau là mình đầy hơi nhiều rồi đó em.
Dạ.
Dạ vậy để nhớ em chỉnh lại cái phần này.
Dạ không giả định và.
Giống như ở phía trên,
mình nói có chút xíu ở dưới mà mình hứa
hơi bị vượt tầm là người ta thấy hơi nghi
nghi rồi đó.
Dạ
Dạ còn out of golf của tụi em là tụi em
không triển khai AI cá nhân hóa cho các
sản phẩm à khách hàng trên app và website,
đồng thời cũng tụi em cũng không xây dựng
chatbot hỗ trợ khách hàng luôn.
Không phải cái này,
mình đừng đưa theo chức năng, các em.
Ví dụ cái clip Tation của em mà em nên
dừng ở Lipitation kỹ thuật tại cái nó,
mấy cái chức năng mình không có là tại nó
đâu trong phòng bị áp dụng của mình thì
nó không phải là cái.
Giới hạn phạm vi của mình.
Dạ.
Cái giới hạn của cái của mình thường của
mình,
Dạ vậy để.
thí dụ là trong cái bài toán mình đặt ra
đó,
mình đã giải quyết được vấn đề gì về vấn
đề nào mình chưa giải quyết được.
Thì cái vấn đề kỹ thuật mình chưa giải
quyết được trong cái bài toán mình đặt ra
thì nó mới là liên minh titiss.
Của mình
À dạ, em hiểu cái câu này ạ.
Thì giống như ví dụ như em xây dựng cái
model,
Dạ.
em nói cái model của em đạt độ chính xác
cao hơn,
nhưng mà límitation thì nó chạy lâu hơn.
Và bây giờ lại nó sẽ là cái định hướng
phát triển tương lai và tôi sẽ cải tiến,
cố gắng cải tiến cái hiệu suất hoạt động
của model này giảm chi phí nhiều hơn
chẳng hạn.
Cái đó mới gọi là lý mitation của mình ha.
Dạ dạ dạ em hiểu ạ,
dạ bây giờ đến dạ xong rồi dạ em tắt xe.
Rồi cảm ơn.
Xong rồi em, xong rồi em.
Rồi cảm ơn nhưng những tiếp theo nhóm số
8.
Và cảm ơn cô ạ.
Đến 8
Bây giờ em nhấn 8 xin trình bày em Lê
Phương Nam.
Nhắc lại là 15 phút,
mỗi bước trong đồ án khoa học và thực
hành trình bản ngắn gọn hả các em?
Em thì xin trình bày về phần đồ án môn
học trước.
Giờ thực hành thì có bạn trường như sau.
Từ cái khảo sát tình trạng thì nhóm em
đang tập trung vào lớp lớp 1 thì phần hạt
que.
Học que và cái phần lớp 4 app interation.
Thì phần này thì đưa tên đề tài có thể em
là.
Ở đề xuất hiện cơ sở hạ tầng cho mát.
vấn đề.
Trên sáng.
Vấn đề vấn đề hiện tại.
Chứ chưa đúng lắm thì vấn đề hiện tại là
bây giờ đang tập trung giải quyết là giả
định thôi thì là bây giờ trong thông
thường thì cũng thường nhật á thì khoảng
18 đến 19 giờ.
Hoặc là lễ tết á thì trong cái phần.
Thu ngân thì cứ nó bị chờ quá quá lớn nên
là khách hàng họ bị khách hàng họ bị nản
trí thì họ bỏ hàng và họ không mua nữa.
Thì theo anh hoặc là vài vấn đề kết nối
thì là bên.
Có đưa ra là bên đó kiếm đoạt mã thì
phương án hội là cái điểm duy nhất 9 tiếp
xúc giữa khách hàng với lại cái điểm
thành viên và các cái.
Thì bây giờ họ sẽ bị lợi dụng trong lúc
đông người,
họ sẽ quẹt thẻ của họ hoặc là kiếm luôn
cái thẻ đó để trục lợi cá nhân.
Thì gây bức xúc cho khách hàng,
cái điểm đó thì nó sẽ không đi đến được
đến khách.
Thì nhớ em muốn là làm cái hệ thống máy
pod check out đó để.
mục tiêu.
Em đang nói bài thực hành hay bài đồ án
gì em?
bài đoán.
Đồ án thì em phải nói ra phần vi cao hơn
chứ sao lại nói vào một quy trình cụ thể.
Ừ cái này tiêu nó nó bị sai sai nó hơi
nhỏ quá.
Nghĩ là nó nói chuyện nhỏ vậy thôi.
Nãy giờ có các nhóm báo cáo rồi đó,
các em hình dung một số nhóm các bạn làm
của mẫu đó.
Các em có nghe sửa nãy giờ không?
Cái em sửa tương tự giống như các bạn,
các cái vấn đề kỹ thuật ở tầm cao hơn.
Để mình đưa xác định các lớp mình chứ nó
không phải là vô một cái quy trình cụ thể,
quy trình cụ thể là qua bài thực hành rồi.
Thì nếu mình tỉnh là cái này ha,
ví dụ giống như là nhu cầu thiếu đồng bộ
dữ liệu giữa các bên,
hoặc là thiếu bảo mật gì đó nên các bạn
đầu tư vào lớp học, cái lớp năng lực.
Và các thành phần về lớp bảo mật mà mục
tiêu trong cái phần đồ án này.
Thì em muốn làm thôi.
Thì em có dạ chắc cái phần này thì em có
lựa chọn cái mục tiêu công nghệ và đối
tượng này thì có vẻ nó switch.
Thì cái vấn đề của em phải đi theo luôn
vấn đề của em phải lớn tương ứng như vậy,
tính theo lớp á.
Vấn đề của em thủ tướng theo lớp á.
Em nên hơi thiếu, nghĩ là sửa lại là được.
Rồi các em chỉnh về cái phần đó đi kéo
xuống KPI nha.
Tin sách KPI hồi nãy là cơ sở cho nhiều
nhóm rồi, nhóm mình.
Biết mình nếu mình có làm đúng không hay
là cần chỉnh lại.
Dạ,
cũng có một phần là các cái API report
này thì em thấy các nhóm khác đều có cái
này là dựa trên slide của cô.
Nhưng mà dựa trên cái tổng thể như bạn
nói,
khoa học công nghệ thì như thế này là
chưa.
Nhưng mà bổ sung thêm để coi thử là cái
này em lấy từ slide ra có cái như valable
nè lớn.
Em nên nghe quang lại,
nên nghe cái báo cáo nãy giờ để mình rút
tự rút kinh nghiệm cho mình thêm.
KP nhắc lại KPI phải đi theo cái mục tiêu
ban đầu,
em đặt ra của đề tài và cái KPI này các
bộ đo nó đã được công bố và có tài liệu
tham khảo.
Rõ ràng để mình sử dụng lại và mình diễn
giải các cái lộ đo KPI và cách tính của
nó trong cái phần này của mình.
Chính là vậy nha.
Bài của mình phải viết nhất quán,
tôi xuống dưới chứ không phải em nói một
đường rồi mình lại sử dụng đồ đâu một nẻo.
Em thấy vấn đề.
Ngày xưa con.
Rồi thôi,
mình chỉnh cái phần này lại chỉnh là cái
phần này vai này mình còn chỉnh nhiều lắm,
em chỉnh lại hết mấy cái nội dung đó hoàn
thiện đi,
còn cái phần mà cái kịch bản sử dụng
phương pháp thì hồi nãy cô cũng sửa cho
mấy nhóm vừa rồi luôn rồi đó.
Các nhóm vừa rồi sửa rồi thì kem còn lại
video để chỉnh lại cái cách mà mình trình
bày là bản so sánh về các cái phương,
cái kiến trúc, hệ thống,
cái kiến trúc triển khai.
Kiến trúc thì cô xem giúp em lỡ,
tôi xem giúp em cái phần này thì nó có.
Không em hồi nãy ra cu đã sửa rồi,
em nhiệm vụ của các em khi nghe báo cáo,
Nhạc.
nếu mình nếu mình báo cáo sau thì các em
phải nghe cái báo cáo trước.
Và cái bản này của em nhìn vô là nó đã bị
sai trang giống như cái nhóm trước rồi.
Cái khúc tính ra và để so sánh giữa này.
Để chọn anh hiểu rồi.
Phải so sánh dựa trên các tiêu chí bình
chọn và nhìn vô là người ta biết cái nào
nó là cái phương án tối ưu nhất và người
ta đưa ra sự lựa chọn luôn.
Chứ không phải mình cái này là mấy cái
tóm tắt theo kiểu AI, nó tóm tắt,
nó mới tóm tắt theo kiểu này á,
tóm tắt kiểu này là nó chỉ tóm tắt gọn
cho em dễ đọc thôi chứ nó không có ý
nghĩa so sánh.
Ý nghĩa so sánh đưa ra sự lựa chọn.
Với cái sơ đồ này tại vì em không hiểu
nên là anh vẽ cái thằng ấy thôi chứ còn
vẽ là giống như cái bạn kia mà vẽ 5 4 gì
đó rồi đúng không cô? Có cái biểu đồ cột.
Coi video lại em.
Chứ không phải nhóm nào cô cũng phải nhắc
đi nhắc lại những vấn đề này ha.
Rồi bây giờ bạn nào bên giống mình trình
bày thực hành.
Dạ em ạ, dạ cô cho em xíu em tìm kiếm.
Rồi trưng bày thực hành đi em.
Dạ, có thấy được chưa?
Rồi em tắt vào đi.
Nhạc về phần thực hành thì tụi em sẽ lấy
tên đề tài là xây dựng hệ thống phần mềm
xử lý thanh toán máy post sale check out
cho siêu thị Lotte Mart thì về hệ thống
này sẽ là cho phép khách hàng.
Tác trực tiếp trên máy như là thanh toán,
hiển thị sản phẩm ờ quét mã QR về buộc
bối cảnh thì.
Trên bàn thông minh là cái gì em?
Dạ.
Cái của mình là ứng dụng hay xây dựng máy
tính phần mềm có ứng dụng công nghệ mới,
công nghệ mới ở đây cái em chọn công nghệ
mới gì?
Thì mấy cái chức năng mấy em nêu nãy giờ
là các chức năng cơ bản thông dụng thôi,
chưa có công nghệ mới nào cả,
hoặc là chưa có chức năng nào đặc biệt và
cái đòi hỏi công nghệ mới cả.
Dạ,
công nghệ thì tại cười em chỉ có sử dụng.
À, thanh toán với lại quét mã sản phẩm.
Đó là quy trình quản lý chức năng bình
thường em. Nếu mình nên xác định lại,
em chỗ này mà sai mấy phía sau mình có
trình bày nó cũng không có ý nghĩa nhiều.
Cái nhựa ở đây của em,
cái phần mềm thanh toán,
thí dụ ở đây em có thể đi theo hướng là
thanh toán thông minh hoặc là thanh toán
an toàn hơn.
Rồi em đi tìm hiểu cái công nghệ nào để
hỗ trợ thanh toán,
sắc giống như hồi nãy các bạn.
Các em thực hiện face study để thực hiện
giao dịch ngân hàng Á thì mình sẽ nghiên
cứu về các cái bài toán deadfest để chống
giả mạo khi mà áp dụng trong vô quy trình
thanh toán.
Để đảm bảo các quy trình toán an toàn bảo
mật hơn chẳng hạn.
Em đang chọn con trâu vô một cái bài toán
công nghệ cụ thể rồi đó.
Và mình sẽ nâng cao tính bảo mật của cái
quy trình thanh toán nhiều hơn.
Giống như cái mua đồ của em tự động thì
test được là đây là cái nó có deffect hay
không,
có đây là cái giao dịch an toàn hay là
giao dịch bất thường để đưa cảnh báo.
Chặn lại giống như ngân hàng mình,
cái này chắc bạn nào cũng có từng trải
nghiệm cái giao dịch bất thường ngân hàng
của xã hội mình.
Trước khi cho mình thực thi.
Cho cái này chắc cô cho em xin phép họp
bàn với nhóm em lại tại vì thực tế là
nhóm em chỉ sử dụng cái mô hình thanh
toán.
Tôi biết.
Nên cô mới nhìn nhóm từ đầu luôn đó,
tại lúc đầu này các em phát xác định sai
phía sau nó không có ý nghĩa nhiều nên
các nhóm thảo luận và chọn cái này đi ha.
Dạ.
Nhạc nhạc đem tặng cô.
Rồi
Vậy màu vàng vẫn giữ nha.
Nhóm tiếp theo.
Nhóm sao thêm.
Dạ, chào cô và các bạn ạ.
Sao nhóm 6 thì nhóm 1 bắt chuẩn bị nha em,
nếu mà có đây không em đã kiếm 6 được
công tiếp, nếu 1 có đây không?
Nhóm 2
Dạ có cô ơi, cái mùa có.
Rồi những sao xong tới nhóm 1 nha chuẩn
bị.
Rồi bắt đầu giống em cũng sao.
Dạ em xin phép xem màn hình em có gửi.
Ừ.
Ừm trình bày dẫn trong vòng 15 phút và
theo các bước nha em.
Dạ,
em có gửi một cái đường link về file dock
của nhóm em lên.
Nhóm thì mời các bạn xem qua,
thì em có thể trình bày tóm tắt bằng file
FTML được không cô?
Được.
Dạ.
Dạ anh đầu tiên em xin đi vào bài thực
hành thì với bài thực hành thì em xin
trình bày với cô của các bạn về hệ thống
tự động phát hiện kiện hàng hư hỏng thông
qua ứng dụng thị giác máy tính.
Với bối cảnh là giao hàng nhanh đang có
một trung tâm khai.
Khai thác khoảng 90.
000 m2 thì một bài toán đặt ra là với
chừng đó,
diện tích thì làm sao có thể nhận diện
được những cái đơn hàng bị hư hỏng do quy
trình hay là do con người?
Để mà kiểm soát được cái thất thoát cũng
như là cái vận hành nó được suôn sẻ hơn
thì.
Ở đây về chuẩn bị đầu vào thì em đang có
một cái tình trạng về dây chuyền phân
loại ở đây,
mọi người có thể xem qua là về dở hàng
quét mã chia hướng.
Nó đang có một cái lỗ hổng ở một cái bước
4 để nhìn bằng mắt thì ở đây nó không có
một cái máy móc nào có thể kiểm tra được
là cái đơn hàng này nó có bị hư hỏng hay
không và cái tỷ lệ bỏ qua nó rất là cao
nên em sẽ gắn một.
Cái ứng dụng về thị giá máy tính ở khúc
này để detect tất cả ở cái cửa ra của kho
hàng thì nó sẽ có một cái tác nhân nghe
ai được quét bằng camera để nhận diện xem
là đơn hàng đó có bị bể bị móp.
Hay là bị vô nước.
Hay là có bị rỗng ruột hay không thì sau
đó thì nó mới được kết thúc và nó đóng
lòng ra khỏi trung tâm thì.
Ở ở cái bước.
Ở một về thông tin chung thì ở đây em xin
phép bỏ qua hệ thông tin này,
mọi người có thể đọc thôi.
Về bối cảnh và lý do chọn thì nó giải
quyết được 3 cái nỗi đau cho doanh nghiệp
đó là không quy được trách nhiệm khi mà
bị thất lạc hoặc là hư hỏng hàng hóa.
Rồi kiện hàng hư hỏng thì nó sẽ gây vấn
đề về thất.
Uy tín và cũng như là đền bù,
và nó cũng ảnh hưởng tới chất lượng theo
cao và dây chuyền để cái người quản lý
cao cũng không biết được là cái.
Đơn hàng này hư hỏng là do con người hay
là do máy móc hay là do một cái nguyên
nhân khách quan nào đó để mà có thể phân
loại ra được và có thể rút kinh nghiệm
thì.
Về mục tiêu và KPI thì team em hướng tới
về KPI là chỉ số ở valable và downtime.
Nó phải luôn tuân thủ cái mục tiêu là 99,
5%.
Camera luôn luôn được hoạt động để những
cửa ra vào có thể soi được hàng,
downtime thì.
Nó tương đương với mức là 99,
9% và không được quá 200 phút trên tháng
và cái tác nhân AI đó khi mà bắt gặp một
cái đơn hàng thì cái mức độ suy luận của
nó nó phải dưới 200 ml second.
Ờm
Trong đó có những cái mô hình KPI về.
Kiểm thử thì cái tỷ lệ bao quát của nó là
phải trên 90%,
tương đương với lại 100 kiện hàng thì
phải bắt được 90.000, 90 kiện,
có thể chấp nhận sai sót ở trên 10 kiện,
tỷ lệ sai sót.
Thì nó sẽ đảm bảo được dưới 15 và cái tỷ
lệ chính xác khi mà nó đoán được cái
nguyên nhân đó thì phải trên được 90%.
Đúng rồi với cái tác nhân nghe này,
mọi người có thể hình dung là nó hoạt
động theo một cái server có gPU để xử lý
hình ảnh và khi camera có thể quét qua
được cái.
Đơn hàng đó thì nó sẽ chụp lại và con
người sẽ tự vào đánh label đánh nhãn cho
cái kiện hàng đó,
nghĩa là mình sẽ có một cái tập dữ liệu 1.
000 hình ảnh.
Để con người có thể đánh lại bồ vô và
nhận dạng những cái chuyện đó là kiện
hàng đang hư hỏng đang vô nước hoặc là
đang rỗng ruột để từ đó nó có thể có một
cái nguồn dữ liệu để.
Nó học tập để lần sau khi mà nó bắt được
một cái kiện hàn có cái hình ảnh tương
đương như vậy thì nó sẽ phân loại ra và
nó đánh nó báo hiệu lên cho mọi người
biết là cái kiện hàng này đang bị móp méo
hoặc bị rỗng ruột.
Đấy là cảnh báo lên và cái người giám sát
ca ngay chỗ đó nó có thể là.
Xử lý cái đơn hàng đó ngay ngay tại chỗ
đó trước khi mà hàng ra khỏi trung tâm để
tránh những cái rủi ro không đáng có thì.
Với đối tượng phạm vi và giả định của tụi
em ở đây,
đối tượng sẽ áp dụng cho tất nhiên là về
nhân viên vận hành rồi.
Những anh chị QC kiểm soát chất lượng,
về nhân viên chăm sóc khách hàng có thể.
Cha soát được cái hình ảnh.
Để mà nhận những cái khiếu nại của khách
hàng và trả lời một phản hồi một cách tốt
hơn và.
Hỗ trợ cho quản lý ca có thể điều phối
được chất lượng ở trung tâm phân loại.
Về giả định ở đây thì tụi em giả định là
dây chuyền đã có cái một cái tập dữ liệu
là khoảng 4.
000 ảnh và đang gắn nhãn để AI có thể gia
định được cái tình huống và bắt đầu phân
loại.
Thì.
Đó là ý tưởng về mặt các bài thực hành
của nhóm 6 ạ.
Rồi cái tượng của em cũng khá ổn,
nhưng mà cái cách định vị,
cái bài toán và cách em làm thì nó chưa
có ổn lắm. Thứ nhất,
cái bài toán của em là ở đây chỗ gia đình
của em thì em cũng nói là em xử lý ảnh
đúng không? Nhưng mà cái ở đây của em nó.
Thị giác máy tính á thì em lấy cái detect
cái hình hình ảnh,
cái video minh họa này nó là cái bài toán
xử lý video camera em camera nó là nhiều
bài toán lắm.
Tại đây có bài toán được test bài toán
hành det đối tượng này.
Bài toán cái hình đầu tiên mà gặp cái các
cái xác định giống như vẽ cái xương hay
cái người đang vận hành.
Đó là bài toán dự đoán cái hành động của
cái người đó đúng là cái này là dự đoán
cái hành động của cái người.
Nó đang làm cái gì thì cái đó là cái bài
toán khác nhau.
Nó là cái bài toán khác nhau mà nó là một
bài toán lớn.
Còn nếu mà các em dùng để gọi là mục tiêu
á.
Theo đúng cái inbox đầu vào của em chưa
có tập ảnh thôi, đã được gắn nhãn,
đúng không?
Tập ảnh gắn nhãn thì có đa lớp,
có nhiều mức độ là cái gói hàng này nó.
À bình thường hay là nó đang bị hư hỏng
một,
loại 2 loại 3 hay bị gì đó em phân loại
các cái mức độ hư hỏng ra để là các loại
nhãn thì nếu mà em làm bài toán mà với
impulse từ đầu hình ảnh này á thì mình
không nên đặt cái ngữ cảnh là.
Camera nó phát hiện thì test ra được cái
lỗi ở giai đoạn nào để mình đi?
Mà cô thấy một cái gợi ý này,
nó sẽ tốt hơn rồi.
Cái bài toán của mình nên đặt theo quy
trình giao vận luôn.
Và thí dụ tới với mỗi bút giao vận mà
truyền tải gì đó thì sẽ chụp hình.
Để xác định xác nhận ở cái giai đoạn giao
vận đó.
Hình như quý cô nói không?
Dạ.
Thí dụ là đóng hàng xong chụp hình,
cập nhật lên là cái trong quá trình giao
hàng bắt đầu tiên là sẽ người bán đi đóng
hàng xong chụp hình,
đưa lên hệ thống thì cái hệ thống sẽ quản
lý là đây là cái gói hàng sau khi đóng.
Và người hàng giao đi sau đó rồi tới cái
người,
tới cái người nhận hàng đầu tiên và tới
lấy hàng đem decor đúng không thì sẽ có
thể chụp trong một tấm hình trước khi
chụp tấm hình là.
Khi nhận được hàng và một tấm hình là khi
giao hàng tới kho.
Sau đó,
khi mà nó bắt đầu nó giao qua một cái
bước cái phe for khác,
hoặc là thông qua cái một người do vận
khác thì nó sẽ mình cũng sẽ thực hiện
tương tự.
Lúc đó mình sẽ truy vết được mình sẽ có
cái hình ảnh là history theo cái lịch sử
flow luôn.
Ở và trải qua các cái bước nào đó luôn,
và nếu mà ở cái giai đoạn nào,
hình ảnh bắt đầu,
nó có biến dạng và detect nó lỗi thì cái
người ở cái giai đoạn đó sẽ chịu trách
nhiệm.
Và em sẽ xử lý cái bài toán đó nó sẽ dễ
hơn, nằm anh lấy dữ liệu từ camera.
Cái toán như là xử lý dữ liệu từ camera
nó chuyên vô một đối nhóm đối tượng đó.
Và ở đây, thí dụ cái bài,
cái kho của mình là nó,
các cái gói hàng nó không có cái.
Đặc điểm nhận dạng giống như con người,
thí dụ có bài detect kiểu này là depack
người á để phát hiện ra thí dụ tội phạm
đang truy nã trong sân bay cái này ta hay
làm nhiều á tại vì nó có cái đặc điểm để
nhận diện.
Hoặc là hành động bất thường cũng có hành
đặc điểm riêng diện,
còn mấy gói hàng của em,
gói hàng nào cũng có hàng nào bây giờ em
thì test qua camera làm sao biết gói của
ai.
Ai đang ai đang quản lý mà gói hàng
thường nếu mà cách mình phải xử lý trên
nhất là từ cái người chụp trong cái quá
trình vận đơn của.
Của mình quản lý đó thì với lại nó sẽ
khớp với đúng cái hợp đầu vào inbox của
em là tập ảnh.
Dạ.
Cái đó là cái gợi ý của cô chứ nếu mà em
bước đầu em kéo lên bước đầu thì em nói
là em lấy cái dữ liệu từ các camera đúng
không?
Dạ, đúng rồi cô.
Camera mình không có chạy cái này được
camera mà mấy cái hàng chất đóng đóng
kiểu này nó không có ti.
Thì ít ý tưởng bên em là camera ở cái
luồng mà xuất hàng phải nhập hàng á cô,
chắc chắn nó sẽ có một cái camera nó chỉ
vào ngay cái luồng hàng mà xuất hàng phải
nhập hàng.
Thì đó,
nhưng mà nếu mà cái camera của em làm
camera thì cái in bước đầu vào của em
không phải là camera chứ không phải là
tập ảnh.
Còn nếu mà em làm vậy có nghĩa là em sẽ
trải qua từ camera,
em phải xếp ảnh từ cái camera chuyển từ
cam từ video thành ảnh xong rồi xử lý cái
tấm ảnh đó.
Đúng là còn ý tưởng là vậy.
Thì cái tải nó sẽ nhiều á.
Cái tải của hệ thống của em sẽ nhiều,
thí dụ mà lúc đó là em chỉ làm đúng một
Dạ.
cái camera đó đi là giả sử cái nó lúc
mình nó tới cái hàng là cái nó trả trả
qua 2 người đã sử dụng tới cái hàng đó,
một là cái người bán,
hai là cái người cái.
Cái nhân viên giao hàng.
Rồi lúc mà đưa vô camera tự nhiên thấy
hàng bị hư,
vậy bây giờ cái hàng hư đó trách nhiệm
của ai?
Camera của em đang detect nó bị giới hạn
đó em.
Còn nếu mà em muốn detect mà em đặt theo
đúng mục tiêu là coi cái mức độ hư hại
này sẽ là do ai chịu trách nhiệm,
khó phân loại ra do ai chịu trách nhiệm
đúng không?
Dạ đúng rồi.
Thì em cần phải có hình ảnh minh chứng
của những người ở từng bước bước qua thì
nó mới gọi là mới làm được cái mục tiêu
mà em đặt ra cái theo như cô gợi ý.
Bây giờ mình cũng phân trách nhiệm thì
tới mỗi làn da trách nhiệm thì có hình
ảnh luvus thôi.
Rồi mình sẽ xử lý trên ảnh lu vết đó.
Nó cũng sẽ chịu tải cái hệ thống của em,
tải nhẹ hơn.
Với chế lại một số lượng vận đơn mà trên
cái đơn hàng mà lớn,
vậy mà em chơi cái dữ liệu camera mà em
phải xử lý camera từ camera,
từ dữ liệu video rồi mà video lúc đó nhận
vô là nó nhận một loại tất cả các đơn
hàng rồi nó còn phải tách ra từng đơn,
từng đơn. Xong rồi.
Lấy cái video đó tách ra hình ảnh của cái
đơn từng đơn đi nữa thì cái chiều tải hệ
thống về sao nổi?
Nó sẽ khá là nặng.
Dạ.
Đó là cái gợi ý của cô,
em chỉnh lại cho nó hợp lý hơn.
Theo đúng cái mình làm luôn á.
Theo cái quy trình này,
trước đây cô đã từng thấy mấy dự án làm
Dạ.
nữa rồi người ta xử lý theo kiểu vậy đó
em,
nếu em muốn nhận diện trách nhiệm này sẽ
do ai thì bây giờ em phải theo sát cái
bước các bước luvert và cái hình ảnh minh
hoạ chứng theo từng bước nữa em.
Tùy vào cái ảnh đó khi người ta chụp vô
đó mà thí dụ có đưa ra cảnh báo mà mình
cũng phải có cái nhân viên đó mới được
cảnh báo có nhân viên kiểm tra lại trước
khi em phạt tiền cái người chịu trách
nhiệm đó chứ em cũng không có giao phó
được hoàn toàn.
Còn nếu mà em thấy ảnh từ camera.
Thì nó lại khó đi test ngược lại,
khâu quản lý hơn chứ.
Nhạc để bên nhóm anh trình điều chỉnh lại
cái phần inbox này.
Rồi chuyển qua đồ án đi em,
cái đó chỉnh là cái đó,
Dạ.
em định hình lại cái đó là ổn rồi.
Còn cái kia cũng được rồi.
Dạ thì về phần đồ Hán thì để cho mạch lạc
với phần thực hành,
bên em làm cái đồ án môn học là đề xuất
dự án đầu tư về hạ tầng thị giác máy tính
và kết hợp với nền tảng lưu trữ.
Dữ liệu,
hình ảnh tại trung tâm kéo hàng hóa thì
lớp năng lực tụi em dự kiến đầu tư.
Nó sẽ ở lớp 1 và lớp 5,
em xin chuyển qua cái file FTML một xíu.
Dạ về bối cảnh thì lúc nãy bà ở bài thực
hành thì bên em sử dụng chung một cái bối
cảnh và cái lớp đầu tư này tụi em sẽ đầu
tư ở lớp 1 và lớp 5,
cụ thể là bên em sẽ đầu tư về một số
lượng lớn camera.
Để bù vào những cái gốc gốc chết,
gốc khuất mà ở trong trung tâm khai thác
còn bị thiếu và thêm 2 server để xử lý về
việc xử lý thị giác máy tính.
Và với cái lưu trữ 2 tuần thì bên em sẽ
có.
Các quản trị dữ liệu và chia sẻ ở lớp 5
để có thể từ một trung tâm khai thác thì
sau khi mà được AI trend một cái số lượng
lớn,
một cái tập ảnh để mà có thể phân loại
được hàng hóa rồi thì bắt đầu sẽ có một
cái nơi để lưu trữ và chia sẻ lại những
trung tâm khai thác.
Khác để từ đó chỉ là một cái nguồn dữ
liệu chung của công ty để xử lý những cái
kiện hàng nó phức tạp hơn và ước tính cái
chi phí đầu tư này khoảng trong vòng 5
năm thì khoảng đâu đó 26 tỷ và tụi em có
3 phương án.
Thì.
Về cái.
Cái phần em nói sơ xíu về cái lớp 1 về
tính toán và kết nối thì tụi em có đầu tư
cái máy chủ về.
Đi nhanh em, mình còn 2 nhớt nữa.
Dạ vậy cái bước không vào bước.
Tuy nhân như cái bước không là bữa trước
báo cáo rồi vô số bút bọt luôn.
Ở cái bước một này thì tụi em giả định
một cái giả lập một cái hiện trạng là một
cái sơ đồ luồng dữ liệu và kiện hàng nó
có qua mã vận đơn và và qua một cái hệ
thống MOMS để lưu trữ mã kiện và mốc thời
gian, nhưng nó không có được.
Một cái điểm liên kết giữa camera an ninh
và một cái hệ thống cam để mà trích xuất
dữ liệu thì mới đầu tư thêm một cái lớp
năng lực này để có thể được lưu trữ và xử
lý hình ảnh để kết nối 2 lớp này lại với
nhau.
Thì.
Đây là những cái hạ tầng dự tính để đầu
tư ở cùng với cái số tiền ở bên trên thì
rủi ro khi mà không đầu tư là gì thì khi
mà một cái kiện hàng hư hỏng á thì nó sẽ
không được.
Thu hồi bồi hoàng hoặc giao lại cho người
ta làm thất thoát tuyệt về tiền bạc và
nhân viên nhân công cũng bị tổn thất do
cái kiện hàng đó khi bị thu hồi hoàn trả
thì tiền hoa hồng hoặc là tiền.
Ờ nhân công ở trên cái đơn hàng,
nó cũng không được thu hồi và khi một cái
camera hoặc một cái đầu ghi nó không có
một cái tác nhân để lưu trữ lại thì cũng
làm mất về cái dữ liệu ảnh để mà chứng
minh cái kiện hàng đó.
Nó có được.
Ở qua một cái luân chuyển nó không có bị
gian lận hay không thì.
À nếu như mà về những cái thiệt hại này
thì bên em giả lập một cái khoảng thất
thoát nào đó khoảng 8,3 tỷ một năm ở.
Còn về các mục tiêu và KPI thì mục tiêu
và KPI nó sẽ cũng sẽ tương tự với lại cái
phần thực hành mà hồi nãy em có mới trình
bày thì nó cũng sẽ quanh quẩn ở những cái
tỷ lệ uptime downtime về cái tỷ lệ bao
phủ về cái.
Letency,
mức độ phản hồi của hệ thống và cái chất
lượng của cái mô hình nó có đạt được cái
tỷ lệ chính xác bao nhiêu phần trăm?
Và
Đây là cái phần bước 4 là đầu tư và 3 dự
án thì ở đây tụi em đang có 3 phương án
là về local trong kho là on-rame,
về hybrid và về cloudfus.
Tụi em chọn về cái phương án là habrid vì
do là.
GPU nó phải gần camera để gần nhất có thể
để có thể xử lý được hình ảnh,
nhưng mà khi đã đạt được một cái dữ liệu
của một cái dữ liệu mà có thể chia sẻ
được rồi thì lúc đó cái dữ liệu đó phải
được đặt ở một nơi nào đó tập trung.
Để mà những cái trung tâm khai thác khác
có thể là họ tận dụng được nên là tụi em
quyết định là chọn mô hình hybrid nên là
GPU và AI thị giác máy tính có thể nằm
tại kho để xử lý dữ liệu.
Nhưng sau khi xử lý dữ liệu xong rồi.
Thì cái dữ liệu đó sẽ được up lên lao và
từ cái cloud đó có thể cho những cái
trung tâm cái khác khác để mà họ móc nối
vô để họ vận hành thì.
Đây là 5 cái lý do để mà vì sao để chọn
hybrid tuân thủ dữ liệu, độ trễ,
năng lực huấn luyện và chia sẻ dữ liệu.
Và năng lực đội đội ngũ có thể vận hành
một cách trơn tru,
ổn định nhất thì cuối cùng hyrid nó là
một cái phương án khả thi nhất,
đó là về đồ án.
Của nhóm 6 ạ.
Đoán thì cái này cũng được,
nhưng mà nếu mà mình có thể lập thành cái
bảng đánh giá được,
chép định lượng để người ta thích trên
cũng được,
hoặc là các em làm cái này cũng được,
nhưng mà chữ hơi dễ.
Nếu cô nghĩ đến mà các em muốn cái chỗ
này mà cải thiện tốt hơn thì em có lập ra
các bản tiêu chí và cái hyrid của mình là
cái mà đạt được đầy đủ hết các tiêu chí
kỳ vọng của dự án.
Để cho người dùng dễ lựa chọn nhanh hơn.
Nh.
Biết các bạn tiêu chí ký hiệu mà đúng
không?
Dạ em cái đó tụi em cũng có làm ở đây
nhưng mà cái bạn đó nó tại vì do giả lập
á cô nên là chưa có một cái nguồn yêu cầu
nào rõ ràng nên là cũng không biết lập
tiêu chí như thế nào.
Em giả lập thì cái giả lập của em là em
đã giả lập rất có điều kiện,
tiêu chí mà em muốn đạt tới luôn mà giả
lập nó các vấn đề đang cần giải quyết thì
nó khi mà em đã tạo lập rồi thì em sử
dụng nó luôn.
Nh.
Nó trở thành mục tiêu để mình giải quyết
mà.
Em hình dung không giả lập xong rồi thì
nó ra thành ngữ cảnh,
ứng dụng của các em và ngữ cảnh viết bài
của em luôn rồi,
thế sao nó lại nó không còn cơ sở.
À, vậy em hiểu rồi, vậy đây,
lần sau em bỏ một cái tiêu chí cụ thể vô
luôn.
Ừ,
các thí dụ cái ngữ cảnh đặt ra mình một
ngữ cảnh của mình đang gặp vấn đề gì?
Công ty đang gặp vấn đề gì là mình đặt ra
và dễ giải quyết cái vấn đề đó rồi thì
chúng ta cần có cái mục tiêu và các cái
tiêu chí cần phải đạt được để giải quyết
cái vấn đề trên.
Thì các em cần phải xác định ngay từ ban
đầu mà mình biết rõ thì tới khúc các tiêu
chí của mình mà mình viết theo kiểu ro
sức và đầy đủ,
thống nhất từ trên xuống dưới thì khi mà
người ta đọc từ trên xuống dưới,
người ta sẽ dễ follow theo cái bài em
viết và người ta nhìn cái bảng đánh giá
của em cũng nhanh.
Dạ.
Nhà em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi đều có thể chỉnh thì chỉnh thêm cái
đó.
Rồi nhóm tiếp theo nhóm số 1.
Nếu số 2
Nếu sai có đang không em?
Nhóm 1 đâu.
Giờ con coi đợi xíu để bạn kia xem màn
hình cho cô.
Còn giống nhóm 2 có đây ai ở đây không em?
Ca vậy.
Rồi nhóm mai không có,
thì nhóm 1 báo cáo đi 15 phút cho theo
cái tính năng theo các bước ở đồ án và
thực hành nha các em.
Là bắt đầu để kem.
Dạ dạ rồi dạ rồi ok chị.
À bây giờ em Tân Sơn,
em xin đại diện cho nhóm số 1 để em
thuyết trình hôm nay nha cô.
Về giống tụi em thì phần về giá của em
thì gồm có 4 mục chính thì về mục đầu
tiên thì tụi em về sẽ là tóm tắt điều
hành,
thì chủ yếu là tụi em về tụi em tìm hiểu
về công ty IoT linh là cái gì?
Chủ lực sẽ sản phẩm chủ lực của sản phẩm
chủ lực của công ty là mã 4D và nó là một
cái nền tảng bản đồ 2D, 3D,
4D là thuần việt,
theo hệ sinh hệ thống của data gi động.
Thì hiện tại là tụi em đã tìm hiểu ra
nhóm đã khảo sát được là 5 nhóm đã khảo
sát 5 nhóm hạ tầng là computer.
Và ở of of flatform và scurity cộng với
identity thì sau khi mà tụi em rà soát
xong rồi thì tụi em nhận định là tụi em
tính focus vào 2 nhóm chính cần được ưu
tiên là tụi em lựa chọn.
Về là offlatform và scurity và và
adentity thì về có về tụi em thì có 3 lý
do chính thì tụi em chọn này là tụi em
lại là một hệ thống,
đó là một hệ thống đạo đức mà nó nhiều hệ
thống.
Không khác cộng lại phụ thuộc vào nó nên
năng lực giám sát và vận hành phải phải
đủ vững còn hai là về IoT linh thì nó có
nhu cầu về tuyển dụng,
về deep of và inprastors của nó rất rõ
ràng.
Nhưng lại nhưng lại nó chưa công bố về
năng lực.
Và bảo bảo mật và tương xứng với nó.
Từ đó,
nhóm nhóm em mới đề xuất đầu tư kết hợp
về Opplastform và Scurity,
còn Midity theo mô hình Hiber,
một phần là một phần là dùng dịch vụ SAS
cho khối vận hành và để triển khai nhanh
ạ.
Quay tới đó, uống rồi.
Bây giờ tới KPI trước là mới coi tới cái
Thì.
phương án kiến trúc em.
KPI là các em có tìm hiểu các KPI nào rồi?
KPI hả cô, đợi để từ bằng bạn đi xuống.
Và đây thì về tụi em,
về 13 thì tụi em có tìm hiểu về KPA thì
về từ những cái vấn đề mà vừa nêu trước
đó thì nhóm em đặt ra mục tiêu là do
trạng thái.
Và tương lai là thu to be là xây dựng môi
trường và vận hành tập trung và có khả
năng quan sát và bảo mật và phản ứng sự
cố và một cách chủ động hơn.
Nền tảng là sự kết hợp của Opplastform và
Scurity và Identity.
Sung và bổ sung cho những cái ứng dụng AI
và ML để phát.
Rồi có biết là em.
Ờ mình báo cáo sớm,
gần cuối rồi phải biết phong cách báo cáo
chứ em.
Dạ dạ.
Bây giờ thứ nhất là cái nhóm KPI của các
em bổ sung cái bài này mình đang dán để
vô cho tặng có cho cái định dạng gì hết,
không có để kiểu này nha.
Giờ.
Ở mấy cái độ đo bổ sung cái tài liệu tham
khảo,
em truyền từ tham khảo nào và diễn giải
biết cách thức đo lường nó.
Dạ,
tụi em có để cái link dưới tham khảo ở
dưới cô.
Phải sai tài liệu tham khảo em,
mình làm học tới đây qua tới phần thứ 2
văn bằng 2 rồi.
Từ Thu Thảo,
thí dụ sử dụng đồ đo nào thì phải sai từ
tham khảo vào ngay đúng cái chỗ đó.
Dạ dạ ok cô.
Rồi đó là cái phần này và mình làm sao
cho nó khớp với cái mục tiêu mình đã đặt
ra phía trên.
Dạ dạ.
Rồi chính là cái chỗ này chỉnh lại chỗ
này đó rồi đi tiếp tới cái bạn,
cái các phương án kiến trúc triển khai.
Các em so sánh và lựa chọn các phương án
kiến trúc triển khai cơ sở lựa chọn như
thế nào?
Ở nước về phương án chỉ cao đi.
Và 14
Ở về về,
em có xuống 14 là về kiến trúc nữa hả cô?
Ừ.
Dạ thì về kiến trúc triển khai thì tụi em
có.
Nãy giờ không nghe báo cáo hả?
Dạ có nhưng mà tụi em đang sàn lại.
Và phương án thì phương án triển khai thì
tụi em có,
phương án này tụi em có on album nâng cấp
và tụi em cũng có liệt kê ra những cái ưu
Rồi bây giờ kéo kéo xuống đi,
kéo xuống bạn so sánh đi.
điểm.
Kem không có nghe báo cáo hồi nãy rồi.
Bạn so sánh không có sánh kiểu này nha.
Dạ.
Coi là video cũ về lập cách lập bản so
sánh để mình đưa ra sự lựa chọn của mình
ở đây hồi nãy nếu mình muốn chọn highbrid
đúng không?
Dạ đúng hả anh?
Thì mình phải có cái bản so sánh hợp lý
để người ta nhìn vô cái bản so sánh của
em để người ta biết,
và nó phải khớp với các mục tiêu và KPI
phía trên các tiêu chí phía trên.
Dạ vâng cô.
Để người ta nhìn vô,
người ta biết là cái phương án kiến trúc
nào là khả thi nhất,
đạt đầy đủ tất cả các tiêu chí cần thiết
và chúng ta chặn nó.
Nhưng mà không có sử dụng AI rồi tóm tắt
so sánh kiểu này,
đọc vô nó không có ý nghĩa.
Dạ dạ con.
So sánh xong rồi, cô không có nói gì hết,
không vận hành gì,
chỉ có cái bảng không thì không có ý
nghĩa gì hết á. Đã ở đây,
cô sẵn cô nhắc chung luôn. Có bảng,
có hình thì phải có giải thích,
Dạ được
có đưa loa và em nhớ là thuyết minh người
ta chỉ đọc cái thuyết minh của em thôi á.
Cho người ta quyết định luôn,
còn ở đây tại môn học nên cô cho các em
Dạ.
còn cơ hội mình đi diễn giải cái của mình
thôi.
Phải chú ý cái phần trình bày.
Rồi nhóm chỉnh cái đó ha bài thực hành.
Dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Ta qua thực hành đi.
Ở về bài thực.
Sao là hồ sơ cái đề tài của em,
hồ sơ thu thập thông tin là sao?
Dạ dạ, không vậy,
tại vì là ban đầu tụi em làm ra cái bài
thực hành rồi mà về cuối thì tự nhiên
thông tin nó bị một người bạn nào sửa về
thông tin nó cho nên là nó bị xáo trộn
lại trên tụi em mới vừa ghép lại xong.
Cho nên tụi em chưa đi,
chưa mua chữa xong ạ.
Để cho cô coi cái tên đề tài.
Để cho cô coi cái tên đề tài của em đi.
xuốngy.
S.
Cái tên này tài mà kéo xuống dưới mới
thấy hả?
Ủa không, ý là nãy em bỏ vô mà.
Thì bây giờ các em tự đọc đi,
nó không kiếm được thì nói lại,
tự nói cái tên thì tài của các em là gì?
Về đây con.
Đâu.
Để từ từ để anh em gửi cho cô sau nha.
Không em,
bây giờ không có tên đề tài thì mình muốn
trình bày tiếp được em.
Thí dụ,
cái em phải nói tên đề tài để cô nhìn vô
Ở tin và tin đề tài của em.
cô coi cái em có đúng hướng đã.
Và tên đề tài của em là xây dựng,
xây dựng hệ thống quản trị vận hành,
tập trung về quản lý,
quản lý hợp đồng và định danh truy cập hạ
tầng cho công ty IoT Linh ạ.
Việc áp dụng công nghệ mới gì ở đây ta?
Cái hệ thống vận đề của em có công nghiệp
mới gì mới, các em dự kiến áp dụng.
Và về dịch từ từ từ.
Y
Về công nghệ mới thì tụi em.
Ơi.
Tại vì chị cô cô cho em xin lại về bài
thực hành này,
em thuyết trình sao đúng không cô?
Tại vì bây giờ bài thuyết trình của em về
bài thực hành của em á,
tụi em soạn ra thì nó bị đè cái.
Cái cái cái cái gì để bạn mới sửa đó.
Rồi vậy mình chỉnh lại hả em?
Tại vì cái này con nhìn vô mấy cái độ đo
Dạ.
của các em là các em đang lẫn lộn của bài
tổ án và bài thực hành á nên mình không
có rồi. Chương trình bày đâu.
Giờ.
Tại vì tại vì là ban đầu tụi em có soạn
ra đầy đủ hết rồi,
nhưng mà tự nhiên về với tới cuối là bạn
chắc bạn nào ghép lộn vô về đồ án với
thực hành của.
Rồi mình chỉnh cái thực hành lại,
ha cho cô vẫn để các em màu vàng.
Trên.
Dạ dạ dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi nhóm tiếp theo, nhóm cuối cùng,
nhóm 4.
Nếu muốn có bạn nào đi học không?
Dạ có con.
Rồi.
Sau màn hình đi em.
Cho cô cho xíu, cô cho xíu để em mở show.
Rồi 15 phút trình bày theo các bước,
mỗi bước ngắn gọn nha em.
Bây giờ cái nào mình báo cáo đồ án trước
hay là thực hành trước.
Dạ.
Cả nhóm em xin báo cáo cái đồ án trước.
Rồi mình bắt đầu đi.
Dạ.
Phần về bước 1 thì phần khảo sát thì nhóm
em khảo sát hết 5 lớp,
nhưng mà chủ yếu là tập trung vào lớp 1
là về hạ tầng kết nối. Hiện tại,
các hạ tầng kết nối đã gần.
Đất đai và cái vi mạng.
Trình bày tương tác.
Mà tính tắt theo các phần.
Dạ.
Với bài đồ án của mình là mình trình bày
từ cái khảo sát hiện trạng thì bây giờ
của em là từ lớp một đúng không?
Rồi bây giờ nêu vấn đề rủi ro các vấn đề
rủi ro của lớp một.
Dạ.
Cũng như KPI và mục tiêu triển khai.
Dạ thôi,
con là về vấn đề rủi ro của lớp 1 thì
hiện tại là độ trễ mạng đang cao thì các
hệ thống.
Cần cấu hình thủ công nên là sẽ tốn thời
gian triển khai lâu hơn.
Dữ liệu hiện tại là phân mảnh.
Nó là lớp 5 dữ liệu hiện tại phân mảnh
các kênh.
Rác ngô thì độ trễ để đồng bộ dữ liệu thì
nó cao.
Và.
Cái này sao phía trên cái nội dung em ghi
là 5 lớp.
Dạ cái phần này.
Cái này là hình như nhóm mình chưa có làm
em,
cái này là cái em còn đang cái bài khảo
sát đi chung chung 5 lớp luôn.
Dạ,
cái phần này chắc để tụi em lọc lại chỉ
phần khảo sát này chỉ 2 lớp thôi hả cô?
Tôi nhóm em làm và tập trung.
Phải viết vô trọng tâm chứ em,
em phải viết vô trọng tâm chứ đâu phải
viết từng lớp kiểu này.
Dạ rồi.
Cái này chưa làm bài tập mà.
Dạ đấy.
Cái này coi lại hướng dẫn của cô hướng
dẫn các nhóm còn lại hồi nãy giờ để sửa
lại cái phần này nha em.
Dạ cô, dạ vậy.
Bà thực hành nằm chưa?
Tiền.
Bài thực hành tụi em có làm nhưng mà tụi
em đang bị lãnh với cái bài đội án là nó
đang xử lý cùng một bài toán bài đội án á
thì tụi em đầu tư lớp 1 chứ về nick hạ
tầng kết nối với đa.
Tiwo Health còn bài tập thực hành thì tụi
em đầu tư công nghệ xây dựng mô hình AI
để dự đoán, phân tích và dự đoán đề xuất.
Các cái về việc vận chuyển hàng hóa với
các kho đến các đơn điểm bán á cô.
Bài thực hành là hệ thống phần mềm,
nếu mà nếu cái đó của em là phần mềm thì
nó vẫn đúng.
Dạ.
À tụi em à.
Nhưng mà cô cảm giác hình như là em chưa
có làm, nãy giờ em chỉ nói ý tưởng thôi.
Các tụi em có làm nhưng mà để em xem lại
cái màn hình.
Cha đây có các phần KPI.
Cái tên đề tài khoan,
cái tên đề tài là gì,
em xác định được cái đề tài mới đúng rồi
mới bàn với cái sau.
Dạ.
Tên đề tài là xây dựng nền tảng dữ liệu
và 2 tầng kết nối phục vụ cho mình.
Cái này,
cái này có giống cái hồi nãy của em đâu.
Hồi nãy em nói là dự đoán nhu cầu,
còn cái này là ghi chữ nền tảng dữ liệu
Dạ.
mà.
Nếu mà cái bài tập hành tụi em.
Chỉ bỏ cái phần kết nối đi,
chỉ làm cho cái phần dữ liệu và cái mô
hình dự báo nhu cầu được không cô?
Hay là chỉ làm mô hình dự báo nhu cầu là
đủ cho.
Coi video lại,
cô mấy cái vấn đề em hỏi là cô đã hướng
dẫn cho tất cả các nhóm rồi,
nhóm mình nhóm cuối cùng rồi đó em.
Sao còn hỏi cô câu này?
Dạ.
Bây giờ,
cái bài thực hành của em coi là cái phần
hướng dẫn là em phải xây dựng cái hệ
thống phần mềm có ứng dụng công nghệ mới.
Đẹp, cô chờ xíu để em.
Nước là các phần phạm vi.
Cái tên của em đã sai rồi thì cái phạm vi
nó cũng đi theo cái tên của mình,
tự dựa trên cái tên em làm thôi đúng
không?
Dạ, đúng rồi cô.
Cái tên của em đã sai rồi.
Thí dụ bây giờ em muốn làm thì em xây
dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm bên mình là
công ty gì?
Và nhà hút Long Châu.
Nhà thuốc Long Châu đúng không?
Thì bây giờ,
Dạ.
thí dụ nhà thuốc Long Châu bây giờ em
muốn phục vụ cho ai?
Dạ,
cái này là phục vụ cho những người quản
trị kho và nhân viên đều điều phối các
phòng ban và quản lý nhập và xuất kho.
Thì em có thể làm tương tự ở đây có một
vài nhóm đã làm tương tự với cái đó rồi.
Là dự đoán cái lưu lượng cái dự đoán cái
số lượng sản phẩm.
Nhu cầu sản phẩm của khách hàng trong
tương lai để mình hỗ trợ cho cái
deadshboard của mình.
Cái bộ quản lý của mình.
Dạ.
Hiện tại thì phạm vi của em là như trên
màn hình.
Cái này là bài tập bài đồ án em.
Cái này là bài đồ án.
Dạ, nếu mà bạn thành,
nếu mà bạn thành thì em làm phần này là
đủ đúng không cô?
Nhỉ áp dụng mô hình AI cho nhu cầu.
Em em phải trình bày ra chứ hôm nay bác
ngồi cô độc trời.
Dạ thì tụi em sẽ xây từ cái nền tảng data
Layhealth tập trung,
thì tụi em sẽ ứng dụng các công nghệ AI
vô để phân tích từ dữ liệu đã.
Đồng bộ về thì sẽ.
Hàng đêm sẽ chạy định kỳ tính toán các
lượng hàng tồn kho và kết hợp với các
thuật toán và mô hình để điều phối.
Đưa ra các đề xuất chụp hàng,
điều phối hàng đến các điểm bán,
hiển thị cái đề xuất lên cái hệ thống
quản trị của.
Của anh, các mình sẽ ra quyết định và.
Rút ngắn cái thời gian mà ra quyết định
và đều đều vận chuyển ra quyết định để
điều chuyển hàng với các kho á cô.
Em nhớ mình đang chọn quá nhiều chức năng,
quá khả năng tạm của nhóm mình.
Nếu mà làm vậy thì em chỉ cần ở đây giới
hạn gửi của cô là các em hãy xây dựng cái
hệ thống,
hệ thống phần mềm hệ thống dashboard dành
cho bên quản lý kho.
Và bên đó trong cái dashboard hai gì chị
có cái phân tích BA thôi thì em có thể
tích hợp thêm cái ứng dụng cái dự đoán về
cái số lượng sản phẩm trong nhu cầu của
khách hàng trong tương lai để mình quản
lý, mình đưa ra cái.
Chiến lược quản lý kho tốt hơn.
Và cái đó là để cho người dùng tự đưa làm
chứ cái vụ mà đề xuất ra chiến lược rồi
đưa ra cái điều hướng phân phối luôn á là
nhóm của mình không có đi theo được tới
cái bài toán đó nổi đâu.
Đặt tên cũng đang định làm tới cái mức
gợi ý của người quản trị sẽ là người
quyết định và cái.
Không phải em ai nó không có quyết định
em cái em phải hiểu một điều,
thời điểm bây giờ ai nó chỉ dừng ở mức
gợi ý.
Tất cả các quyết định và chịu trách nhiệm
vẫn là con người chịu trách nhiệm.
Dù mình có sử dụng AI thì người chịu
trách nhiệm vẫn là cái người sử dụng.
Nên cái phần gợi ý là chắc chắn là ai nó
gợi ý rồi.
Yeah.
Còn cái gợi ý được cái gì,
gợi ý được cái em gợi ý là em dự đoán
được cái nhu cầu,
còn bây giờ em gợi ý được nguyên cái quy
trình,
phương án thực hiện thì nó là một bài
toán khó.
Mình không có áp dụng,
mình đang ôm đồm quá nhiều bài toán trong
một cái dự án phần mềm được.
Dạ vậy,
chỗ này nhóm em sẽ rút gọn lại là theo ý
của nó là chỉ phạm vi nhỏ hơn,
nhưng phạm vi như này hoạt động.
Coi video lại nha em.
Dạ dạ ok con.
Cái cô cảm giác luôn,
cô cảm giác nhớ mình cũng không hiểu,
chưa hiểu nữa đó.
Rồi coi video là cô đã sửa của các nhóm
trước.
Mình là nhóm cuối cùng rồi thì mình không
có nên sai sai làm lại mấy cái lỗi nhỏ
giống như trang như nhóm cũ mà cô đã
hướng dẫn rồi hay hỏi lại mấy cái đó nữa?
Dạ,
dạ nhóm em ghi nhận để nhóm em sửa lại.
Rồi thì nhóm mình vẫn giữ highlight màu
vàng nha.
Dạ.
Đổi kem về chính đi hát rồi buổi học mình
kết thúc ở đây nha kem.